OKAY GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
AND NOW WELCOME TO THE SECOND
HEARING WE'VE HAD OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE HEARING ON.
BETWEEN WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT. I'M SUSAN EGGMAN I'M
A CHAIR OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT AND MR GARCIA IS WITH
ME HERE TODAY IS THE CHAIR OF
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
TO WIN A WELCOME EVERYBODY THE
AUDIENCE AND WELCOME ON ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY FROM
THESE TWO TWO COMMITTEES TO COME
TOGETHER.
AND WE ALSO HAVE CENTER NIELSEN
WITH US HOME WELL THIS IS AN
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES HAS TO BE
REPEATED A BE HERE WITH US AND
WE CERTAINLY WELCOME ALL
MEMBERS.
.
AGAIN TODAY WERE GONNA FOCUS ON
THE INCIDENT IN ORVILLE.
AND TODAY'S IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR.
TO UPDATE US ON THE RECOVERY
AND MORE BROADLY THE STATE'S
EFFORT ON OVERALL DAM SAFETY.
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM ORVILLE?
HOW CAN SIMILAR INCIDENTS BE
PREVENTED?
WHAT IS THE STATE'S AGENCIES ON
THE A WATER CONTRACTORS HOWARD
THOSE THINGS WORKING TOGETHER?
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIA STAY SAFE AND AND
HAVE WATER DELIVERED DO WE HAVE
GAPS STILL ON WHAT MORE CAN WE
DO.
AND A NEW COURSES HEARINGS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY BECAUSE WE
JUST HAD THE REPORT COME OUT
FROM THE INDEPENDENT FORENSIC
TEAM.
WHO INVESTED THE HORRIBLE
INCIDENT?
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK THE LEADER
OF THAT BY JOAN FRANCE FOR BEING
HERE WITH US TODAY.
AND IT ALSO A LIKE TO SAY THAT
WE HOPE THE DIRECTOR IS DOING
WELL HE WAS CALLED AWAY ANA ON
AN EMERGENCY SO TODAY WE HAVE
CHIEF DEPUTY. AM CINDY MEISSNER
FROM.
D. W. ARE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
SO WELCOME EVERYBODY.
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE IF MR
GARCIA WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS.
FROM CRAFT I THINK WE'LL SEE THE
FIRST PANEL.
ANYBODY ELSE WHY MAKE ANY
OPENING WELCOMING MISTER
GALLAGHER FROM CRACK AYE MR
GALLAGHER REPRESENTS THAT AREA.
OMINOUS PEOPLE EVER BEFORE I
HAVE FAMILY IN THAT AREA.
WE WENT UP AND DID A TOUR A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO STOOD AT THE
BOTTOM STOOD AT THE TOP IT'S
CALIFORNIA'S PROCESS.
TWO ON THE FIRST PANEL WE HAVE
CINDY AS A SAID THAT MEANT
MESSER.
MR SHOULD MEASURE SHE'S THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES WE HAVE JOHN FRANCE
WHO'S A LEAD MEMBER OF THE
INDEPENDENT FORENSICS TEAM. AND
WE HOPPED JOLE.
WHAT DOES MY DAD REDIRECTOR OF
STATE WATER PROJECT W. ARE THANK
YOU AND WELCOME ALL OF YOU?
UP THERE AGAIN OKAY
AND I BELIEVE.
OKAY SO HOPEFULLY EVERYONE HAS A
POWER POINT PRESENTATION.
AND WILL GO THROUGH THAT JUST A
SECOND BUT MORE MATURE ONE HAS.
SO GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
CHAIRMAN IN MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THAT WERE SO
ARTICULATELY SET UP BY THE.
CHAIRWOMAN.
AGAIN JUST FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS CINDY MESSER I AM THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND I AM STANDING IN TODAY FOR
DIRECTOR.
SO I AM WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
IS JUST OFFER SOME OPENING
REMARKS AND THEN QUICKLY DO AN
OVERVIEW TO SERVE RE ORIENT
EVERYONE TO WHAT HAPPENED LAST
FEBRUARY. AND THEN RUN THROUGH
SOME OF THE ACTIONS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE STATE HAS
UNDERTAKEN IN THIS LAST ALMOST
YEAR NOW.
IN TERMS OF CONSTRUCTION
REPAIRS AND RECOVERY AND THEN
I'LL TURN THINGS OVER TO MR
FRANCE TO WALK THROUGH THE A
INDEPENDENT FRIENDS EIGHTEEN
REPORT.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY WE ARE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
SO BEAR WITH ME WHEN I READ A
LITTLE BIT FROM THE NOTES THAT I
INHERITED SALONIKA SO.
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE MAJOR FOCUS
OVER THE LAST TEN MINUTES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN THE
STATE'S EFFORT TO RECONSTRUCT.
THE LAKE OROVILLE SPILLWAYS.
COME BOTH SPILLWAYS TO ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY THROUGH THIS NOW
RAINY SEASON THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING.
AND TO CONTINUE PLANNING FOR THE
REMAINING CONSTRUCTION THAT WILL
BE HAPPENING THROUGHOUT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
I APPRECIATE IN THE DEPARTMENT
APPRECIATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THE ACTIONS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED AT ORVILLE RESERVOIR
SINCE YOUR LAST OVERSIGHT
HEARING BACK IN MANY.
DEPARTMENTS DIVISION OF SAFETY
OF DAMS AND THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE
ALSO HERE AND I KNOW THERE THE
SECOND PANEL. ON THE AGENDA TO
DISCUSS SOME OF THE CHANGES MADE
BY THIS LEGISLATURE BACK IN
JULY.
THEIR PROACTIVELY ADDRESSING
VITAL ISSUES HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
OROVILLE INCIDENT.
THESE ACTIONS BY THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED THROUGH PROVISIONS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S FOUR POINT PLAN.
THAT WAS RELEASED LAST FEBRUARY.
TO OUR TO DO THE FOLLOWING AND
I'D LIKE TO JUST RUN THROUGH
THOSE VERY QUICKLY.
SO THE ACTIONS INCLUDE A
DEDICATION OF FUNDING. TO
IMPROVE FLOOD PER PROTECTION FOR
THE STATE.
IT REQUIRES INUNDATION COURTS
OUR IT REQUIRED INUNDATION
MAPPING AND EMERGENCY ACTION
PLANNING BY DAM OWNERS.
IT ENHANCED CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING DAM SAFETY INSPECTION
PROCESS SEIZE.
AND IT SOUGHT ACTION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REGARDING
THEIR OWN DAMN INSPECTIONS THE
UPDATE OF OPERATION MANUALS FOR
THE STATE'S RESERVOIRS.
AND THE USE OF FEDERAL FUNDING
TO FACILITATE DAM REHABILITATION
EFFORTS.
YOU WILL HEAR TODAY HOW THE
SPECIFIC CHANGES TO THESE
INSPECTIONS AND TO THE MAPPING.
AND THE PLANNING EFFORTS AT
DAMAGE HAS ALREADY BEGUN TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
INDEPENDENT FORENSIC TEAMS
REPORT.
AS YOU WELL KNOW OF THE
INDEPENDENT FORENSIC TEAM WAS
TASKED WITH DETERMINING THE
LIKELY CAUSES OF THE EROSION AND
THE SUBSEQUENT DAMAGE TO THE
LAKE ORVILLE SPILLWAYS.
LAST FRIDAY THE TEAM RELEASED
ITS FINAL REPORT.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS REPORT IS
OF GREAT INTEREST TO THESE
COMMITTEES.
AND WE WILL MOVE TO THAT PART OF
THE PRESENTATION SHORTLY BUT
BEFORE THAT AS I MENTIONED I'D
LIKE TO OPEN A FEW OFFER A FEW
OPENING REMARKS IN AN OVERVIEW.
AND THEN I WILL TURN THINGS OVER
TO MR FRANCE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY ON BEHALF OF
D. W. ARE THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
INDEPENDENT FORENSIC TEAMS WORK.
AND WE TAKE THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND YOU WILL HEAR US
PROBABLY REITERATE THAT POINT
THROUGHOUT THE PRESENTE ASIANS
AND AS WE GO THROUGH THE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS.
WE AGREE WITH THEIR STATEMENT
THAT THIS IS A WAKE UP CALL FOR
THE DAM SAFETY INDUSTRY. AND WE
WILL USE THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THIS INCIDENT.
STRENGTHEN OUR OWN DAMN SAFETY
PROGRAM AND TO HELP LEAD THE WAY
AND MODERNIZING. AND CREATING AN
EVENT INNOVATIVE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS FOR THE DAM FOR DAM
SAFETY.
IN THE STATE AND BEYOND.
WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
IN THE DAM SAFETY INDUSTRY AS
WELL AS WITH ACADEMIA.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND OUTSIDE
EXPERTS TO IDENTIFY STRONGER
SCIENCE BASED STRATEGIES AND
METHODS TO EVALUATE OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN PARDEE HOMES.
THE REPORT IDENTIFIES ISSUES
WITH THE ORIGINAL DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE MAIN
SPILLWAY. AND HIGHLIGHTS THE
NEED FOR MORE IN DEPTH
EVALUATIONS OF ALL ASSOCIATED
STRUCTURES OF A DIEM FACILITY
NOT JUST THE DAM ITSELF.
ADDITIONALLY IT SHOWS THE NEED
TO DIG DEEPER INTO THE ORIGINAL
CONSTRUCTION AND GEOLOGICAL DATA
IN FUTURE REVIEWS OF DAMS AND
THEIR ASSOCIATED STRUCTURES.
FOR THESE REASONS THE DIVISION
OF SAFETY OF DATA HOMES HAS
ALREADY BEGUN THESE RE
EVALUATIONS OF SPILLWAYS THAT
ARE SIMILAR TO OR OF BILLS IN
THEIR AGE THEIR SIZE AND THEIR
DESIGN. AND WE'LL TALK A BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT LATER.
WITH THE HELP OF OUR CONTRACTOR.
AND THE OVERSIGHT FROM AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD OF
CONSULTANTS.
STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATORS
GW R. HAS SUCCESSFULLY REBUILT
THE MAIN SPILLWAY. I'M AS OF
NOVEMBER FIRST BRINGING IT TO
TODAY'S STANDARDS.
AND IN DESIGNING AND
CONSTRUCTING THE MAIN SPILLWAY.
GWR TOOK INTO CONSIDERATION THE
TWENTY FOUR POTENTIAL FAILURE
MECHANISMS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
BY THE INDEPENDENT FRIENDS
SIXTEEN BACK IN THERE MEMO FROM
OF THE MAY TIMEFRAME.
WE HAVE TAKEN THOSE INTO
CONSIDERATION. WE'VE INCLUDED.
MANY MODERN STANDARDS AND
ADDRESSED ISSUES IN THE.
CONSTRUCTION OF THE REPAIRS OF
THE MAIN SPILLWAY.
THESE.
POTENTIAL CAUSES ARE ALSO A
FOCUS OF THE DIVISION OF SAFETY
OF DAMS SPILLWAY RE EVALUATIONS.
AND WITH THAT I'M GONNA SWITCH
GEARS AND MOVE INTO THE POWER
POINT PRESENTATION ALBUM.
TRY TO KEEP US GOING ON WHICH
NUMBER SLIGHT MONSTER.
OKAY EVERYONE HAS THAT SUNROOM
IN BEHIND ME AND I'M ITS PROBLY
NOT VISIBLE BECAUSE IT'S
DIRECTLY BEHIND ME BUT WE HAVE
SOME BLOWN UP FIGURES JUST A FEW
OF THE IMAGES THAT ARE IN YOUR
POWER POINT. AND WE MAY REAP
REFERENCE THOSE IT DOWN AGAIN AS
WE GO THROUGH THE PRESENTATION.
OKAY SO MANY JUMPED TO SLIDE
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS AN OVERVIEW
OF THE LAKE OROVILLE SPILLWAYS
INCIDENT AREA. AND THIS IS JUST
QUICKLY TO REORIENT EVERYONE TO
WHAT.
THE STRUCTURES LOOK LIKE IN THE
ORIENTATION UP THERE SO VERY
QUICKLY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
IMAGE.
.
TO THE RIGHT OF OF THE PAGE IS
THE DAM ITSELF.
AND AT THE BASE OF THE DAM IS
THE HIGHEST POWER PLANT IN
CONCEDE THERE'S SMALL A GREAT
FIGURE. AND THERE'S ALSO THE
DIVERSION POOL WHICH.
COMES OUT OF THEM AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE DAM.
IF YOU MOVE OVER TO THE LEFT
SIDE OF THIS FIGURE I SHOULD
POINT OUT THERE'S THERE'S FIVE
STRUCTURES ARE MINUTE.
POINT TO THE DAM THE POWER
PLANTS THEDIVERSION PULL MOVING
OVER TO THE LEFT THE MAIN ITEM
OR GATED.
SPILLWAY WILL PROBABLY GO BACK
AND FORTH WITH TERMINOLOGY ON
THOSE TWO SAME THING MAIN
SPILLWAY.
I'M YOU CAN SEE THAT THE IMAGE
THERE AND HOW THE WATER SORT OF
FANS OUT BECAUSE THIS PHOTO WAS
TAKEN AFTER THE INCIDENT
OCCURRED.
AND THEN SHIPPED TO THE LEFT OF
THAT IS THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY
WHICH IS KIND OF. THAT YOU CAN
SEE IT'S.
SORT OF THE RED SOIL BEAR AREA
THAT'S TO THE LA JUST TO THE
LEFT OF THE MAIN SPILLWAY. SO
THIS IS THE DAM IN ALL OF THE
ASSOCIATED STRUCTURES THAT ARE
THE SUBJECT OF THE HEARING IN
OUR INFORMATION TODAY.
SO MOVING IN TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
QUICKLY AGAIN WANTED TO REMIND
EVERYONE AND SET THE STAGE AGAIN
FOR THE WEATHER. THAT WE WERE
EXPERIENCING FEBRUARY JANUARY
AND FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR. THIS
IMAGE SHOWS THE SERIES OF
ATMOSPHERIC REVERSE THAT HIT THE
WEST COAST OF NORTH AMERICA
BETWEEN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY.
AYE SHE THIS IS A LONGER STRETCH
I'M SORRY IF I CAN KEEP IT ONE
ONE SECOND IF YOU JUST GO BACK
FOR.
BUT AND AND TALK ABOUT THE
TRANSMISSION LINES I WAS
RELEASED REQUIRE THAT WHEN I WAS
OUT. A ON THE OPEN AND LOOKING
AT THE DAM.
JUST THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
HAD TO GO INTO A DON'T KNOW THAT
BUT PEOPLE I THOUGHT ABOUT ALL
THE TRANSMISSION LINES THAT WERE
OUT THERE THAT ALL HAD TO BE
MOVED.
YES ABSOLUTELY I'M SORRY I
PROBABLY SHOULD APPOINTED THAT
OUT YOU CAN BARELY SEE THEM IN
THIS IMAGE BUT YES THOSE WERE
PART OF IN. WALL TALK ABOUT
THOSE WHEN WE GET INTO SORT OF
THE BALANCING OF THE RISK WHEN
THE INCIDENT OCCURRED IN AND
THAT WAS.
I'M TOLD YOU WANNA HEAR WELL I
THINK. THAT.
SORRY AND I GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US TODAY.
I THINK YES THAT.
TOWER THAT YOU CAN SEE RIGHT TO
THE LEFT
OF THE A SPILLWAY WAS A GREAT
CONCERN AND THAT TOWER. WORKS
BACKWARDS TOWARDS.
TO.
DISC.
POWER THE TRANSMISSION LINE FOR
P. G. ANY SO THAT LINE IF WE HAD
LOST IT AT THE TIME WOULD HAVE
LOST POWER TO THE RADIO GATES.
THAT WERE ALLOWING US TO TO
RELEASE WATER AND IT WOULD HAVE.
TAKEN OUT THE POWER FOR THE
POWER PLANT WHICH WOULD HAVE
TAKEN AS MONTHS TO REBUILD THAT
POWER LINE SO TO TO ACTIONS WERE
TAKING AT THE TIME DURING THE
IMMERSING ONE IS TO RELOCATE THE
POWER LINES UP ABOVE. THE.
THE RADIO GAVE STRUCTURE SO
THAT IT'S OUT OF THE WAY AND
THEN.
ULTIMATELY REROUTED COMPLETELY
AWAY FROM THE SPILLWAY SO THAT
IT WOULD NO LONGER BE A THREAT
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY SO.
QUICKLY ON THE NEXT SLIDE
WANTED TO AGAIN POINT OUT THE
NUMBER OF ATMOSPHERIC REVERSED
THAT HIT OF THE WEST COAST LAST
WINTER. AND ESPECIALLY IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY WE
EXPERIENCED THE WETTEST ABOUT.
TWO MONTHS ON IN A. HUNDRED AND
TEN YEARS OF RECORD KEEPING FOR
THE FEATHER RIVER BASIN.
SO.
.
AS. WE WERE BALANCING INFLOWS
AND RAINFALL AND STORM EVENTS IN
THE MIDST OF ALL THIS AND YOU
WILL SEE ON THE NEXT SLIDE. WE
HAD THE INCIDENT OCCUR AT THE
MAIN SPILLWAY.
AND ONE THING ABOUT BEEF I WILL
JUST MENTION IN TERMS OF INFLOW.
RIGHT AT THE POINT OF THE TIME
OF INCIDENTS AROUND THE SIXTH OR
SEVENTH OF FEBRUARY. THE STORM
THAT WE EXPERIENCED DURING THAT
TIME FRAME EXCEEDED THE
FORECASTED AMOUNT IN THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE EXPERIENCE
SEVERAL TIMES LAST WINTER. AND
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE IT BE
AMOUNT WAS SUCCEEDED BY ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND CUBIC FEET PER
SECOND OVER THE.
AS THE MAIN SPILLWAY BEGAN TO A
ROAD SAYS WE'RE HAVING THE ISSUE
WE ARE ALSO HAVING A STORM THAT
WAS MUCH LARGER THAN WE HAD BEEN
ABLE TO PREDICT THE FORECASTING.
SO THIS NEXT SLIDE SHOWS THE.
THE INCIDENT.
AS IT BEGAN ON THE SEVENTH.
THIS WAS A POINT THAT DID OF
YOUR STOPPED FLOWS ON THE MAIN
SPILLWAY DURING THE SEVENTH TO
ASSESS THE INITIAL DAMAGE. YOU
CAN SEE BY THE PHOTO ON THE LEFT
HAND SIDE OF OF YOUR PAPER THAT
ANNA WE PUT SOME STATS IN THERE
THAT THE DAMAGE INITIALLY WAS
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FEET
WIDE.
FORTY FEET LONG AND THIRTY TO
FORTY FEET DEEP.
THE WHOLE THAT HAD BEEN CREATED.
BUT I AND I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT EVEN AS WE WERE STOPPING
FLOWS WE ARE EVALUATING THIS
INITIAL DAMAGE WE HAD D. W. ARE
EMPLOYEES IN CREWS THAT WERE
BEGINNING PLANNING FOR RECOVERY
AND REPAIRS IN THE IMMEDIATE
TIME.
AND.
ALSO BEGINNING TO THINK LONGER
TERM THROUGH THE WINTER SEASON
THE SPRING AND BEYOND.
SO.
MOVING TO THE NEXT SLIDE HOME.
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT SIDE HERE.
OH I'M SORRY I'M NOT BUT THAT'S
OKAY WE CAN JUST GO THERE AND
ALL KEEP TALKING FOR AWHILE
HERE.
THIS IS WHERE I WANTED TO POINT
OUT AND THE FOUR MAIN RISKS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAD TO BALANCE
DURING THOSE HOURS AFTER BETWEEN
FEBRUARY SEVENTH. AND THE
TWELFTH.
AS A WATER CONTINUED TO FLOW
DOWN THE DAMAGED MEAN SPILLWAY
BECAUSE WE HAD TO MANAGE
INFLOWS.
EROSION IN THE FAILURE OF THE
SHOOT ITSELF CONTINUED AT AN
ALARMING RATE EROSION WAS MOVING
UP.
UPWARDS UPHILL FASTER THAN WE
HAD ANTICIPATED INITIALLY.
THE HIGHEST RISK THAT WAS FACING
THE DEPARTMENT WAS THE CONTINUED
EROSION OF THE MAIN SPILLWAY
TOWARDS THOSE GATES.
THAT WE BELIEVE.
HOW IT MADE ITS WAY TO THE GATES
WOULD HAVE MEANT CATASTROPHIC AN
UNCONTROLLED RELEASES OF WATER?
SO THAT WAS OUR ONE OF OUR
NUMBER ONE CONCERN WAS HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THAT.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAD VAST AMOUNTS
OF CONCRETE AND DEBRIS THAT HAD.
BEEN PUSHED DOWN.
THIS BILL WAY AND WERE BEING
COLLECTED IN THE DIVERSION
POLITIC POINTED OUT
THE BOTTOM OF THE DAM.
AND THAT WAS BEGINNING TO CAUSE
A BACKUP OF WATER TOWARDS THE
HYATT POWER PLANT IN INCREASING
THE LIKELIHOOD OF FLOODING IN
THAT CRITICAL STRUCTURE.
SO WITH A BROKEN MAIN SPILLWAY
THE POWER PLANTS
AS WE.
SOUGHT AND CONTINUE TO SEE IT
BECAME INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT AS
THE ONLY OTHER WAY TO MANAGE.
WATER RELEASES OUT OF THE REST
OF WAR AND TO HAVE CONTROLLED
RELEASES.
FOR THE REMAINDER OF WINTER AND
BEYOND INTO THE SPRING SESSION.
AT THE SAME TIME DWI ARE NEEDED
TO PROTECT THE POWER LINES HAS
TOLD JUST DESCRIBED HOME TO US
WHICH WERE INSTALLED ON THE
HILLSIDE THAT WAS PARALLEL TO
THE MAIN SPILLWAY. SAME HILLSIDE
THAT WAS ERODING. WITHOUT THESE
POWER LINES AS JOE POINTED OUT
D. W. R. WOULD HAVE TEMPORARILY
LOST ITS ABILITY TO OPERATE NOT
ONLY THE POWER PLANT BUT HE
MAIN GATES AT THE TOP OF THE
SPILLWAY.
AND THIS WOULD HAVE ON HIM
TEMPORARILY COULD HAVE BEEN JUST
A FEW DAYS BUT IN THE CASE OF
THE POWER PLANT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
MONTHS.
SO TO REDUCE THE RISK TO THE
MAIN SPILLWAY THE POWER LINES IN
THE POWER PLANT DWI ARE DECIDED
TO REDUCE RELEASES FROM THE MAIN
SPILLWAY. DWS MODELING SHOW THAT
AT THESE REDUCED RELEASES THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD STILL BE ABLE
TO KEEP THE WEIGHT LAKE LEVEL AT
A SAFE.
LEVEL BELOW THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY CELL.
HOWEVER INFLOWS INCREASED AND AS
I MENTIONED BECAUSE OF THE STORM
EVENT THAT HAD COME IN AND HAD.
IT ACTUALLY HAS SEVERAL STORMS
ARE COMING ITS APART.
THEMSELVES OVER THE AREA AND THE
RINK CONTINUE TO COME TO THE
INFLOWS. CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
AND LASTED LONGER THAN WE HAD
ANTICIPATED HARM. AND.
AND LAKE LEVELS CONTINUE TO RISE
WHICH RESULTED IN THE ULTIMATE
USE OF THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY ON
FEBRUARY STARTING ON FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH.
AND SO NOW THE SUSPECTS ARE THE
SLIGHT HAD YOU GUYS TURNED TO
WAS JUST AS AN IMAGE OF THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY AS EROSION
WAS OCCURRING. THIS PHOTO TAKEN
ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH.
SO. ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH AS WE
WATCHED THE HILLSIDE BELOW THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY BEGIN TO
ERODE AND AGAIN MORE QUICKLY AT
THAN WE HAD ANTICIPATED. THIS
WAS THE POINT IN TIME THAT IN
PROVIDING INFORMATION TO THE
BUTTE COUNTY SHERIFF HER SHARE
OF COREY HONI. IT WAS DECIDED
THAT IN EVACUATION NEEDED TO
OCCUR IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC
SAFETY SO THIS WAS ON THE
TWELFTH.
EAH.
SO JUST ADD A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION AND I WAS PART OF
THE INCIDENT
COMMAND TEAM THAT WAS UP THERE
FROM THE SEVENTH AND ULTIMATELY
BECAME THE INCIDENT COMMANDER
SOON AFTER THE EVACUATION SO I
WAS THERE FROM THAT ALL THE WAY.
ALMOST TO THE END OF MARCH.
TO WE STABILIZED BUT I THINK
THOSE RISKS.
MANAGING THOSE RISKS MEANT THAT
WE DID HAVE A TEAM THAT WAS
PUTTING TOGETHER CONTINGENCIES
FOR ALL THOSE RISKS.
IN THE EVENT ANY OF THEM
HAPPENED SO WE WERE NOT ONLY
MANAGING THAT THEY WOULDN'T
HAPPEN REDUCE THE RISK BUT WE
WERE MANAGING RISK UP IF THAT
HAPPENED WILL OUR CONTINGENCY
PLANS. AND I THINK ON THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY. OUR INTENT
WAS NEVER TO USE IT.
BUT THAT WASN'T ENOUGH WE NEEDED
TO BE PREPARED IN CASE.
THINGS UNPREDICTABLE THINGS LIKE
THE WEATHER HAPPEN AND WE NEEDED
TO THAT'S WHY YOU SAW A
SCRUBBING THE HILLSIDE CLEARING
IT.
PUTTING.
SHOTCRETE OR CONCRETE ON THE
PRINTING THOSE WERE ALL
CONTINGENCY PLANNING EFFORTS.
IN THE EVENT IT HAPPENED EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS NOT AND WE WERE
HOPE WE WERE TRYING NOT TO LET
THAT
SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
ARE RISK MANAGER THAT WAS THERE
WAS TRYING TO MANAGE A CRISIS
AND NOT ONLY FOR THE IMMEDIATE
BUT. IN THE EVENT THINGS
HAPPENED.
THINKING JAW. SO I JUST WANT TO
END ON ON THIS PARTICULAR SLIDE
WAS.
BY SAYING THAT WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE THERE WERE NO LIVES
LOST.
AND THE DEPARTMENT RECOGNIZES
THAT THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT HAD TO EVACUATE THEIR HOMES
IN THAT THIS WAS A VERY
TERRIFYING EXPERIENCE FOR THEM.
AND HAVING GONE THROUGH SEVERAL
OF THE COMMUNITY MEETINGS
ESPECIALLY EARLY ON NOW I
RECOGNIZE THAT.
THIS WAS AN ORDEAL.
FOR FOLKS.
IN THE CITY OF OROVILLE THE
DOWNSTREAM COMMUNITIES BUT AGAIN
WE FEEL VERY FORTUNATE THAT
THERE WERE NO LIGHTS LOST IN IN.
THAT PARTICULAR INCIDENT SO.
QUj SO GUT NEXT SLIDEIS OF
PHOTO ON TAKEN.
TWENTY DAYS AFTER THE INCIDENT
OCCURRED AND IT'S IT'S HERE TO
ILLUSTRATE.
THE AMOUNT OF DEBRIS THAT ENDED
UP IN THE DIVERSION POOL AND HOW
IT IN LOOKING AT THIS YOU COULD.
SEE HOW WATER WOULD BEGIN TO
BACK UP BEHIND THAT IN THE POWER
PLANT WOULD BE OFF TO THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THIS PARTICULAR. PHOTO
SO I'M. AGAIN IS IS JILL
MENTIONED BALANCING RISK THERE
WERE A LOT OF FACTORS THAT WERE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT AND THIS
VOTERS JUST ILLUSTRATE THAT THE
AMOUNT OF DEBRIS THAT ENDED UP
IN THE DIVERSION PULL WAS QUITE
EXTENSIVE TWENTY DAYS AFTER THE
EVENT.
OF I'M I'M GONNA MOVE TO THE
NEXT SLIDE BECAUSE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I'D LEAVE PLENTY
OF TIME FOR MY. COLLEAGUES IN
THE TABLE TO DO THEIR
PRESENTATIONS ARE I'M ANSWER
QUESTIONS SO I'M GONNA MOVE TO
THE NEXT SLIDE WHICH IS THE
EMERGENCY RECOVERY PLAN.
AND WITH THIS SLIDE REALLY WHAT
WE WANTED TO DO WAS TO
SUMMARIZE.
EARLY ON WHAT THE KEY OBJECTIVES
WERE IN OUR EMERGENCY RECOVERY
PANNING AND THEY'RE JUST LISTED
HERE AS YOU CAN SEE INSURING
PUBLIC SAFETY IS NUMBER ONE ON
THE LIST.
AND BY DO IN DOING THAT ENSURING
THE INTEGRITY OF THE OROVILLE
DAM THE ASSOCIATED FACILITIES
pTOWARDS US LAST YEAR WE HAVE A
NOVEMBER HAD IN NOVEMBER ONE.
MILESTONE DATE TO GET THE MAIN
SPILLWAY TO A PLACE WHERE IT
COULD. TAKE FLOWS FROM THE.
FEATHER RIVER.
AT ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND CFS
THROUGH THE WINTER SEASON WE MET
THAT MILESTONE. A THAT WAS
DEFINITELY R. NUMBER ONE ONE OF
OUR NUMBER ONE.
.
NICHOLS THROUGH THIS LAST YEAR
AND A VERY ACCELERATED RATE AND
TO ACHIEVE THAT.
THE SECOND GOAL WAS TO HOPE
SORRY THAT WAS THE SECOND GOING
MERGE THEM.
AND THE LAST ONE ON HERE'S
HAVING TO DO WITH THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY SO ALSO PART OF OUR
RECOVERY PLANNING OVER THE LAST
YEAR WAS TO BUILD A SEE CAN'T
CUT OFF WALL. IN TO THE BASE AT
DOWN THE SWORD DOWN HILL A BIT
FROM THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY SILL
SO THAT.
SHOULD WE HAVE TO USE IT THAT IS
NOT THE INTENTION ON THE SEASON
BUT SHOULD THAT OCCUR THIS
CONCRETE WALL GOES DOWN INTO THE
FOUNDATION AND WOULD STOP
EROSION FROM COMING BACK UP THE
HILL SO ARE TO THOSE WORDS.
PRIMARY GOALS
AND THE NEXT SERIES OF PHOTOS
GIVE YOU A SENSEOF SOME OF THE
CONSTRUCTION THAT WENT ON OVER
THE YEAR SO THAT NEXT THREE
SLIDES IF YOU WILL. GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF OF THE TYPE OF WORK THE
SCALE OF WORK TOM.
AND THE A FIGURE.
THAT ACTUALLY ILLUSTRATES THE
MAIN SPILLWAYS AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS OF INCURRING
DEBTS WITH.
AND SO ON.
HOME DURING CONSTRUCTION I WOULD
I WANTED TO MENTION THAT ALL
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS OVER THIS
LAST YEAR WE HAVE WORKED
OBVIOUSLY VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
CONTRACTOR. BUT ALSO WITH OUR
REGULATORY ENTITIES BOTH THE
FEDERAL AND ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION.
THE DIVISION OF SAFETY OF DAMS
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
BOARD OF CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE
BEEN WITH US THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS.
LOOKING AT THE DESIGN LOOKING AT
CONSTRUCTION OFFERING US A
RECOMMENDATIONS REVIEWING THINGS
ADVICE THAT WE'VE INCORPORATED
AND BEEN. VERY CLOSELY IN
COMMUNICATION THROUGH THE WHOLE
PROCESS WE'VE ALSO COORDINATED
VERY EXTENSIVELY WITH THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS AS WE'VE
MOVED THROUGH THIS PROCESS. AND
IN FACT THROUGH.
ALL OF THESE ENTITIES WE
RECEIVED SOMEWHERE AROUND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY INDIVIDUAL
COMMENTS THAT ASSISTED US IN OUR
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION PROCESS.
OKAY AND THEN I'M GONNA JUMP TO
DISLIKE HERE WHICH IS THE SORT
OF A SERIES OF. PHOTOGRAPHS THAT
GO FROM MAY THROUGH NOVEMBER
FIRST FIRST THAT SHOW THE
PROGRESS OF CONSTRUCTION.
AS I MENTIONED MAY AND NOVEMBER
FIRST WAS A MAJOR MILESTONE AND
WE ACHIEVE THE ABILITY TO PASS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CUBIC FEET PER
SECOND OF FLOW OVER THE MAIN
SPILLWAY. THROUGH THIS WINTER
AND SPRING HOME.
SEASON.
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK TO AND I
FLEW TO THIS BUT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE AMOUNT OF DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS IT WITH THEIR CONSULTANTS IN
OUTSIDE EXPERTISE HAS. COMPLETED
THIS LAST YEAR ERECTION REALLY
IN ABOUT SIX MONTHS IS
UNPRECEDENTED THIS IS USUALLY
MORE OF A FIVE YEAR IRISH
PROCESS BETWEEN DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION. ON THOSE THAT'S
MORE NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES THIS
OBVIOUSLY WAS.
HUGE ENDEAVOR THAT TIME WE ARE
VERY HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WE MET
THE FIRST MAJOR MILESTONE. BUT
THE WORK IS NOT COMPLETE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LOOKS EVERY BIT AS
BUSY.
ON A WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO
DO IN TERMS OF GETTING THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
REPAIRS DONE A HAND FINISHING
REPAIRS NEEDED TO THE MAIN
SPILLWAY.
BECAUSE THE NEXT SLIDE IS THE A
GRAPHIC OF THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY A GIVES YOU A SENSE OF
THAT UNDERGROUND CUT OFF WALL
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. AND THE
AGAIN THE PURPOSE OF THAT IS TO
PREVENT UPHILL OR HAD CUTTING
EROSION SHOULD WE NEED TO USE
THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY THE
SEASON.
AND THEN MY LAST SLIDE IS A
QUOTE FROM THE INDEPENDENT
FORENSIC TEAM REPORTS AND I
GUESS I WOULD READ IT THOUGH
THAT WE SENSIBLE AWKWARD BUT
FOUND LITTLE. TEA AT MY LAST
POINT I SUPPOSE.
SO THE QUOTE IS THE FACT THAT
THIS INCIDENT HAPPENED TO THE
OWNER OF THE TALLEST DAM IN THE
UNITED STATES. UNDER REGULATION
OF A FEDERAL AGENCY WITH
REPEATED EVALUATION BY REPUTABLE
OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS.
IS A STATE IN A STATE WITH THE
LEADING DAM SAFETY REGULATORY
PROGRAM IS A WAKE UP CALL FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN DIEM
SAFETY.
CHALLENGING CURRENT ASSUMPTIONS
ON WHAT CONSTITUTES BEST
PRACTICE
IN OUR INDUSTRY IS OVERDUE.
AND SO WE WANTED TO TO POINT OUT
TO THIS QUOTE AGAIN WERE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK THAT
FORENSIC TEAM HAS DONE BUT I
THINK THIS TRULY IS A HOME THERE
ARE MANY LESSONS TO BE LEARNED.
FROM WHAT HAPPENED LAST FEBRUARY
THE DEPARTMENT IS TAKING.
THE FINDINGS IN THE REPORT VERY
SERIOUSLY WE HAVE
BEGIN TO MAKE CHANGES WILL TALK
ABOUT THOSE THERE ARE MORE TO
COME. BUT THE INDUSTRY AS A
WHOLE I THINK NEEDS TO WE NEED
TO COLLECTIVELY MOVE THIS
FORWARD WITH THE INFORMATION WE
HAVE AT HAND.
SO WITH THAT I THINK I AM DONE
FOR NOW ENDS DO WE WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE THINGS OVER JUST
HARD BUT YOU COULDN'T GIVE
PRESENTATIONS WELL WE'RE GONNA.
WE'LL GO TO MR OKAY RISK
MISPRINTS IT BUT I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION AND THEN I COULDN'T
WAIT TO QUESTIONS AT THE END
BUT.
YOU READ THAT LAST QUOTE SO.
ARE WE AWAKE.
WE ARE WEAK.
DIFFERENT.
BUT THANK YOU ARE GOOD MORNING
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A.
GREEN FOLDER THERE WITH.
WITH A COPY OF THE MAIN REPORT.
AS WELL AS A COPY OF.
SOME TALKING POINTS THAT I PUT
TOGETHER TO SPEAK WITH YOU THIS
MORNING. THAT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE THIS MORNING TO TALK WITH
YOU. THOUGHT IT WAS A.
AND ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS IT
WAS HONORED TO BE ASKED TO LEAD
THIS OF FORENSIC INVESTIGATION
TEAM ON SOMETHING THAT'S ARE SO
IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO.
TO CALIFORNIA AND TO THE STATE
WATER PROJECT.
BUT TO THE ARE DAM SAFETY
INDUSTRY WHICH IS UP INDUSTRY
I'VE BEEN A PART OF FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS NOW.
AND LOCAL TELL YOU THAT OUR OUR
TEAM OF SIX PEOPLE. REALLY TOOK
THIS ON.
FEELING A PROFESSIONAL DUTY TO
DO THIS AS THOROUGHLY AND
COMPLETELY UNFAIRLY AS WE COULD.
AYE AND THAT'S THE WAY WE CHOSE
TO DO TO DO OUR SCI MED AND HOPE
THAT WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING
THAT.
THE.
.
ONE THING I'VE LEARNED WORKING
MY FRIENDS OF THE COURT
ENGINEERS OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS IS IN ALL THEIR
PRESENTATIONS THEY REQUIRE THE
PRESENTERS TO GIVE THE BOTTOM
LINE UP FRONT.
SORT OF.
WHAT WHAT ARE WE REALLY LEARNED
OUT OF THIS THING AND AND I TOOK
A QUOTE OUT OF?
THE SUMMARY OF OUR REPORT.
WHICH WAS THAT THE INCIDENT WAS
CAUSED BY A LONG TERM SYSTEMIC
FAILURE. OF THE D. W. OUR
REGULATORY AND GENERAL INDUSTRY
PRACTICES AND I WAS VERY
CAREFULLY PUT TOGETHER THAT IT'S
THE IT'S THE SYSTEM AND IT'S NOT
JUST THE W. ARE IT'S ITS DEBUT
ARE THE REGULATORS. OF THE
CONSULTANTS WHO WERE WORKING IN
S. EVERYONE AND A HAND IN THIS
EVERITT A LOT OF PEOPLE TOUCH
THIS PROJECT SO.
IT INVOLVED A LOT OF PEOPLE SO
IS A FAILURE OF OF THAT.
PRACTICE TO RECOGNIZE AND
ADDRESS WHAT WERE INHERENT
SPILLWAY DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
WEAKNESSES POOR BEDROCK QUALITY.
AND TERRY DETERIORATED SERVICE
SPILLWAYS SHOOT CONDITIONS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT SORT OF
BROUGHT EVERYBODY TOUCHING IT WE
REALLY CAN'T REASONABLY BLAME A
SINGLE ORGANIZATION OR SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL. AND AIR THAT THAT
IT'S NOT. ALWAYS SATISFYING TO
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO FIND
SOMEONE OR SOME ORGANIZATION
THAT WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS.
BUT BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE
TOUCHED IT WE ALL TO SOME DEGREE
SHARE THE BLAME FOR THIS THING.
AND AS AN INDUSTRY.
IT LIKE OTHER INDUSTRIES A WE
NEED TO LEARN FROM FROM WHAT
HAPPENED IF I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY FOR
EXAMPLE EVERY TIME THERE WAS AN
AIRLINE CRASH OR IN THEIR LIGHT
INCIDENT. THEY LOOK AT IT AND
THEY LEARN AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IN THIS WE
HOPE.
WE CAN WE CAN HELP DO I WAS
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE A AN
EXCELLENT TEAM.
TO DO THIS INVESTIGATION AND I
MYSELF I I WAS THE LEADER OF THE
TEAM. AND MY BACKGROUND IS
GEOTECHNICAL ENGINEERING BUT I
HAVE A BROADER EXPERIENCE IN DAM
SAFETY AND DAM DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION.
SO AND KNOWLEDGEABLE OF
SPILLWAYS AND HYDRAULICS IN AND
OTHER THINGS ALL THE MIKE
SPECIAL EXPERTISE IS IN
GEOTECHNICAL ENGINEERING.
OR I'LL BE.
AS A DRUG STRUCTURE ENGINEER
AND OUR FINEST SERVED ON IT
ASSOCIATIONS STATE DAM SAFETY
OFFICIALS COMMITTEE THAT HAS
BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER OVER THE
LAST DECADE OR SO PROTOCOLS WERE
INVESTIGATING INCIDENTS. AND
FAILURES OF DAMS AND
PARTICULARLY FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF THE HUMAN FACTORS HELP HUMAN
ORGANIZATIONS
PLAY INTO THESE THINGS BECAUSE
IT HAS BEEN SAID BY OTHERS IN
ITS TRUE. THAT YOU CAN IDENTIFY
THE PHYSICAL CAUSES BUT THE
PHYSICAL CAUSES.
TYPICALLY HAVE NOT CREATED
THEMSELVES.
HUMANS HAVE CREATED THE
STRUCTURES THAT THE PRODUCERS
PHYSICAL CAUSES.
PETER DICKSON IS AN ENGINEERING
GEOLOGIST WHO UP HAS WORKED ALL
OVER THE WORLD ON DAMS AND AND
SPILLWAYS.
HENRY FLP HANK FALVEY IS AN
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
HYDRAULIC.
ENGINEER RETIRED FROM THE
BUREAU OF RECLAMATION AND AN
INDIVIDUAL CONSULTANT.
A STEVEN RIGBY IS CURRENTLY THE
DIRECTOR OF DAM SAFETY OF BC
HYDRO ANOTHER LARGE DAM OWNER.
WITH THAT PROJECTS NOT
DISSIMILAR TO OROVILLE AND
STEVENS.
PROSPECTIVE THAT HELPED US A
LOT WAS AN DAM SAFETY PROGRAM
AND ALSO ON THE HUMAN FACTORS
ASIDE AND IN ADDITION WE'RE
FORTUNES STEVENS IN JAIL LOGICAL
ENGINEER SO HE WAS ABLE TO.
SUPPLEMENT WHAT PETER DIXON WAS
DOING AND LASTLY. BUT NOT LEAST
JOHN TROJAN OWSKI WHO'S RETIRED
FROM PUREXML NATION AND SPENT
HIS CAREER YOUR RECLAMATION IN
HYDRAULIC STRUCTURES DESIGNED
EVALUATION. AND JOHN WAS ONE OF
THE KEY MEMBERS WHO DEVELOPED
THE BUREAU RECLAMATIONS
PROTOCOLS FOR EVALUATING
SPILLWAY FAILURE MODES AND WHAT
YOU MIGHT DO TO TO TAKE CARE OF
ISSUES THAT YOU HAVE CONCERN WAS
SPILLWAYS SO WAS. AN EXCELLENT
TEAM A LOT OF GOOD DEBATE AND
GOOD INTERACTION AND UP. AND AND
WHO WAS A WONDERFUL GROUP TO
WORK WITH. CAUGHT IN VERY
DEDICATED VERY HARD WORKING.
R. METHODOLOGY.
WE REVIEWED A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION TO REVIEW AND WE
NOTE IN THE REPORT THAT ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE VOLUME OF
INFORMATION AND THE WAY IT IS
CURRENTLY ORGANIZED. IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THERE'S SOME
PERTINENT INFORMATION THAT
ESCAPED OUR ATTENTION OR DIDN'T
COME TO OUR ATTENTION WE TRIED
THIS BEST WE COULD DO NOT LET
THAT HAPPEN BUT IT'S POSSIBLE IT
DID.
A WE DID HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF SITE VISITS AT THE TIME OUR
WORK STARTED IN APRIL. IDEA BR
WAS ACTUALLY GETTING READY TO
BEGIN THE REPAIR WORK SO.
WE'D WE DID VISIT THE SITE
RIGHT AWAY IN APRIL AND ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS OF.
PETER DIXON VISITED DURING SOME
OF THE DEMOLITION AND SOME OF
THE INVESTIGATION WORK WHERE WE
ACTUALLY WOULD. CUT OUT SOME
LARGE PIECES OF CONCRETE LIFT
THEM UP SEE WHAT WAS UNDERNEATH
THAT SEE WITH THAT CONCRETE LOOK
LIKE PETER WAS ON SITE DURING
THAT WORK.
WE INTERVIEWED A LARGE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE
PEOPLE OF OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS AYE EACH ONE
OF THEM TYPICALLY AT LEAST AN
HOUR SOME OF THEM WERE MORE THAN
AN HOUR IN SOME OF THOSE FOLKS
WE. INTERVIEWED FOR.
A MULTIPLE INTERVIEWS AND.
WE WE TRIED TO.
INTERVIEW A BROAD SPECTRUM OF
PEOPLE WE INTERVIEWED
INTERVIEWED PEOPLE WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE INCIDENT.
WE INTERVIEWED PEOPLE WHO CAME
FORWARD WITH INFORMATION THAT
THEY THOUGHT MIGHT BE USEFUL TO
US. BUT THEN WE ALSO LOOKED AT
THE ORGANIZATION OF D. W. ARE OF
BOTH TO THE ART BUT DIVISION
ENGINEERING OPERATION
MAINTENANCE AND DO SO DIEM WE.
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AND WE PICKED
PEOPLE WITHIN VARIOUS LEVELS AND
WE ASK THEM TO INTERVIEW SO WE
CAN GET A CROSS SECTION OF THAT
ORGANIZATIONS. AND ALMOST
WITHOUT EXCEPTION ANYONE WE
ASKED INTERVIEW WAS HAPPY TO
INTERVIEW AND AND COME FORWARD.
WE SUGGESTED SOME
INVESTIGATIONS ANALYSIS THE D.
W. ARE EITHER DID ITSELF OR HAD
DONE BY CONTRACTORS AND WE DID
SOME OF OUR OWN INDEPENDENT
ALICE'S.
A WE REVIEW DESIGN PRACTICES OF
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES I'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT MORE IN A MOMENT. WE
REQUESTED INFORMATION FROM THE
PUBLIC SET UP A MAILBOX
INDEPENDENT FROM D. W. ARE
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO DO OUR
WORK.
INDEPENDENT FTW R. AND IN WE DID
INDEED DO THAT.
WE DO W. ARE SUPPORTED US IN
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND
ARRANGING OF FOR INTERVIEWS AND
AND MANY ASPECTS SUPPORTED US
BUT OUR WORK WAS INDEPENDENT.
AND EVEN TO THE DEGREE THAT THE
REPORT THAT WAS RELEASED DWI R.
DID NOT SEE THAT REPORT INTO IT
WAS COMPLETED WE DID BRIEF THEM
LAST THURSDAY BUT THE REPORT
THAT WE BRIEFED THEM ON. WAS
EXACTLY THE SAME REPORT THAT WAS
LEAKED RELEASED ON FRIDAY SO
THERE WAS NO INPUT THAT REPORT
FROM FROM GW R. WAS A FULL
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION.
WE DID ALSO COMPLETE SOME
SURVEYS MDW R. WINE OF DWI R.
DAM SAFETY OF PERSONNEL PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE DAM SAFETY
PROGRAM. AND ANOTHER ONE.
BROADER CRUSTY W. ARE TRYING TO
ACQUIRE LOUBET THAT THE
ORGANIZATION A D. W. OUR IN
HOUSE IT FUNCTIONING AS AN
AGENCY IN WATER MIGHT BE ISSUES
WITHIN AT. ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DID WITH ALL OF OUR INTERVIEWS
IN THE SURVEYS IS WE ASSURED R.
UP FOLKS WE'RE TALKING TO. THAT
WE WOULD NOT PUBLICLY IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE REPORTING WE
WOULD NOT SHARE THEIR NAMES THAT
WAS CONFIDENTIAL BETWEEN THEM
AND US.
IN LESS A CORD OR SOME LEGAL
ENTITY CAME FORWARD AND
COMPELLED US.
SO WE WE WANTED THEM TO BE
FRANK AND FORTHCOMING AND WE WE
PROVIDED THAT ASSURANCE TO THEM.
I AND THEN WE HAD A NUMBER OF
WORKING SESSIONS AMONGST OUR
GROUP BECAUSE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
WHEN YOU START TO LOOK AT THIS
INFORMATION. YOU COME AWAY WITH
DIFFERENT IMPRESSIONS AND YOU
HAVE TO TALK THOSE THROUGH AND
COME TO A COMMON CONSENSUS ON
WHAT WE AS A GROUP THINK.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN SEE WHAT
HAPPENED YOU SEE SOME
INFORMATION AND YOU AB ONE
INTERPRETATION OF IT SOMEBODY
ELSE ON THE TEAM MIGHT HAVE A
DIFFERENT WHEN IT WE TALKED AT
THROUGH IN. AND CAME TO A
CONSENSUS TO I CAN TELL YOU
CONFIDENTLY THAT REPORT IS A
CONSENSUS THAT ALL SIX MEMBERS
STAND BEHIND.
.
VERY BRIEFLY FOR SOME OF THE
CONTENT OF THE REPORT OF THE
WHAT HAPPENED THIS IS THE
PHYSICS OF WHAT HAPPENED.
THIS IS THE FIFTH SLIDE IN IN
THE PACKET THAT WAS GIVEN TO
YOU.
UP WITH REGARD TO THE SERVICE
BILL WAY.
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD THIS AND
PREVIOUSLY BUT WHAT WE BELIEVE
HAPPENED THIS IS SOMEWHERE IN
THIS.
AREA OF.
BETWEEN THIRTY FOUR PLUS ZERO
ZERO AND THIRTY THREE PLUS ZERO
ZERO THAT SHOWN ON THAT FIGURE.
SOMEWHERE WITHIN THAT AREA A
SECTION OF THE CONCRETE SHOOTS
LAB WAS LIFTED UP. BY PRESSURE
WATER PRESSURE UNDERNEATH OF IT
BEING GREATER THAN THE
RESISTANCE THAT THAT SECTION OUT
AND IT COULD HAVE BEEN A SMALL
SECTION.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A COUPLE FEET
BY A COUPLE FEET IT COULD HAVE
BEEN LARGER. BUT ONCE IT LIFTED
WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN YOU HAVE A
SECTION OF SLAB THAT LIFTS INTO.
INTO HIGH FULL OF THEIR VERY
QUICKLY FLOWING WATER LIKE ELLEN
THE SHOOT THAT WATER HITS.
THAT FACE THE CONCRETE AND THE
CONCRETE STOPS THE WATER AND
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT KINETIC
ENERGY OF THE VELOCITY THE WATER
THEN GETS TURNED INTO PRESSURE.
THAT PRESSURE GROWS UNDERNEATH
THE SLAB AND JUST INCREASES THE
PRESSURE AND CONTINUES TO LIFT
IT UP.
SO IT LIFTED UP AND WHAT
HAPPENED IS WHEN IT LIFTED UP
THE FOUNDATION IN THIS AREA WAS
STRONGLY WEATHERED ROCK POP
POSSIBLY EVEN SOIL LIKE
MATERIAL.
AND AS SOON AS THAT CHUNK OF
SLAB WAS GONE IN THAT HIGH
VELOCITY FLOW HITS THAT MATERIAL
RICHES STARTS TO A ROAD. AND
THEN IT JUST GOES OUT OF CONTROL
INTO ROADS AND REMOVE SLABS AND
WE CREATED THE WHOLE THAT WE SAW
THERE SO THAT'S THAT THE PHYSICS
OF WHAT HAPPENED WE BELIEVE IN
THE SERVICE BUT WAY.
THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY EVERYONE
GOT TO WATCH THAT HAPPEN.
AND A WHAT HAPPENED THERE IS
WHEN THE WATER BEGAN TO FLOW
OVER THE.
THE HILLSIDE DOWNSTREAM OF THE
CONCRETE STRUCTURES.
IT FOUND PLACES WHERE THERE WAS
STRONGLY WEATHERED ROCK.
TO DEPP'S GREATER THAN A FEW
FEET AND IT STARTED TO A ROAD
DOES IT WAS PROBABLY AIDED BY. A
CONCENTRATIONS IN TOPOGRAPHY AND
PERHAPS SOME OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE ROADS AND
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
CONCENTRATE THAT FLOW AND
CONCENTRATE THE EROSIVE FORCES.
THOSE AREAS OF STRONGLY
WEATHERED ROCK HAPPEN TO BE
ORIENTED IN A WAY THAT WHEN IT
STARTED TO ROAD THEY BEGAN
MOVING TOWARDS THE SPILLWAY AND
AS THEY MOVE TOWARDS THIS BILL
WHEN THEY MOVE. RELATIVELY
QUICKLY AND THE.
THE DECISION TO TO EVACUATE
CERTAINLY IN OUR VIEW WAS A
PRUDENT ONE AT THAT POINT TIME
THERE WAS NO CHOICE BUT TO MAKE.
THAT DECISION IN THE THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
ARE MOVING ON TO THE THE SIX
LIED.
.
VOTES TITLED WHY THE INCIDENT
HAPPENED SERVICE SPILLWAY.
IT MIGHT ALSO BE TITLED.
COME WHY DID WE NOT EXPECT THAT
TO HAPPEN.
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS HIS INTO
THE QUESTION OF WHY DID WE NOT
KNOW AHEAD OF TIME THIS THIS IS
HAPPENING.
AND AND THE Y..
HAD IT HAPPENED.
FROM THE HUMAN ORGANIZATIONAL
SIDE IS THAT WE. AS WE DUG INTO
THIS WE FOUND IS IS HAS
CONSTRUCTED THAT SPILLWAYS
SHOOT.
WAS INCOMPATIBLE WITH ITS
FOUNDATION AND HYDRAULIC
CONDITIONS THE HYDRAULIC
CONDITIONS BEING THE VERY HIGH
VELOCITY FLOWS OF WATER. THE
FOUNDATION BEING THAT IN PLACES
RATHER THAN BEING CONSTRUCTED
ON.
A RELATIVELY SOUND ROCK WHICH
WITH THE DESIGNERS INTENT IT
ENDED UP BEING CONSTRUCTED ON
STRONGLY WEATHERED ROCK.
OVER IN PARTICULAR IN THE AREA
WHERE THE SHOOT FAILED.
THE SO THE SLAB HAD FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE THERE WERE CRACKS.
OVER TOP OF THE DRAINS UNDER THE
SLAB BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
DRAINS.
THE IN THE CONCRETE SECTION
ABOVE THE THE SLAPPING AS THE
SLABS
OCT CURED AFTER BEING PLACED
CRACKS DEVELOPED OVER THOSE THAT
DRAINS IN THOSE CRACKS EXTENDED
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE CONCRETE
SECTION DOWN TO THE DRAIN. SO
THEY ALLOWED WATER TO ENTER. IN
ADDITION THE.
THE JOINTS BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT PANELS OF THE SLAB DID
NOT HAVE WATER STOPS.
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE COMMONLY
DO TODAY SO THIS WOULD BE A
RUBBER. GASKET IF YOU LIKE
ACROSS THE JOINTS THAT WATER
COULDN'T PENETRATE SO THOSE
JOINTS WERE DID NOT HAVE THAT'S
WATER CA GOING THROUGH THE
JOINTS.
SO AS A RESULT.
WHENEVER THIS BILL WE OPERATED
THOSE UNDER DRAINS WOULD FLOW IN
THAT FLOW A LOT THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY INTENDED. TO.
TO COLLECT MINIMAL GROUNDWATER
THAT HAVE BEEN ENCOUNTERED
DURING INVESTIGATIONS BUT
INSTEAD THEY WERE COLLECTING
THIS WATER COMING THROUGH THE
CHUTE.
AND THAT WAS OBSERVED AGAIN
FIRST TIME THIS BILL WE OPERATED
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. QUESTION
WAS RAISED ABOUT IS THIS NORMAL
DISTRICT WE PLEA SAW DOCUMENT
THAT SAID.
DESIGNERS ARE LOOK AT THIS AND
WE DIDN'T SEE ANY FOLLOW UP TO
THAT THERE WAS NO INDICATION
THAT SOMEONE LOOKED AT IT SAID
YES IT'S OKAY SOMEONE LOOKED AT
ITS IT NOW TO PROBLEM IT JUST.
IT WAS SO THE ONE DOCUMENTS THAT
LOOK AT IT AND NOTHING FURTHER
AND THEN WHAT SEEMS TO HAVE
HAPPENED IS.
.
THAT.
THE CRACKS IN THE BRAIN FLOWS
BECAME NORMALIZED.
THERE'S A CONCEPT WE TALK ABOUT
IT ACTUALLY DEVELOPED FROM THE.
THE SPACE SHUTTLE CHALLENGER
DISASTER A NORMALISATION THE
DEVIANTS WHERE SPACE SHUTTLE
CHALLENGER IF YOU REMEMBER.
THERE WAS WHEN THEY WENT BACK
AND LOOKED THERE WAS A LOT OF
QUESTION ABOUT THE O. RINGS THAT
ULTIMATELY FAILED YEARS BEFORE
THAT FAILURE BUT THEY CONTINUED
TO HAVE LUNCH AFTER LAUNCH THAT
WORKED.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE O. RINGS
WERE WORKING IT WAS A. DEPARTURE
FROM WHAT WAS EXPECTED.
BECAME ACCEPTED AS NORMAL AND
ULTIMATELY LED TO THE CHALLENGER
IN THIS CASE. THESE CRACKS IN
THOSE FLOWS BECAME ACCEPTED AS
NORMAL AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL
THE EXPECTATION REPORTS THEY
NOTE THE CRACKS ARE THERE THE
DURING FLOWS IT THERE. BUT
THERE'S NO.
COMMENT OR CONCERN AS TO WHAT
WHAT THE WHAT WAS WRONG WITH
THEM.
SUBSEQUENT SECTIONS EVALUATIONS
DIDN'T IDENTIFY.
AND THEN BECAUSE IT WASN'T
IDENTIFIED AS A SERIOUS DEFECT
THE REPAIRS TENDED TO BE
RELATIVELY SHALL REPAIRS THAT
JUST RESTORED.
THE SURFACE OF THE SLAB TO A
SMOOTH UNIFORM SURFACE RATHER
THAN RECOGNIZING THAT THERE WAS
THIS INHERENT PROBLEM. A WITH
THE SLAP IN WHICH FOUNDATION TO
THE SLAB.
SO THOSE ARE THE WHY IT HAPPENED
WITH THE THE SERVICE BILL WAY.
THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
.
WHAT THE BIGGEST THING THAT WE
POINT OUT THERE IS THAT THE?
OVER TIME THE GEOLOGY OF THE
HILLSIDE REALLY BECAME MISS
UNDERSTOOD.
A WHEN WE GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THE GEOLOGY REPORTS FROM THE
DESIGN PERIOD NINETEEN SIXTY TO
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR. WE SEE
DRILL HOLE LOGS AND WE SEE A THE
TEXT IN THE REPORTS THAT
INDICATE THAT THAT HILLSIDE
ALTHOUGH IT'S THE FEEBLE LIGHT
ROCK THAT HAS A LOT OF GOOD
QUALITY ROCK. IT ALSO HAS SOME
AREAS OF DEEPER STRONGLY
WEATHERED ROCK. UP TO TEN TEN
FEET TWENTY FEET TENS OF FEET.
INTO THE ROCK OF THAT'S IN
THOSE FIRST COUPLE OF REPORTS
THAT THE REPORT THAT WAS DONE
RIGHT AFTER CONSTRUCTION THE
GEOLOGY REPORT.
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE DRILL
HOLES. AND THEN IT.
IT FURTHER.
HAS SOME STATEMENTS THAT GIVE
AN IMPRESSION THAT THE HILLSIDES
FEES AWFULLY GOOD.
AND WHAT HAPPENED OVER TIME
APPARENTLY IS THAT.
BETTER INTERPRETATION OF THE
HILLSIDE IS WHAT. COLLECTIVELY
GOT INTO THE MINDS OF OF THE
FOLKS WHO WERE MANAGING THE
PROJECT IN THE HILLSIDE WAS
THOUGHT OF THOUGHT TO BE VERY
GOOD.
A THE BEST EXAMPLES OF THAT ARE
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
THERE WAS A MEMO ON THAT WAS
WRITTEN IN RESPONSE TO QUESTIONS
THAT CAME UP DURING THE FOR
RELICENSING PROCESS.
AND THAT PRODUCE SEEMS PRETTY
STRONG LANGUAGE CHARACTERIZES
THE ROCK.
IN THE HILLSIDE DOWNSTREAM OF
THE MERCY SPILLWAY AS BEING VERY
GOOD QUALITY.
ESSENTIALLY EROSION RESISTANT
ROCK IT AT THE SAME TIME IT
INCLUDED BORE HOLES THAT WERE.
WHERE THE CREST STRUCTURE IS IN
THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY BUT NONE
THE LESS
SOME OF THOSE BORE HOLE DID
SHOW WEATHERED ROCK TO
SIGNIFICANT DEPP'S?
SO THE DATA EVEN IT TAX THE MEMO
SORT OF DID NOT WAS NOT
CONGRUENT.
WITHOUT WITH WHAT WAS DONE THAT
WAS SUBMITTED TO FOR FOR DID NOT
OBJECT TO IT.
AND IT WENT FORWARD THERE WAS
ANOTHER MEMO ISSUED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE.
THAT WAS LOOKING AT THE
QUESTION HOW MUCH MATERIAL MIGHT
A ROAD INTO THE RIVER IF THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY OPERATED.
THAT ONE.
AGAIN CONCLUDED.
REFERENCE DO THOUSAND FIVE MEMO
AND CONCLUDED. THAT IT WOULD BE
THREE TO FOUR FEET OF SOIL AND
ROCK WITH A ROAD AND THEN WE HIT
NOT A RELIABLE MATERIAL ON IT
WOULD STOP.
BUT IT IN IT ALSO INCLUDED A
TABLE OF SEVERAL OF THESE DRILL
HOLES IN WITHIN THE TABLE ARE
NUMBERED DRILL HOLES THAT SHOW.
WHETHER PROCTOR GREATER DEPTH SO
DOES TO.
DESPITE HAVING DATA WITHIN THEM
REACH A CONCLUSION THAT IS A
LITTLE HARD TO SUPPORT.
WE DO TALK IN THE REPORT A BIT
ABOUT THE RISK BALLOTS IN THE
TRADE OFFS AND JUDGMENTS DURING
THE EVENT.
AND I WANT TO STRESS AGAIN AS AS
WE SAY IN THE REPORT.
ITSELF THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
CRITICIZE THE DECISION MAKERS
I'VE AT LEAST THREE TIMES IN MY
CAREER I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN DAM
INCIDENTS IN EMERGENCIES.
AND I KNOW IT'S A SITUATION IT'S
A STRESSFUL SITUATION YOU HAVE A
LOT OF INFORMATION COMING AT YOU
FROM DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS. YOU
MAKE THE BEST JUDGMENT THAT YOU
CAN AT THE TIME AND I WAS
ACTUALLY ASK A QUESTION. ON
THIS.
THAT WOULD HE DO I KNOW FOR
CERTAIN THAT IF I WERE IN THAT
ROOM I WOULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENT DECISION TO USE THE
SPILLWAY MORE AND DON'T TAKE
LESS OF A CHANCE OF OPERATING
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY. AND I CAN'T
TELL YOU I WOULD DO THAT
BECAUSE I WASN'T IN THAT ROOM
AND YOU HAVE TO BE IN THE ROOM
TO REALLY KNOW THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO POINT OUT HERE. IS THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE INFORMATION
THERE WAS INFORMATION AVAILABLE
THAT MIGHT HAVE LED YOU TO A
REASONABLE TO A DIFFERENT
DECISION WITH A REASONABLE
BASIS.
TO THINK ABOUT THAT FOR THE
FUTURE AND HOW CAN WE PERHAPS
COMMUNICATE BETTER DURING THESE
THESE EMERGENCIES.
SO WITHOUT WHAT DID WE LEARN HOW
WE SUGGEST IN THE REPORT SOME
LESSONS TO BE LEARNED ABOUT FOR
SOME PRETTY W. ARE IN SOME FOR
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR D. W. ARE.
I'M WE BELIEVED TO BE OUR NEEDS
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON.
MATURING IT'S DAM SAFETY CULTURE
AND ORGANIZATION AND THEM CAN
IMPROVE THE PRIORITY WITHIN THE
W. ARE ON THE DAM SAFETY.
WE.
.
THE THE ORGANIZATION HAS A DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM WE ASK IN A
NUMBER OF OUR INTERVIEWS WHO IS
THE SENIOR EXECUTIVE AT GW R..
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR DAM
SAFETY AND WE WOULD GET
DIFFERENT ANSWERS SO WHEN YOU
DIFFERENT ANSWERS THAT MEANS THE
ORGANIZATIONS A WHOLE DOESN'T
EXACTLY KNOW WHO THAT INDIVIDUAL
IS? SO THERE REALLY NEEDS TO BE
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT THE
ORGANIZATION KNOWS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
AND THAT INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO BE
BRIEFED BY THE DAM SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS THE CHIEF DAM
SAFETY OFFICER ENGINEER IN THIS
CASE ON A REGULAR BASIS WHAT ARE
ISSUES WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING.
pORGANIZATION HAS ONLY SO MUCH
MONEY AND HAS TO BALANCE ITS
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES OBJECTIVES
BUT TO BE SURE THE DAM SAFETY
GETS ITS APPROPRIATE.
VOICE IN THAT DECISION WHEN
THINGS ARE BEING MADE.
BOB WE'VE FEEL THERE WAS SOME
OVER CONFIDENCE AND COMPLACENCY.
THAT THE LEGEND IS THAT.
STATE WATER PROJECT WAS WAS WAS
BUILT A BEST BEST PRACTICES AT
THE TIME.
AND.
IT'S WAS THAT THERE'S LITTLE
THAT THAT THAT STUFF IS REALLY
GOOD INFRASTRUCTURE WE DON'T
NEED TO WORRY ABOUT IT WELL. NAY
WE NEED TO BE A BIT MORE
CRITICAL THAT MORE QUESTIONING
OF WORRY ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
WE THINK THEY'D SOME NEED TO
ADDRESS INSULARITY IN THE
ORGANIZATION
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE W. ARE
SPEND THEIR ENTIRE CAREERS
WITHIN ONE ORGANIZATION AND
THAT'S NOT FUNDAMENTALLY PROBLEM
THERE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
DO THAT TOO. BUT YOU NEED TO
REACH OUT AND LEARN FROM WHAT
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS IN YOUR
BUSINESS OR DOING.
AND CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
CREATES A BIT OF A CHALLENGE
WITH THAT FOR APPROVALS TO GO
OUT OF STATE FOR TRAINING AND.
AND CONFERENCES WHERE THAT
INFORMATION EXCHANGES SO.
IT PERHAPS LOOK TO YOU TO ARE
THERE WAYS THAT THERE COULD BE
RELIEF FOR THE FOR DWI TO BE
ABLE DO THAT MORE EASILY. AND
THEN DELIVERY ARE COULD ALSO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF DISTANCE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES IN
PERHAPS BRINGING TRAINING IN THE
STATES WOULD REACH OUT AND LEARN
MORE WITH OUR BUSINESS IS DOING.
DWI NEEDS TO WORK TO BUILD A
APPROPRIATE SIZE COMPOSITION
EXPERTISE OF TECHNICAL STAFF
INVOLVED IN DAM SAFETY. AND DAM
ENGINEERING AND AGAIN THAT MAY
BE SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN HELP
WITH BECAUSE.
BUT WE HEARD A LOT THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF CONSTRAINTS ON D.
W. ARE HIRING NUMBERS OF
POSITIONS. AND AN ABILITY TO
ELEVATE PEOPLE TO SENIOR
POSITIONS AS TECHNICAL EXPERTS
NOT AS MANAGERS.
AND SOME HELP WITH THAT WITH
WITH THOSE BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESSES WOULD BE GOOD.
AND THEN ALSO ON EMPTY
INFORMATION MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
COULD BE IMPROVED WEEKS WE HAD
STRUGGLED WITH FINDING
INFORMATION AND AND IF. DATA BR
COULD REALLY TAKE ON HOW CAN WE
HAVE A STATE OF THE PRACTICE.
INFORMATION MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
FOR OUR DAM SAFETY INFORMATION.
OUR INDUSTRY ALSO HAS A LOT OF
LESSONS TO LEARN.
ONE BEING.
THE IMPORTANCE BECAUSE DWI R.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE TO
D. W. ARE IF I WERE GOING TO
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF OTHER OR A
DANCE TONY ORGANIZATIONS I
PROBABLY MAKE THE SAME
RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S NOT THE D. W. OURS AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE PACK THERE RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE THERE A LOT OF
THEM. THERE LIKE THAT THERE ARE
SOME THAT ARE BETTER BUT THEY'RE
A LOT THERE RIGHT THERE WITH
THEM.
AND AND PART OF THAT IS THIS TOP
DOWN DAM SAFETY CULTURE THAT I
MENTIONED REALLY HAVE A SENIOR
EXECUTIVE RESPONSIBLE HAVE HIM.
GET THE PROPERTY INFORMATION.
OF PHYSICAL INSPECTIONS ARE DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM IN THE UNITED
STATES IS IN LARGE PART DRIVEN
BY GOING OUT ANNUALLY IN LOOKING
AT THAT THE DAM AND SEEING WE
SEE ANY ISSUES.
THE ISSUES HERE WERE UNDER THE
SLAB AND ONCE YOU HAVE DECIDED
THAT.
THE CRACKS IN THE DRAIN FLOWS
WERE NOT THEY WERE NORMAL THAT
THEY WERE NOT ABNORMAL PROBLEMS.
THERE VISUAL INSPECTION WOULD
YOU SHOW YOU ANYTHING YOU HAD TO
DO WHAT'S NEXT IN THE BULLET
THERE IS TO GO BACK AND DO A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW DIG INTO
THE DESIGN DIGGING TO THE
CONSTRUCTION RECORDS. IDENTIFY
THOSE INHERENT DEFECTS THAT WERE
BUILT IN AT THE BEGINNING.
AND THEN. A WHAT CAN HAPPEN ON
A PROJECT LIKE OROVILLE YOU'VE
GOT A SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY FOOT
EMBANKMENT DAM. OVER THERE WHEN
YOU'RE DOING REVIEWS IT TENDS TO
DRAW A LOT OF ATTENTION.
AND PEOPLE CAN SOMETIMES FORGET
THESE APARTMENT FACILITIES LIKE
THE SPILLWAY THE OUTLET WORKS
THE POWER PLANT THEY DON'T GET
AS MUCH ATTENTION BECAUSE THAT
REALLY BIG ELEPHANT THE ROOM.
GETS THE ATTENTION SO WE NEED
THAT TO THINK ABOUT THAT AND
HAVE THAT ATTENTION BY THE
PEOPLE WITH THE RIGHT
EXPERIENCE.
WE HAVE A PROCESS CALLED THE
POTENTIAL FAILURE MODES ANALYSIS
A PROCEDURE THAT USED TO LIVE IN
DAM SAFETY AND I WANT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT UP HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF YOU WANNA KNOW MORE
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENS WITH IT IT WAS DONE AT
ORACLE. BUT IT FOCUSES ON THE
RISK
OF HAVING RESERVOIR WATER
RELEASED.
SO IF YOU GET TO A POINT LIKE AT
THE SERVICE BILL WAY.
WHEN THEY DID THIS THEY
CONCLUDED THAT THE ROCK THE
SERVICE SPILLWAY WAS SUCH THAT
EVEN IF EROSION HAPPENED EVEN IF
THE SLAB.
WITH FAILED THE EROSION
WOULDN'T GO BACK UP TO THE GATE
STRUCTURE WOULDN'T RELEASE THE
STORAGE SO THEY STOPPED IT LOOK
ANY FURTHER AND. WELL THEIR RISK
AS.
PROS BY THIS INCIDENT AND AS
DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY WITH
THESE POWER LINES HIM DOWNSTREAM
OF THE MERCY SPILLWAY THAT IN
OUR CURRENT USE THE PROCESS
DON'T COME OUT.
AND PROBABLY NEW NEED TO COME
OUT.
AND THEN.
THE LAST ONE THERE FOR OUR
INDUSTRY IS OWNERS OFTEN THINK
THAT IF THEY DO WHAT THE DIRECT
WHAT THE REGULAR TELLS THEM TO
DO ALL OF THEIR RISK ARE
DRESSED.
AND THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY TRUE
BECAUSE THROUGH IT REGULATORS
AGAIN OFTEN ARE FOCUSED ON. THIS
RELEASE OF RESERVOIR AND NOT
THESE OTHER NON RELEASE.
INCIDENT SO THAT'S WHAT OUR
REPORT HAD TO SAY AND IN SHORT
AND UP BE HAPPY TO. ENTERTAIN
ANY QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSION ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M JUST
START ONE OF A START UP BY AM.
THINKING IT PW R..
I KNOW IT'S IT IT'S BEEN AT
LEAST INCREDIBLY STRESSFUL
SITUATION TO HAVE THE WHOLE
STATE EYES ON YOU.
AND HAVING YOUR YOUR WHOLE AND
DIVISION EVERYONE EVERYONE'S
EYES ARE ON THAT RIGHT. THEM.
SO I THINK IT IS IT IS A. IT IS
NATURAL
I FEEL.
DEFENSIVE IT UNDER THE
MICROSCOPE BECAUSE YOU ARE RIGHT
YOU ARE IN EVERYBODY'S WATCHING.
AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
CONTEXT IN WHICH IT OCCURRED
THAT THE ABUSES MILLIONS OF
ACRES FEET OF WATER A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT WE HOLD TO.
TO TRANSFER ACROSS THE STATE.
THEN AND IT BRAIN AWAY MORE
THAN ANYBODY THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO WRITE SO THE CONTEXT
WAS.
AND THAT HAPPENED.
.
BUT AS WE AS GOING FORWARD AND
TO MR FRANCE.
JUST WANTED ENGINEER SOCIAL
WORKER RIGHTS AYE I START DOING
ANALOGIES IN MY HEAD OF. LONG
TERM RELATIONSHIPS
RATES WE GET MARRIED THE
SIXTIES%
THAT YOU THOUGHT IT WAS A REAL
FIRM FOUNDATION AND AS THEY GO
ON.
THINGS STILL SHAKY TO GET
COMPLACENT AND THEN A BIG CRISIS
OCCURS.
AND THE RELATIONSHIP BEGINS TO
CRUMBLE AND YOU THINK YOU KNOW
HOW. SO IN A RELATIONSHIP WHO
SCUTTLED BACK HOW HOW COULD WE
HAVE SEEN THIS.
AND I KNOW YOU HAD ALL THE THE
CONSTRUCTIONS AND EVERYTHING
GOING ON AND I UNDERSTAND IT
SOUNDS LIKE AND HAPPENS IN
BUREAUCRACIES IN ANY
ORGANIZATION. COMPLACENCY OCCURS
AS A DOZEN RELATIONSHIPS.
WHAT COULD HAVE MINK SO NOW
YOU'VE DONE A FORENSIC?
REPORT IT ARE THERE MORE KIND OF
ONGOING FORENSIC. INSPECTIONS
THAT CAN OCCUR DUE TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CATCH THIS. EARLIER
BECAUSE ALSO YOU WANT THROUGH
THE RELATIONSHIP AWAY RIGHT AND
I KNOW I MEAN TO BE IT TO THAT
THE AMOUNT OF REPAIRS THAT
HAPPEN TO GO DOWN TO REACH
BEDROCK. WAS ENCRYPT IT YOU KNOW
AND AN INCREDIBLE HOW COULD THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE WHILE THE DAM WAS
OPERATING WITHOUT THIS CRISIS
OCCURRING.
IT'S A FACT I LIKE THE ANALOGY
OF THE THE MARRIAGE SENSE NOT OF
THAT ONE BEFORE BUT I LIKE THAT.
.
THE THE THE THING THAT WOULD
HAVE POINTED OUT IN AND THE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN PFM A ALMOST
GOT THERE.
THEY FOR THE THE ISSUE AT THE
SERVICE BILL WAY THEY IDENTIFIED
THE PARTICULAR FAILURE MODE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. BUT BECAUSE
THE FOCUS WAS ON ONE WOULD IT
RELEASED THE RESERVOIR OR NOT.
OF ONCE THEY FELT THE GEOLOGY
WAS WAS.
SUCH THAT IT WOULD NOT REACH
THE RESERVOIR.
THE FAILURE MODE WASN'T
CONSIDERED ANY FURTHER AND IN
RETROSPECT IT MAY OF BEEN A
CORRECT CONCLUSION BECAUSE IN
RETROSPECT. YOU PUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CFS THROUGH THAT
STRUCTURE AFTER THE MERGE THE
SPILLWAY ISSUE DEVELOPED ANY
DIDN'T PROGRESS BACK TOWARDS THE
TO SO THAT WAS PROBABLY CORRECT
INCLUSION ACTUALLY.
BUT.
THAT'S WERE REPORTING IT TO THE
INDUSTRY AS WE NEED TO STEP BACK
AND REALIZE. THAT THERE THERE
ARE OTHER THINGS THAT.
WE WE TALK ABOUT OUR REPORTS
COMPONENT FAILURES WOULD THINK
OF THIS SHOOT THE SHOOTER IS A
COMPOUND IN THE OVERALL
STRUCTURE.
AND THIS SHOOT FAILED IS YOU
CAN'T.
TAKE THAT WORD AWAY I HAVE THIS
IS NOT A DAMN FAILURE BECAUSE
THE RESERVOIR WAS RELEASED BUT
THE SHOOT FAIR. AND THAT
COMPONENT FAILURE THEN LED TO D.
W. ARE NOT BEING ABLE TO CONTROL
THE REST OF WAR THE WAY IT WOULD
LIKE TO CONTROL THE REDS WERE IT
LED TO ALL THAT. THE BRISK TRADE
OFFS AND LED ULTIMATELY TO THE
WATER GOING OVER THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY. SO WE NEED TO AS A AS
A DAM SAFETY PRACTICE OR STEP
BACK AND REALIZE THAT. WE WE
NEED TO SOMEHOW FIND A WAY TO
IDENTIFY THOSE MORE SERIOUS.
NINE RELEASE FAILURE MODES THAT
THAT AN OWNER NEEDS TO THINK
ABOUT. AND AND IF THE REGULATORS
OF IT WE HAVE A VERY COMPLEX
REGULATORY SYSTEM IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAVE THE THE THE FEDERAL DAM
OWNERS PUREXML MISSION COURT
ENGINEERS REGULATE THEMSELVES.
THE FEDERAL YOU REGULATORY
COMMISSION FOR. REGULATES THE
HYDRO POWER GENERATING DAMS
ALL THE REST OF THEM ARE
REGULATED BY THE STATES.
AND ALL THE STATE'S ARE
DIFFERENT.
CALIFORNIA'S FORTUNATE THAT
REALLY HAVE IF YOU STATE IS A
GOOD PROGRAM IT HAS BEEN A GOOD
PROGRAM. AND I'M CONFIDENT WILL
LEARN FROM THIS INCIDENT WILL BE
AN EVEN BETTER PROGRAM.
BUT.
.
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE AS WE SAY
HERE BEEN DRIVEN BY THE PHYSICAL
INSPECTIONS WHICH IN THIS CASE
WOULD NOT HAVE INDICATED THE
PROBLEM.
AND.
THE.
THEY'VE BEEN DRIVEN BYBOTH
THAT AND THEN OCCASIONALLY AN
INCIDENT THAT LEADS IN TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT FOR MEMBER
BACK TO. OF FOLSOM DAM HEN THE
GATES FAILED CALIFORNIA THEN
WENT OUT AND LOOKED AT ALL THE
THE GATES AS IT DID OTHER
REGULATORS SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS WE REALLY NEED TO DO NOW STEP
BACK AND POLICE WITH CITIES FIND
AWAY IN WITH THAT THAT'S.
MORE RESOURCES OR ALLOCATING THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY TO DO THESE LOOK BACKS AT
WHAT WAS DESIGNED AND BUILT. HOW
DOES IT LOOK IN THE WHAT WE
SUGGESTED HERE'S THE QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING IS YOU LOOK AT?
HOW WAS IT DESIGNED AND BUILT
HOW DOES THAT COMPARE TO THE WAY
WE WOULD DESIGN AND BUILD IT
TODAY?
AND. IF IT IS DIFFERENT DO THE
DIFFERENCES BUT HAS LIKE
COMPROMISE THE STRUCTURE.
AND IF THEY DO THEN YOU NEED TO
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT IF YOU
DON'T KNOW THEN YOU NEED TO DO
FURTHER INVESTIGATIONS INTO YOU
DO NOW.
SO THAT'S THE.
THAT'S THE BIG TAKEAWAY FOR OUR
INDUSTRY IS WE'RE NOT DOING THAT
NOW. AND IF WE'RE NOT THAT WE
DON'T DO THAT
THERE WILL BE THINGS LIKE THIS
THAT WILL HAPPEN AGAIN IN THE
NEXT TIME IT MIGHT NOT BE A
SPILLWAYS MAYBE SOMETHING ELSE
OF THE.
THE LESSON DOESN'T APPLY JUST TO
SPILLWAYS IT APPLIES TO THE DAM
AND ALL OF ITS RELATED
STRUCTURES.
THANK YOU MR PERSON.
I SAW A WAS REVIEW UP AND THEN I
STRIPS TO PATTERSON.
I THINK IT TO TO UP PICKING BACK
ON THE RELATIONSHIP.
ANALOGY.
ITSELF LIKE THERE WAS A LOT OF
MISCOMMUNICATION. O. OR LACK OF
COMMUNICATION SO CAN YOU. HELP
ME. OR HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT
CHANGES ARE GOING TO BE MADE SO
THAT.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN MASON
MISCOMMUNICATION.
WHAT IS WTO ARE GOING TO BE
DOING TO?
HELP.
THE DIFFERENT. AGENCIES ARE THE
DIFFERENT.
DIVISIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
OKAY LEGAL STARTIN TOLL FREE ONE
ACNE THING SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
THE YEAH I THINK THAT.
.
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN SOME STEPS
OVER THIS LAST YEAR TO IMPROVE
COMMUNICATIONS AND ALL RUN
THROUGH A FEW OF THOSE. I THINK
THE REPORT THAT THE ROAD
INDEPENDENT FORENSIC TEAMS PUT
OUT GIVES US SOME GOOD
GUIDELINES AS TO WHAT.
SOME OF THE FOLKS MAYBE WERE
THINKING THAT THEY INTERVIEWED
OR WHERE THERE WERE GAPS IN
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN.
I MOVE FORWARD TO FILL AND. SO
PART OF IT.
IS
I THINK CLEARLY IDENTIFYING WE
DO HAVE EXECUTIVE LEVEL POINT.
PEOPLE FOR THE VARIOUS FACETS OF
DAM SAFETY IN THE DEPARTMENT AND
ONE OF THE THINGS TO REMEMBER AS
WE HAVE.
MULTIPLE FACETS OF BROWN'S
INFRASTRUCTURE DAM SAFETY SO I
THINK IT'S MAKING SURE THAT.
IT ALL OVER FOLKS UNDERSTAND
THAT TOLL AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE STATE WATER PROJECT IS
THE DAM OWNER SO FROM THAT SIDE
OF DWI ARE. ULTIMATELY THOUGH HE
HAS MULTIPLE DIVISIONS UNDER HIM
THAT YOU KNOW DEAL WITH THAT.
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE AND
ENGINEERING ULTIMATELY HE IS
THE THE HEAD OF THAT.
PART OF THE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT AND ALL THE DECISIONS
YOU KNOW BANNER RECOMMENDATIONS
COME UP THROUGH HIM AND HE IS
HOUSED THEM FINAL SAY ON THAT SO
MAKING SURE THAT.
AS A DIEM OWNER EVERYONE
INTERNALLY KNOWS THAT'S JEWEL IN
HIS ROLE WE ALSO HAVE OUR
REGULATORY ARM THE DIVISION OR.
SAFETY OF DAMS AND WE HAVE ERA
COKE IS GONNA BE PART OF THE
NEXT PANEL IS OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THAT PIECE. HAS
WHEELS ARE CHIEF ENGINEER
SHARING TAPIO SO.
PEOPLE ARE IN PLACE BUT
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU DO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY.
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT
UNDERSTANDS
WHERE THAT RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
ROLES LIFE SO I THINK THAT IS.
AN EASY FIX IN MY OPINION I
THINK IT'S JUST MAKING SURE WE
CLARIFY THAT ALL THE WAY DOWN
THROUGH THE RANKS.
.
WE HAVE DONE ALSO A BIT OF WOOD
AND BEGINNING TO CONTINUE TO RE
ORGANIZE INTERNALLY TO HAVE A
COUPLE OTHER POINTS PEOPLE WE
HAVE SOMEBODY THAT WE RECENTLY
PUT IN PLACE AS A. EXECUTIVE
LEVEL OB PROJECT MANAGER FOR ALL
THINGS WERE A BILL SO THIS
PERSON WORKS WHICH ALL THEY WORK
WITH THEIR COKE BUT THEY'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE BROADER SCALE
KEEPING AN EYE ON THE
CONSTRUCTION THE DAY TO DAY. SO
WE'RE MAKING SURE EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT THAT PERSON. ALL
ORVILLE COMMUNICATIONS
CORRESPONDENCE
GOES THROUGH THAT PERSON AND IN
FACT THAT PERSON KEEPS MYSELF
FOR DIRECTOR IN THE OTHER
DEPUTIES INFORMED SO WE'RE GONNA
TIGHTENING THAT THAT INTERNAL
STRUCTURE AROUND INFORMATION
FLOW. BOTH WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AND INSIDE AND OUT AND I KNOW
THERE WILL BE OTHERIMPROVEMENTS
SERVE ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE WILL
NEED TO MAKE.
WE HAVE YOU KNOW THE CAPACITY
TO DO THINGS THERE ARE INTERNAL
INTRANET.
A WE HAVE A FABULOUS OR A FILM
LIKE IT'S FABULOUS MAYBE NOT
EVERYBODY THINKS SO BUT WE
HAVEN'T OR OF THE WEB PAGE NOW.
THAT IS OUTWARD FACING BOTH FOR
THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO WE HAVE A
LOT OF STAFF THAT.
HER ARMOR CLUED INTO THAT
LOOKING TO THAT GETTING
INFORMATION FROM THERE AS WE CAN
USE THAT AS A TOOL TO KEEP
PEOPLE INFORMED WE HAVE AN FAQ.
I THINK THEY'LL BE SOME
ADDITIONAL FAQS THAT COME OUT OF
THE FORENSIC TEAM REPORT THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
AWARE OF. THIS IS
YOU KNOW UP.
GOOD THE ROLES OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THIS IS WHAT DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS RESPONSIBLE FOR SO
WE CAN WE CAN GET THE WORD OUT
THAT WAY AS WELL.
.
AND THERE'S MORE TO COME
OBVIOUSLY WITH OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL TOM.
S. STRUCTURE TRAINING THAT
SOMETHING WILL NEED TO LOOK AT
IT AND I THINK THERE WERE SOME
GOOD OPTIONS WITHIN THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE. WITHIN THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE TO DO MORE
TRAINING INTERNALLY TO GET MORE
STUFF SORT OF.
INFORMED IN AND AWARE OF OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE
REQUIREMENTS AND WHATNOT SO.
MYSELF IN THE EXECUTIVE TEAM
ARE TAKING A CAREFUL LOOK AT HOW
WE CAN AT.
JUST GIVE THAT INFORMATION FLOW
I THINK IN IN MY OPINION.
PART OF WHAT I I GOT FROM THE
REPORT WAS WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE INFORMED I THINK
AND THEY HAVE QUESTIONS AND
MAYBE THEY HAVEN'T MADE THEIR
WAY TO ME BUT THEY THEY ARE
THERE NOW. SNOW NOW I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT HELPS AT ALL.
WILL CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
AND IF THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON.
YEAH WE WOULD HAVE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY BE HAPPY TO COME AND
PROVIDE UPDATES AS WE KIND OF
BUILD IT'S IT'S IT'S A
COMPLICATED. PROCESS IT'S A BIG
DEPARTMENT WE'VE MADE SOME
INITIAL STEPS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BUILDING A PRCE LIKE THINK
MY CONCERN IS THAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT OF FOLKS I DIDN'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OR. AND SO IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
ADDRESSING THAT I HAVE MY ANSWER
OR I'M SORRY THE ANSWER THAT I'M
LOOKING FOR.
YOU KNOW A COMPLACENCY I LOVE.
DOCTOR EGGMAN'S ANALOGY BECAUSE
THE COMPLACENT SOUNDS LIKE.
THERE WAS A LOT OF COMPLACENCY
AND I. PEOPLE DIDN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE AND SO
THAT'S A MORE WHEN I'M LOOKING
FOR OKAY. I'M I THINK TO A DO
OU WANT HIM MAYBE IF I CAN HAVE
A LITTLE. TOO DEPUTY
I JUST SAID.
YOU KNOW ONE.
WE WE AS WE WERE EXAMINING
OURSELVES AFTER FEBRUARY WE
STARTED RECOVERY THERE'S A LOT
OF CONCLUSIONS IN HERE THAT WE
OURSELVES CRADDOCK.
AND HE'S HE'S ALSO SUPPORTING SO
WE HAVE NOW TAKEN CARE ALL
COMMUNICATION. ALL THAT'S GOING
ON THROUGH ONE EXECUTIVE THAT IS
WAYNE AND AND THAT'S HIS DAY JOB
NOW.
FOR NOW. AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
THIS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DONE. YOU
KNOW ABSORBING ALL OF IT AND
REALLY COMING OUT WITH WHAT IS
THE WORK STRUCTURE THAT MAKE
SURE THEIR IS A SINGLE EXECUTIVE
THAT'S REALLY WEIGHING IN ON ALL
DECISIONS RELATED THEY CAN MAKE
TAKEN THAT RISK.
AND PUT IT INTO HOW WE MANAGE
ALL OUR ASSETS.
PUTTING THE DAM SAFETY PROGRAM.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE'RE TAKING
THOSE STEPS THE COMMUNICATION.
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL ONE
AM. D. AN ENGINEERING HIS.
CARMEN IN THE INDUSTRY THAT
THERE'S ALWAYS THAT NATURAL
ENGINEERING TENSION.
BUT IT CAN NOT CONTINUE
OTHERWISE THE DOCKS THAT MR
FRANCE WAS TALKING ABOUT WON'T
ALWAYS GET CONNECTED SO THE
COMMUNICATION IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND WE NEED TO BUILD WE NEED TO
BREAK DOWN THE SILOS AND MAKE
SURE THEY ARE COMMUNICATING.
SO THAT WHEN WE IMPLEMENT THE
NEW PROCESS IS A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEWS ALL THE
WAY TO DESIGN.
THAT DOES DOTS ARE LOOKED AT AND
SEEN AND AND WE CAN TAKE ACTION
ON SO WE STARTED NOW WITH AN
EXECUTIVE WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO PUSH THAT AND THIS FORENSIC
REPORT. INFORMATION WILL LEAD US
TO VOTERS WAS OUR FINAL OR.
AND THAT TOP DOWN APPROACH LOOKS
LIKE.
IS IT OKAY TO ADD JUST ONE MORE
THING TO CIRCLE BACK TO SORT OF
THE RELATIONSHIP QUESTION I JUST
WANTED TO COMMENT THAT I THINK
YOU FOR THE KNOWLEDGE MEAN ABOUT
BEING UNDER THE MICROSCOPE AND
ALL EYES ON US. IT IS A VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE PLACE BUT I WILL
SAY THAT I THINK.
THE SILVER LINING OF IT IS IT
WILL.
MOVE US FORWARD IN TERMS OF
IMPROVEMENTS AND CHANGES AND
ENHANCEMENTS NONPROFIT A FASTER
PACE
THEN WE WOULD SO WHILE NOT FUN I
DO. MYSELF AND OTHERS WELCOME IT
AS.
OF MOMENTUM TO TO KIND OF KEEP
THIS GOING HANGING MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE CHANGES AND
BE CREATIVE AND ADD AND KIND OF
THINKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOX SO I
JUST WANTED TO THROW THAT OUT
THERE.
JUST AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT ARM.
IT.
I'VE ASKED IN.
IT'S DIFFERENT MOVIES BUT WHAT
UC ACCOUNTABILITY.
.
PRACTICES I GUESS IF YOU IF YOU
WELL I MEAN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMPROVEMENTS YOU KNOW ETCETERA
ETCETERA WHAT ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS ARE GOING TO PUT IN
PLACE TO MAKE SRE THAT. YOU
KNOW THESE FOLKS THAT.
WHATEVER THE THE ISSUES MAY BE.
KIDS WE CAN TALK ABOUT
PRACTICES AND YOU KNOW CHANGIN
THE POLICIES AND ALL OF THAT BUT
IF THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL. MATTER.
UNIT WE CAN PUT THE BEST
PRACTICES IN PLACE BUT IF
THERE'S NOBODY BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WHATEVER YOU PUT IN PLACES IS IS
BEING FOLLOWED SO. I GUESS IT'S
NOT REALLY A QUESTION IT'S MORE
OF A COMMENT BUT YOU KNOW I I
URGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE
SOMETIMES.
AND I FOUND THAT IN MANY OF OUR
AGENCIES THERE IS NO REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. AYE AND.
THE THE WE CAN TALK TO OR PLAN
THE FACE BUT IF NOBODY'S BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTABLE THEN INCIDENTS
LIKE THIS CAN HAPPEN AGAIN ARE
HOPEFULLY NOT TO THIS EXTENT
BUT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER NO ILENE
AYE INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE AND IF
THERE IS NO COMMUNICATION AND
THERE'S NO REAL ACCOUNTABILITY
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AGAIN AND
SO I GUESS IN IN YOUR AYE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. OF OUR
PRACTICES THERE HAS TO BE A REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
BOB PIECE ATTACHED TO ALL THOSE
AND SO HOPEFULLY WHEN YOU COME
UP WITH THAT IF WE CAN GET SOME
INFORMATION ON HOW. YOU'RE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PRACTICES ARE BEING PHAM.
THINK.
DISA DERBY CAN BE VERY PAINFUL.
OF AND I'M ALSO PLEASED.
AND ALL SAVE FOR FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT NEW
DIRECTOR JUST PINPOINT GRANT
DAVIS. IS FROM OUTSIDE THE
AGENCY SO I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
THING YOU TALKED ABOUT SOME THE
COMPLACENCY THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN
EVERYBODY'S BEEN A REALLY LONG
TIME. WHICH IS TO CONVERT NATURE
BUREAUCRACY BUT HAVING NEW
OUTSIDE EYES COMING IN AS A
DIRECTOR.
I THINK WILL BE GOOD A.
MR PATERSON DID YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
FIRST TO UP.
FRETS UMP. AYE. I'M REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
.
WHAT APPEARS TO BE CANARIES IN
THE COAL MINE THAT WERE IGNORED?
WE HEARD WE HEARD ABOUT CRACKS.
AND.
FLOWS.
AND WE ALSO HEARD ABOUT BORE
HOLES AS FUNDAMENTAL REASONS FOR
I GUESS THAT.
A FAILURE.
.
HOW WOULD YOU ASSESS?
WHETHER THIS WAS.
A REASONABLE OVERSIGHT.
OUR A PRACTICE OVER TIME THAT
SOMEHOW DEVELOPED WITH MAYBE
SOME OF THE COMPLACENCY THAT
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT.
AND TO WHAT DEGREE DID THIS
SURPRISE YOU OR SH SHAKE YOU.
.
WAS IT A RED LIGHT SIGNAL GOING
OFFER WAS IT A CAUTION SIGNAL
THAT WAS.
FLASHING SHOULD THIS HAVE BEEN
DISCOVERED.
IT.
IT WAS NOT A RED LIGHT SIGNAL OF
AND IF I CAN GO BACK TO YOUR
CANARIES IN THE COALMINE ANALOGY
A MOMENT AGO.
THE CANARIES MAY HAVE BEEN IN
THE COAL MINE BUT THEY WERE IN A
DEEP SECTION OF THE COAL MINE
THAT WASN'T BEING WORKED
ANYMORE.
SO THAT PEOPLE WEREN'T THERE
SEEING THOSE CANARIES THAT THE
DATA THAT SHOWED LEAD TO
PROBLEMS WITH THE GEOLOGY WAS IN
THE RECORDS.
OF THE W. ARE THEY WERE THERE
BUT YOU HAD TO GO DEEP INTO
THOSE RECORDS BACK TO NINETEEN
SIXTIES YOU NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
TO FIND. SOME OF THE LATER
REPORTS DIDN'T REPEAT IT AND
THEN AS I TALKED ABOUT WITH THIS
NORMALIZATION OF THE OF THE
UNUSUAL BEHAVIOR THE CRACKS IN
THE AND THE TRAINS. NOBODY
THOUGHT ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
THE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
POTENTIAL FAILURE MODE
ANALYSIS-ALMOST GOT THERE.
BUT BECAUSE
THEY CONCLUDED THAT IT WOULDN'T
RELEASED THE RESERVOIR THEY
DIDN'T DIG THAT BIT DEEPER THAT
YOU HAD TO GO BACK INTO THOSE
RECORDS TO FIND IT. SO IT WAS
THERE
BUT YOU HAD TO DIG FOR THAT
THERE WASN'T A FLASHING RED
LIGHT RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU AND
THAT'S A LITTLE. IS WE TALK
ABOUT THIS MORE DETAIL IN THE
REPORT IT'S MORE A PRACTICE.
IT'S NOT A TYPICAL PRACTICE WHAT
OUR INDUSTRY IS DOING RIGHT NOW
AND THAT'S WHY OUR INDUSTRY I'M
A PART OF IT IS SO I NEED TO
LEARN THIS TO. WE NEED TO LEARN
THAT THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE OF
THAT DEEP DIVE INTO THE
INFORMATION.
.
SO FROM THE STANDPOINT OF DID IT
SURPRISE US.
IT DID SURPRISE ME UNFORTUNATELY
I HAVE TO SAY NO IT DIDN'T
SURPRISE ME BECAUSE.
I KNOW THE WAY THE INDUSTRY
WORKS AND AND THAT'S WHERE WE
HAVE TO IMPROVE OUR WAY OF DOING
THINGS TO DO IT BETTER SO THERE
WASN'T A FLASHING RED LIGHT THAT
WAS MISSED. YOU HAD TO BE A LOT
MORE DILIGENT TO GET IS THERE IS
THERE ANY.
UP.
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE HERE AND
LOOKING AT THIS.
ARE THERE OTHER.
BUT WHAT KEEPS YOU AWAKE AT
NIGHT YOU HAVE DUG THROUGH ALL
OF THIS.
AND YOU ARE A RENOWNED EXPERT
AND YOUR TEAM WAS A RENOWNED
EXPERT.
.
APART FROM LEARNING ABOUT WHAT
WENT WRONG HERE.
DO YOU. HAVE ANY CONCERNS THAT
THERE ARE OTHER TICKING TIME
BOMBS BECAUSE OF THE STRUCTURE
BECAUSE OF THE OVER CONFIDENCE
BECAUSE OF.
OF THE COMPLACENCY.
ARE THERE OTHER.
THINGS GOING ON OUT THERE WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT YOU WORRY
OVER.
I DO.
BECAUSE PARENTS THE THE DAMN
INFRASTRUCTURE IS RELATIVELY OLD
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE AVERAGE
AGE OF DAMS IS FIFTY YEARS ARE
GREATER.
AND A LOT OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE
NOT DOING THIS DEEP DIVE INTO
THE INFORMATION SO THAT'S THE
WORRY AND THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE
IS THE WAKEUP CALL TO WEAR
INDUSTRIES WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE RIGHT NOW NOT.
DIGGING IS DEEPLY AS WE NEED TO
DEFINE THOSE TICKING TIME BOMBS
IF YOU LIKE.
AND.
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A LESSON
R. INDUSTRY WILL TAKE TO HEART
WILL LEARN AND WILL.
WE BUT IT IS GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE FOR.
.
CORD LEGISLATURE'S LIKE YOURS
AND IN OTHER STATES AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE IT
MAY TAKE MORE RESOURCES THAN
WE'VE BEEN PUTTING ON A
HISTORICALLY. I THINK AGENCIES
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT CAN THEY RE
EVALUATE AND AND REASSIGNED THE
RESOURCES THEY HAVE BUT SOME OF
THEM ARE GOING TO NEED MORE
RESOURCES. ALSO DEDUCED THESE
DEEP DIVES INTO THE INFORMATION
AND THEN MAKE THOSE EVALUATIONS
AYE YEAH I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER. MEMBERS IN THIS
LEGISLATURE WHO HAVE EXPRESSED
REAL CONCERN THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NOT BEEN MODERNIZED. IN A LONG
LONG TIME AND THAT WE HAVE NOT
REALLY SPENT THE KIND OF
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE A GEM OF
THE HYDROLOGY SYSTEM. BUT IT IS
OLD OUTDATED AND.
FRAUGHT WITH WITH SOME PROBLEMS
AND SO THIS IS NOT ONLY I THINK
FROM A WAKE UP CALL. FOR THE
OPERATION IT IS A WAKE UP CALL
FOR THE MODERNIZATION OF OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM
AND IT CANNOT WAIT ANY ANY
LONGER A QUESTION TO.
.
TO DO D. W. ARE UP.
THAT PAGE FIFTY NINE AND IN THE
REPORT.
USED SOME LANGUAGE OF
SIGNIFICANTLY OVERCONFIDENT.
AND COMPLACENT ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF ITS STATE WATER
PROJECT.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
I DO YOU. DO YOU CONCUR WITH THE
FINDINGS THAT.
THERE WAS COMPLACENCY THAT
OVERCONFIDENCE.
RIGHT POLLSTER WITHOUT ON ON.
AYE.
WE ARE CONFIDENT WE HAVE BEEN
CONFIDENT ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OVERCONFIDENT I
DON'T KNOW THAT I.
COMPLETELY AGREE ARE NECESSARILY
AGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT.
I THINK THE CONFIDENCE CAME.
IN PART FROM THE INFORMATION
THAT WE'VE BEEN THE DATA WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THAT. CONTINUE
TO LEAD US TO BELIEVE THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS.
IN GOOD SHAPE THEIR WARRANT
ISSUES THAT WE NOW RECOGNIZE
THERE ARE.
HOME I THINK.
BUT I WOULD ALSO.
NOT WHOLE HEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
COMPLACENCY BUT I. WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AS A WAKE UP CALL THAT THIS IS
WE DO NEED TO NOT ONLY FOR THIS
PARTICULAR FOR STRUCTURE BUT THE
OTHER DAMS THAT WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT WE'VE
ALREADY BEGUN THESE RE
EVALUATIONS.
WE REALLY NEED TO NEED TO TAKE A
STEP BACK AND REALIZE THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING TO THE
INDUSTRY STANDARDS TO WHAT THE
REGULATORS HAVE ASKED US TO DO
BUT WE DO NEED TO DO A DEEPER
DIVE AT THIS POINT TO REALLY
LOOK AT.
IT.
POTENTIAL ISSUES THE TRUE NATURE
OF THE TRUE.
.
I AM LOSING MY WE'RE HERE THE.
CURRENT STATUS OF.
DAMS OF OTHER SPILLWAYS SO WE
HAVE TO GET. AWAY AND COME BACK
WITH SOME FRESH ICE I THINK
MAYBE THAT'S THE WAY I WOULD
PERMITTED TO SAY. WE NEED TO DO
A DEEPER DIVE WE NEED TO GO ON
WITH A FRESH SET OF EYES. AND
I'M.
AND.
WE WILL DO THE ON PAGE PAGE
SIXTY.
EW R. WAS LARGELY IN A MODE TO
REACT TO PROBLEMS.
WITHITS STATE WATER PROJECT
CIVIL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AT AS THEY AROSE IN THE SHORT
TERM RATHER THAN TAKING
PREEMPTIVE ACTIONS PROACTIVELY
TO PREVENT THE PROBLEMS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT FINDING.
YOU MIND IF I PUMP THIS ONE TWO
YEARS.
BECAUSE OF THAT COMPREHENSIVE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF.
PUT THIS ON OVER TO JOLT JUST
BECAUSE I THINKING GIVING HIM
MORE IN DEPTH ANSWER REACTIVE
RATHER THAN PROACTIVE THAT'S A
CLAIM IN THE REPORT RIGHT.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
NO BUT GOING BACK TO YOUR OTHER
QUESTION JUST ADD A LITTLE BIT I
I WANT TO REALLY LEVERAGE
THE.
THE A FORENSICS REPORT LESSONS
LEARNED ON THE PROBABLE FAILURE
MODES ANALYSIS BECAUSE.
FUNDAMENTALLY THAT IS THE
BEGINNING. AND SETS REALLY THE
OBJECTIVE FOR. WHAT YEAR
PROTECTING FROM?
AND IF CURRENTLY WERE PROTECTING
FROM A FULL DAM FAILURE.
THEN THAT DOES.
YOU KNOW COULD. REALLY TAKE AWAY
ALL THOSE OTHER FAILURES THAT
HAVE COME AND DON'T MEAN NOT A
FULL DAM FAILURE BUT STILL ENDS
UP BEING AND IT'S.
OR NUMBERS SEE WHAT I WANT TO
GET TOO SO I THINK FUNDAMENTALLY
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT THINKING.
WHICH THEN PULLS YOU INTO NOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT EVERY
COMPONENT OF THIS OF THE OF THE
SYSTEM.
ON THE ONTHE BEING REACTIVE OR
NOT. I THINK THE DEPARTMENT.
YOU KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND EVEN IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN STARTED
UPGRADING OUR ASSET MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM TO REALLY LOOK AT. EVERY
ASSET
FROM MY RISK PUBLIC SAFETY TWO
EVEN TO THE BUSINESS PROCESS
ABOUT.
DELIVERING WATER IN IN THE
REPORTED DOES SAY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE LEVERAGE THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE IT STARTED
IT'S A FIVE YEAR PROJECT WE'RE
NOT COMPLETELY THERE YET. BUT I
THINK THAT WAS VERY PROACTIVE OF
PARIS DAM THE DEPARTMENT TOOK ON
ON ITS OWN THAT PROJECT TO
REALLY.
BOLSTER IT FROM FROM THE
SEISMIC PERSPECTIVE AND WE WERE
NOT TOLD BY FOR COR DS SO NEED
TO DO THAT THAT WAS ON OUR OWN
AND THAT WAS A VERY EXPENSIVE.
PROJECT BUT IT'S THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO DO
SO I SEE OURSELVES AS A.
PROACTIVE ORGANIZATION BUT I CAN
UNDERSTAND FROM THE INFORMATION
THE FORENSICS TEAM HAD AND WHAT
HAPPENED HERE. THAT YEAH THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE DONE ON
THAT SPILLWAYS IF WE HAD BEEN
ABLE IF WE HAD DONE THE
INSPECTIONS THAT THEY INDUSTRY
IS LEARNING FROM AND WOULD HAVE
DONE SO.
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOW AT LEAST IN
MY OPINION. THE.
.
THERE'S A CONVERSATION HERE FROM
OTHER MEMBERS IN QUESTIONS FROM
OTHER MEMBER WITH RESPECT
COMMUNICATION AND THE LINE OF.
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IT IS MY OBSERVATION THAT
MUCH OF WHAT WE ARE.
A TALKING ABOUT HERE MUCH OF THE
PROBLEMS WERE IS IS QUITE
FRANKLY INHERENT IN ALL
BUREAUCRACIES.
IT IS ALMOST THE NATURE OF
AND SO I THINK YOU KNOW HARRY
TRUMAN HAD A THE THE BUCK STOPS
HERE ON HIS ON HIS.
PRESIDENTIAL DESK.
AND D. W. ARE WHERE DOES THE
BUCK STOP WHO IS THE FINAL
EXECUTIVE. WITH THE AUTHORITY.
TO DEVELOP AND AND AND CREATE.
A DEPARTMENT THAT WILL IN FACT
DIG DOWN DEEPER WILL IN FACT
FIND SOME OF THE.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND AND WILL IN
FACT MOVE THE THE. THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM AWAY FROM. REACTIVE TO
PROACTIVE SO THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE IMPROVED
TO PREVENT. A PROBLEMS BEFORE
THEY START WHERE DOES THE BUCK
STOP.
THE BUCK STOPS WITH THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT IS WITHIN MY SUPPORT AND
THE DEPUTIES AS THE EXECUTIVE
TEAM MAKING SURE THAT WE. BRING
THAT INFORMATION UP WE AS
EXPERTS IN OUR OWN. RIGHTS
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
ULTIMATELY THE DIRECTOR HOW I'M
GONNA ASK THE.
WHAT KEEPS YOU AWAKE AT NIGHT
QUESTION IS WELL WHAT DOES KEEP
YOU AWAKE AT NIGHT YOU YOU HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THIS EVERYDAY? YOU
REPORT TO US IN THE SPOTLIGHT
CAN BE.
PRETTY PRETTY US SIGNIFICANT
BUT YOU HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND I KNOW YOU TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY
WHAT KEEPS YOU AWAKE AT NIGHT
ABOUT THIS HYDRAULICALLY
HYDROLOGIST SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE.
PRO ACTIVELY REPAIRED.
AND MODERNIZED.
SO FOR ME BECAUSE I AM ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT IS VERY MUCH
ABOUT KEEPING THE TRAINS GOING
IN MAKING SURE THE TRAINS ARE
RUNNING ON KEEPING THINGS
ORGANIZED I'M MORE OF THE INWARD
FOCUS FOR THE DEPARTMENT FOR ME.
IT IS
HOW.
WE.
WE HAVE A ROAD MAP SO TO SPEAK
FROM THIS REPORT FROM THE WORK
THAT WE'VE ALREADY STARTED WITH
OUR COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WITH A RISK
ASSESSMENT.
MOVING THAT INTO IMPLEMENTATION
PHASE
I KNOW WE CAN GET THERE BUT.
I SPEND HOURS AT NIGHT.
JUST THINKING ABOUT HOW WE MOVE
THAT FORWARD DO HAVE THE
RESOURCES HOW DO. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE WITH THE
RIGHT EXPERTISE JUST PULLING
THAT ALL TOGETHER. I DON'T DOUBT
THAT WE CAN'T MAKE THESE CHANGES
AND BE ACCOUNTABLE BUT.
WE ARE A BIG DEPARTMENT THERE
IS.
A LOT OF WORK TO DO HERE AND HOW
I AM VERY DEDICATED AS IS THE
EXECUTIVE TEAM. BUT GETTING
THERE YOU KNOW JUST MAKING THIS
WEEK IS.
GONNA BE A HECK OF A LOT OF WORK
ONE FINAL QUESTION MR FRANCE
THE.
STATE WATER PROJECT IS UNIQUE IN
THAT THE W. OUR FUNCTION
AS AS BOTH THE OWNER IN THE
REGULAR.
I CONSIDERING THE W. ARE
SUBSTANTIAL RESPONSIBILITY OF
ORGANIZATIONAL COMPLEXITY.
THEN YOU BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO HAVE ANOTHER
ENTITY ASSIST WITH OPERATIONS OF
THE STATE WATER. PROJECTS
SPECIFICALLY THE.
ORAL VILLE FACILITIES AND DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THE DIVISION OF
SAFETY AND DAM SHOULD REMAIN
UNDER THE W. ARE.
YES IT IS RICOCHET DO OF THE
SITUATION WHERE THE THE ONE
DEPARTMENT HAS BOTH THE
REGULATOR AND DAM OWNER.
AYE I WOULD COMMITTEES NOT
ACTUALLY UNIQUE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES WHERE EXACTLY THE SAME
SITUATION EXISTS IN MY HOME
STATE OF COLORADO.
THE SAME SITUATION EXISTS
DEPARTMENT NATURAL RESOURCES.
HOUSES THE.
THE DAM SAFETY PROGRAM AND IT
ALSO HOUSES THE PARKS AND
WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT WHICH OWNS
DAMS THAT ARE REGULATED BY THAT
GROUP I BELIEVE IN MEXICO'S THE
SAME WAY I THINK YOU'LL FIND
MULTIPLE STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IT IS SAME WAY. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S AN INHERENT FLAW I
THINK THOSE ORGANIZATIONS WORK
VERY WELL. IT DOES RELY ON
KEEPING THAT REGULATOR.
KEEPING SEPARATION PUNIT
REGULATOR AND THE OWNER.
AND WE DID WE'VE BELIEVE FROM
WHAT THE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD
AND WE SAW IS THAT. THAT'S
REALLY NOT A FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM
HERE DSO DE IS NOT EASIER ON D.
W. ARE THAT IS ON ON ITS OTHER
OWNERS.
IN IN FACT IF ANYTHING WE
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT OF OF
EVIDENCE THAT SUGGESTED DSO DE
MIGHT BE EVEN A LITTLE HARDER ON
D. W. ARTISTS OCCUR COMPENSATE
FOR THAT SITUATION SO. THAT
THERE ARE OTHER MODELS AND NOT
SAYING THATTHE THERE'S NOT
REASON TO THINK ABOUT ANOTHER
MODEL BUT IT'S NOT UNIQUE IT'S
NOT TO BE A FATAL FLAW IT
DEPENDS ON THE DEDICATION OF THE
DAM SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
DAM SAFETY DIVISION AND. I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF GOOD
DEDICATED PEOPLE HERE AND THAT'S
HOW I DON'T SEE THAT. UP I'LL
JUST CONCLUDE WE EAT.
WE HEARD THE A WORD ABOUT WE ARE
FORTUNATE THAT.
LIVES WERE NOT LOST.
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE WERE MORE
LUCKY THAN GOOD.
AND IT SEEMS THAT IT'S ABOUT
TIME FOR US NOT TO DEPEND ON
BLOCK SO MUCH.
TO GET A WHOLE LOT BETTER AT
WHAT.
THINK MISTER PATTERSON ALMOST
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR.
SO WE TALK ABOUT. HIS SEISMIC
HAS BEEN.
DISCUSSED.
VERY ON A VERY SMALL SCALE. WHOM
WE HAD LOMA PRIETA IN CALIFORNIA
WE WENT THROUGH IN REEF
RETROFITTED ALL THE BRIDGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND EX A COST.
IT WAS ENORMOUS.
BUT THERE WAS NO.
EXPENSE SPARED BECAUSE.
OF THE SAFETY.
THAT IT AFFORDED.
WHAT PLANS YOU HAVE GOING
FORWARD KNOWING THE DESIGN
CRITERIA THIS CHANGE TECHNOLOGY
IS CHANGED?
IN IN CONSTRUCTION PRODUCTS.
.
BECAUSE CONCRETE DOES HAVE A
LIFESPAN.
WELL WE KNOW THAT UP TO DATE
THAT IF THIS DAMN WORTH
SPILLWAYS BEEN TREATED IN THIS
FASHION AND ALL OF THEM HAVE
PROBABLY BEEN TREATED IN THIS
FASHION.
WITH TOPICAL REPAIRS THAT ARE
JUST BANDAIDS.
WHAT ARE YOU?
WHAT IS YEAR PLANS TO GO OUT AND
INSPECT FORENSICALLY?
ON THE OTHER DANCE SO THAT OTHER
PEOPLE ARE AT RISK AND WE CAN
HAVE AN ASSURANCE.
WITH THIS WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN
ELSEWHERE.
YOU KNOW AND ALSO BEFORE THE
RESPOND AND THEY'RE GONNA
RESPOND BUT. I THINK WILL GO
INTO DEBT DEEPER TO ON THE ON
THE NEXT PANEL WHICH WILL FOCUS
ON THE DAM SAVED UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
SO WHICH SLEEVED R. CHRISTOPHER
SUREI MEAN YOU GO AHEAD BECAUSE
YOU'RE TO BE ON THE NEXT PANEL
TO HOPPING ON TAKE IT NOW OR
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE UP HERE WITH
YOU COULD YOU HAVE OTHER EXPERTS
UP.
WHEN YOU ANSWER THAT THAT. I
THINK THAT'S A QUESTION THAT
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO GET OUT TO.
OKAY I'M. BLACK CHAIR WAS GOING
TO SAVE IF YOU.
WANT TO HOLD THE QUESTION WE'RE
GOING TO RUN THROUGH ANOTHER
QUICK PRESENTATION THAT SORT OF
SETS THE STAGE FOR WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED DOING AND
MOMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE OTHER TO
FURTHER IS.
SO WE ALSO WHEN YOU SAY THE BUCK
STOPS WITH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IN
ONE NOT WE HAVE A HUGE.
.
CHANGE OF STAFF
IN AGENCIES.
WHAT PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE TO?
I HAVE.
.
INSPECTIONS AND AND THEN FOLLOW
UP AND LEFT LIKE A FLOW CHART OF
WHAT WHAT GOES IN PLACE TO.
CREATE.
A PROCESS THAT.
IS RECOGNIZED BY THE EXPERTS
AND I'M NOT SAYING AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO DIMINISH.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE BUT WHO SAYS
YOU'RE QUALIFIED TO MAKE HIS
INSPECTION R. AND ARE YOU.
GETTING THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
BECAUSE FROM WHAT I'M SEEING IF
WE HAVE AN WATER INTRUSION
SPILLWAYS IS CREATING. A RUSTING
OF COP OF.
REBAR. AND IT'S BALLING AND NOW
IT'S SO WE COMPLAIN BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE THE TINSEL
STRENGTH THAT USE TO HAVE
BECAUSE NOW. IT'S DIMINISHED.
OF OVER A PERIOD TIME. OF WHAT
WHAT YOU GONNA PUT IN PLACE SO
WITH STAFF CHANGES THAT YOU HAVE
A NORMAL. SET OF STANDARDS.
NO ALL STARTIN DEPEND ON SO THAT
IT THERE ARE SOME.
STANDARDS GUIDELINES PROTOCOLS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE THAT
COME FROM PRIMARILY OUR
REGULATORY.
ENTITIES SO DIVISION OF SAFETY
OF DAMS AND FOR. AND THOSE ARE
PRIMARILY WHAT WE FOLLOW WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT HAS A DAMN OWNER
AS MANY OTHER DAM OWNERS DO.
THEY ARE. WRITTEN DOWN THEY'VE
BEEN FOLLOWED WE.
WHO OVER THE ENTIRE?
HISTORY YEAR LIFESPAN OF THE DAM
AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE
DONE OUR ANNUAL INSPECTIONS ARE
EVERY TWO YEAR INSPECTIONS ARE
FIVE YEAR INSPECTION SO THESE
ARE. LAID OUT BY THE DIFFERENT
REGULATORY ENTITIES WE HAVE OUR
STAFF THAT
OR TRAINED.
IN THESE AREAS OF DAM SAFETY
AND.
FIELDS OF ENGINEERING BUT WE
ALSO UTILIZE A LOT OF OUTSIDE
EXPERTISE IN TERMS OF
CONSULTANTS THAT ARE EXPERTS IN
THESE FIELDS SO.
WE DO HAVE OUR OUR FOLKS THERE
OBVIOUSLY.
MS TURNOVER IN STAFF BUT THE
FRAMEWORK IS THERE BY WHICH WE
OPERATE UNDER IN REPORT OUT
THROUGH THE HAND SO IT'S IT'S
BEYOND.
JUST DWI R..
TIGHTEN UP THAT.
GOING TO GET HIM HOME LOOKING
FOR BECAUSE IF THE PROTOCOLS ARE
IN PLACE.
WE HAD A MASSIVE FAILURE BECAUSE
PARTICLES PART FOLLOWED IN SOME
FORM OF RESPECT OF THE REPAIRS.
THAT'S THE REPAIRS WERE DONE IN
THE APPROPRIATE FASHION.
IN THE WASN'T INTRUSION PIMP.
I'M SAYING POSSIBLY.
THE
FAILURE MAY HAVE BEEN MINIMIZED.
SO COULD WE SHOULD WRITE BUT.
WE DIDN'T DO THINGS
APPROPRIATELY IN.
AND CONCRETE I MEAN THERE'S
THREE THINGS IN LIFE DEATH TAXES
IN CONCRETE CRACKS OKAY.
GUARANTEED.
I'M WILL TALK WITH THE NEW
PANEL.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE COULD
CRACK CRACK OF CONCRETE AND IN
THE UP. THE NEW SPILLING HER IN
THE IN THE CURRENT.
OF.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
.
I'M I'M.
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT.
THERE IS NO. CONSISTENCY.
IN.
GOING OUT IN NUMBERS ACCOUNTABLE
HIS AS. I MEAN.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY DON'T DO IT
RIGHT ONLY ONE THAT PAYS FOR THE
ADDITIONAL REPAIRS ARE THEY ARE
THE FAILURE IS THE TAXPAYER?
THE AGENCY JUST CLOSE MY EYES AS
WE NEED TO DO WE NEED TO FIX IT.
.
SOMEONE LOOKING FOR.
IN THIS PROCESS.
THAT
THERE'S MORE THAN.
AND I THINK IT WAS. TOUCHED ON
BY MISTER PATTERSON.
SEPARATION OF CHURCH AND STATE
ONE COMES TO FOLLOW UP AND THAT
THEY DID TO REPAIRS WERE DONE
ACCORDANCE TO.
STRINGENT GUIDELINES.
.
AND THAT WE GO FORWARD. AND KNOW
THE FACT IS WE'RE GOING IN TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
PREVENT FUTURE. DEGRADATION OF
THE CONCRETE A REBAR WHATEVER
GOING FOR. SO HOW DO YOU.
HOW DOES HE W. OR LOOK AT THAT?
ON.
GOING FORWARD I MEAN. DIDN'T DO
YOU GUYS HAVE A PLAN. HARD TO
PUT THAT THAT UP BOUNCING CHECKS
AND BECAUSE IT WASN'T THERE
BEFORE.
I THINK. SO. I BELIEVE WE DO I
MEAN THE FORENSICS REPORT KIND
OF LAYS OUT THE LESSONS LEARNED
THAT WE HAVE TO INCORPORATE
THERE'S NO.
YEAH AND IF SOMEBODY'S WE
HAVEN'T INCORPORATED WE HAVE
ALREADY INITIATED AND JUST
RECENTLY. A DAM SAFETY
INITIATIVE.
AND THAT GROUP IS BEING LED
UNDER THE NEW EXECUTIVE THAT WE
PUT IS GONE IS ALREADY STARTED.
GOING TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WHO HAS A GOOD PROGRAMS
GOING TO THE BUREAU. NEXT WEEK.
THAT THEIR PROGRAM TO COME BACK.
AND THERE AND TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT AND USE AND USE THE.
p AYE SO FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND ONE
ASSET MANAGEMENT STANDARD
ENGINEERING STANDARDS WHICH WE
ALREADY USE PULL THEM ALL
TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH. WHAT
SHOULD OUR LOOK LIKE?
WHAT'S EXPERTISE THAT WE EITHER
HAVE DON'T HAVE OR NEED MORE.
AND WHAT'S THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
ENGINEERING AND SUPPORT STAFF
THAT WE DO TO TAKE ON THESE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT SO.
THAT INITIATIVE.
IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
WILL KIND OF.
FULFILL.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE HUMAN
FACTORS AYE.
THAT WILL START BEING ABLE TO
WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY AND LEAD
THE INDUSTRY ON FIXING. THE
INDUSTRY LESSONS LEARNED THAT WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO CHANGE SO
THERE IS A PLAN IN PLACE NOW.
FOR OROVILLE SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THAT'S BE THAT THAT'S
THE PLANNING STARTED IN MAY.
IT STARTED IN JANUARY THE ACTUAL
ASSESSMENT. AND WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH FOR THE SOD AND WE'RE
GETTING ANOTHER BORDER
CONSULTANTS
THAT WILL PRIMARILY LOOK AT
ORVILLE.
AND DO THESE DEEP DIVES FOR
EVERY COMPONENT. DAMS.
AND STRUCTURES SO FOR ORVILLE
SPECIFICALLY THAT'S A TWO YEAR
ASSESSMENT OUT OF IT WILL COME.
PROJECTS TO BUILD ANOTHER
SPILLWAY. WHAT DO WE DO WITH THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY?
THE THE THE THE WHOLE DAMN
ITSELF AND SO THOSE WILL BE OUR
ROADMAP ON NOT JUST WHAT WE DO
OR HELP CONSTRUCTION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUT MODERNIZE
IT IS YOU GUYS POINTED OUT.
BUT THEN WHAT IS OUR
ORGANIZATION LOOK LIKE BECAUSE
WE HAVE MORE DAMS.
AND THESE ASSESSMENTS HAVE
ALREADY STARTED FOR THE REST OF
THE DEPARTMENT DAMN DAMN ON HOME
DAMN. DAMN OWNS.
THAT WE HAVE AND THEN START TO
A EFFORTS THERE ALSO.
SWIM WISH WINTER. SO. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WAS
RECOMMENDED THAT THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY IT BE. LINED WITH
CONCRETE HOME EARLIER ON AND
THAT THE AGENCY.
DETERMINED THAT IT WASN'T
NECESSARY.
.
BOOKS.
SO.
WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE TALK ABOUT THE CUT OFF WHILE
WE TALKED ABOUT.
.
IN SOME OF THE. THINGS TO GO
FORWARD. BUT DO WE HAVE THAT
SITUATION IN OTHER.
DAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
OF THE WHERE YOU'VE MADE A
DETERMINATION WAS UNNECESSARY
AND THEN.
NOW YOU'RE AT RISK.
WELL. TWO THINGS AND THEN YOU
CAN.
AND AS WELL.
.
SO I JUST WANT TO ADD TO DOLE'S
DISCUSSION OF A COMPREHENSIVE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF IN TERMS OF
THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY FOR
OROVILLE.
PART OF THE LIST OF
POSSIBLE ENHANCEMENTS THAT WILL
BE LOOKING AT.
WE WILL CIRCLE BACK TO THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY TO SEE BEYOND
THE CUT OFF WALL IN THE
IMMEDIATE ACTIVITIES.
WHAT MORE SHOULD WE BE THINKING
ABOUT DOING THERE SO WE'LL
CIRCLE BACK TO THAT PARTICULAR
ONE? IN TERMS OF OF OTHER
SPILLWAYS ARE OR DAM FACILITIES
IT MIGHT BE SIMILAR I AM I THINK
THAT WILL COME OUT OF THESE.
EVALUATIONS IT ARE BEING
CONDUCTED ON NUMEROUS OTHER DAMS
THAT ARE SIMILAR IN SIZE AGAIN
AND DESIGN IN AN AGE
SO THAT.
THIS REEVALUATION.
IDEA THAT'S.
CAPTURED THEN DESCRIBE IN THE.
PRINCE EIGHTEEN REPORT IS
REALLY I THINK THIS NEXT WEEK WE
STARTED TO DO THAT IT'S THE NEXT
NEXT BIG STEP THAT GIVES US
INFORMATION.
PROBLY BETTER INFORMATION TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE MOVE AHEAD AND
WHAT SORT OF ENHANCEMENTS WE
MIGHT NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
IT THIS
THIS POINT THAT WE HADN'T.
I AM GOING TO GET TO THE NEXT
PANEL BUT I THINK. AND GET THE
QUESTION. OKAY.
.
LESSIMPORTANT THAN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE BUT I DO WANT TO I
ASK.
IN REGARDS TO BUY.
THINGS ARE IMPORTANT TO SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC A SPECIFIC
ORVILLE. WHAT SUPPORT IS BEING
GIVEN TO THE DOWNSTREAM
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THE
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
NOT DIMINISHED AS THE RESULT OF
THAT THIS?
I HOW DOES THE W. ARE PLANNED TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS TO
DOWNSTREAM COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
SETTLEMENT BUILDING.
NINE.
OKAY WELL.
WE ARE CURRENTLY HAVING
DIALOGUE WITH MEMBERS OF THE
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES TO TALK
ABOUT. THAT PARTICULAR ITEM AND
AND A FEW OTHERS AND WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL PLAN YET WE'RE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF AND.
REALLY UNDERSTANDING.
WHERE THE WHAT THE ISSUES ARE
WHERE THEY LIE WHAT THE CAUSES
HAVE BEEN?
THAT HAVE LED TO THOSE
PARTICULAR I'M ISSUES BUT.
IT IS MY INTENT THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND.
THERE IS A COALITION GOUP THAT
HAS FORMS THAT WE PARTICIPATE IN
MEETINGS WITH TO TO REALLY SORT
THROUGH.
THOSE PARTICULAR ITEMS THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF.
.
INFORMATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
PULLED TOGETHER AND SORTED
THROUGH TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT.
AMONG OTHER THINGS WHAT CANDY W.
R. DO IN TERMS OF OUR AUTHORITY
WHAT OTHER AGENCIES OR ENTITIES
MIGHT WE NEED TO ENGAGE IN THIS
DIALOGUE WHICH WE HAVE STARTED
OUT AS WELL TO TO SORT OF FIGURE
OUT HOW IF WE WANT TO MOVE AHEAD
WHO HAS TO BE INVOLVED. WHITES.
YOU KNOW WHERE THE.
OBSERVER HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
DESCRIBE THAT THAT WE WE NEED TO
GET THROUGH TO THEM REALLY. BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES.
CAN THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD WAS
A I'M AWARE THAT TO MANY OF THE
EVACUEES HAVE SUBMITTED CLAIMS
FOR DAMAGES.
I THAT THEY'VE INCURRED AS A
RESULT OF THE EVACUATION
WHILE I KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES IS HANDLING
THESE CLAIMS THE W. R. HAS
INDICATED THAT WOULD SUPPORT
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS.
THAT'S FAR EVERY CLAIM HAS BEEN
DENIED WHAT IS D. W. ARE.
DONE TO SUPPORT CLAIMS
BEING.
.
I DONE AS A RESULT.
SO THAT'S HOME.
THE TOUGH QUESTION JUST IN TERMS
OF THE G. D. GS AS ROLE IN THIS.
AND YES
CLAIMS HAVE BEEN DENIED THERE
ALSO ARE.
A COUPLE OF CLASS ACTION SUITS
THAT HAVE BEEN FILED WHICH.
I'M TOLD LIMITS ME IN MY ABILITY
TO.
SPEAK TOO MUCH TO THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC.
GALLAGHER BRIEFLY.
I THINK YOU MEANT CHAIR OF. THIS
IS SERIOUS BUSINESS YOU KNOW AND
AND I THINK ITS SERIOUS BUSINESS
FOR ALL OF US.
INSANE UP HERE BUT CERTAINLY.
FOR MYSELF.
HAVING BEEN AN EVACUEE MYSELF
MY FAMILY WAS AFFECTED BY THIS
INCIDENT.
MY CONSTITUENTS. HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY.
.
OVER THE YEARS YOU'RE NOT JUST
THIS INCIDENT.
BUT BY THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THIS REPORT.
SO. WHAT I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR
IS IS REALLY HEARING A FIRM
COMMITMENT OUT OF D. W. ARE? TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT UP IN THIS FRIENDS
IT REPORT AND I JUST WANNA
DETAIL.
VERY QUICKLY YOU NO. I THINK MR
FRANCE POINTED OUT TWO VERY BIG.
THERE'S THAT THINK THERE'S THREE
VERY FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
ORGANIZATIONAL PROBLEMS.
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
THIS REPORT BUT THERE'S A LOT IN
HERE BUT.
THAT ONE IS THE GEOLOGY THE WHAT
WHAT MR FRANCE CALLED THE MIS
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE GEOLOGY.
I THINK IN THE REPORT IT BECAUSE
IT A MYTHOLOGY.
REGARDING THE GEOLOGY THERE WAS
A REPORT.
DONE WHEN THIS DAM WAS BUILT
THAT CLEARLY IDENTIFIED.
WHETHER GROK IN THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY HILLSIDE. AND WHERE THE
GATED SPILLWAY WAS DONE.
AND OVER TIME.
THIS VERY CLEARLY SHOWS IN THE
REPORT THAT THE ORGANIZATION.
AT SOME POINT CREATED THIS
MYTHOLOGY THAT WAS ALL COMPANY
ROCK AND THERE WERE NO PROBLEMS.
AND IN FACT IN RESPONSE TO WHAT
WAS BROUGHT UP DURING THE FIRST
PROCESS.
THAT WAS BOLDLY ASSERTED THAT NO
THIS IS COMPANY ARRIVED IN THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
AND THERE WON'T BE THE KIND OF
HAD CUTTING EROSION. OF THAT WE
SAW.
IN FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THAT WAS INCORRECT.
AND SO THAT'S A BIG.
THE A MONUMENTAL FAILURE I
WOULD.
I WOULD CALL IT. A OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
.
THERE WAS CLEARLY A DESIGN FLAW.
IN THE ORIGINAL DESIGN OF THE
SPILLWAY.
THAT NOT ONLY MR FRIENDS AND HIS
TEAM IDENTIFIED IN THE EMBEDDED
DRAINS AND NOT SUFFICIENT
THICKNESS CRACKING THAT SOON
APPEARED AFTER THE CONSTRUCTION
OF IT. BUT PRETTY MUCH EVERY
EXPERT THAT'S LOOKED AT THIS IS
SAID THAT DESIGN WAS FLAWED.
AND AT NO POINT IN THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS.
DID ANYBODY EVER GO BACK AND
LOOK AT THAT DESIGN AND SAY YOU
KNOW WE HAVE PROBLEMS HERE WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
THAT'S A MONUMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONAL.
FAILURE.
BUT WHAT I ALSO WANT TO GET TO
IS THIS VERY CLEAR FINDING.
AND.
IN THE HUMAN FACTORS FRAMEWORK
APPENDIX.
PAGE J. TEN.
THAT IS CLEARLY STATES DWI OR
DID NOT HAVE A SUFFICIENTLY
STRONG DAM SAFETY CULTURE.
AND DAM SAFETY DID NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE PRIORITY RELATIVE TO
NON SAFETY GOALS.
SUCH AS DELIVERING WATER.
GENERATING POWER
AND CONTROLLING COSTS.
AND IS SAID TO MR FRANCES OUT A
PRETTY CLEAR.
DEPICTION OF SOME OF THE HUMAN
ORGANIZATIONAL PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE FACING HERE.
I THINK THERE'S ARE ALL CORRECT
DEPICTIONS INTERPRETATIONS OF
THE REPORT OKAY THANK YOU. AS A
NOW TO THE W. ARE WHAT I WANT TO
HEAR IS DO YOU AGREE.
WITH THESE FINDINGS.
OF THE INDEPENDENT FORENSIC
REPORT OF OF THESE FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN ORGANIZATIONAL PROBLEMS.
AND I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR YES
OR NO ANSWER.
AND THE MUCH AND THE FOLLOW UP
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW IS OKAY.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO TO TO
ADDRESS?
THOSE VERY CLEAR.
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE BEEN SPELLED
OUT IN THIS INDEPENDENT THE
FORENSIC ANALYSIS.
I WISH I COULD GIVE YOU AYE YES
SERRANO I THINK MY ANSWER IS IN
PART WE AGREE I THINK THERE ARE.
SOME STATEMENTS IN THE FRIENDS
EIGHTEEN REPORT THAT WE DON'T
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH AT THIS
POINT.
BUT I CAN SAY THAT YES MOVING
FORWARD WE ARE COMMITTED TO
LOOKING AT FOR EXAMPLE AS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE FULL
REEVALUATION.
UP OF THE SPILLWAY.
THE OTHER ASSOCIATED STRUCTURES
APPLYING IT TO OUR FACILITIES
ASKING OTHER DAM OWNERS TO ALSO
GO THROUGH THIS EXERCISE SO THAT
WE CAN.
MOVE FORWARD AND ADDRESS.
THE ISSUES AND HAVE THAT DATA
SAID.
BE.
CURRENT AND I KNOW ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
HAS TO DO WITH INFORMATION
MANAGEMENT I THINK THAT'S VERY
KEY AS WE MOVE ALONG. THIS IS
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION THAT
CANNOT GET LOST IT MUST BE
PULLED FORWARD.
EACH TIME WE DO INSPECTIONS EACH
TIME WE'RE DOING SOME REPAIRS IT
HAS TO BE LOOKED AT AGAIN I
THINK THAT'S A CHANGE.
ON THAT WE WILL INSTITUTE MOVING
AHEAD THAT IS DIFFERENT.
AND I BELIEVE ADDRESSES.
COUPLE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE REPORT.
OKAY BUT DO YOU BELIEVE THE YOU
HAVE A SUFFICIENTLY STRONG DAM
SAFETY CULTURE.
RIGHT NOW.
AND DOES IT ADEQUATELY
PRIORITIZE DAM SAFETY RELATIVE
TO THE NON SAFETY GOALS OF
DELIVERING WATER GENERATING
POWER CONTROLLING COSTS.
I BELIEVE THAT WE DO PRIORITIZE
DIEM SAFETY IS THE GROUP BIG
ENOUGH NO WE HAVE. A CORE GROUP.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THE ADMINISTRATION
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
BOLSTER THAT GROUP SO THAT WE
CAN.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD HAVE THE
EXPERTISE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO THIS DEEPER DIVE IN TERMS OF
DAM SAFETY AND INSPECTIONS AND.
CHANGES TO THE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS THAT WE ANTICIPATE
WILL HAPPEN.
SO.
RIGHT OPINION IS IT IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT WILL
IT DOES IT.
WARRANT SOME ENHANCEMENTS
ABSOLUTELY.
LET ME JUST GIVE HER A QUICK
EXAMPLE THAT WAS IDENTIFIED
REPORT MISTER FRIENDS MAYBE YOU
CAN.
HELP ELABORATE ON THIS DURING
THE EMERGENCY INCIDENT.
YOU IDENTIFY THAT THERE WAS TWO
VERY CRITICAL DECISIONS MADE.
REGARDING SENDING FLOWS DOWN
THE REGULAR SPILLWAY THAT WAS
BROKEN AT THE TIME.
TWO KEY POINTS WHERE BASICALLY
FLOWS WERE REDUCED.
OR THEY WERE DELAYED.
A BECAUSE THERE WAS TWO GROUPS.
WITHIN THE W. ARE AT THE TIME.
ONE THAT WAS SAYING. NON THAT
THE GREATER RISK WAS LOSING THE
POWER HOUSE.
AND ANOTHER THAT WAS MUCHMORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY.
BECAUSE. AT THIS POINT THEY HAD
ACTUALLY PULLED THAT YELLED YOU
POURED OUT THE SHELF.
AND PEOPLE WOULD SAID YOU KNOW
WE GOT SOME REAL PROBLEMS WITH
THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY TWO
GROUPS.
WHO?
WORSE YOU KNOW AND ULTIMATELY
THE GROUP THAT WANTED TO SAVE
THE POWERHOUSE THAT THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS THE GREATER RISK ONE
OUT. YOU DESCRIBE THAT IN THE.
AT LEAST ONE OF THE REASONS.
BEHIND THE DECISION TO SAY THE
POWER HOUSE WAS THE CONCERN OVER
WATER DELIVERIES.
FOR LATER IN THE SUMMER OF THAT
YEAR. IS IS THAT A CORRECT
DEPICTION OF YOUR FINER THAN ME
ELABORATE IS.
HOWEVER YOU LIKE MR FRETS BUT IS
THAT ONE OF THE.
IS THAT AN EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE
ISSUES HERE WE SAY THE.
THE DAM SAFETY COMPONENT IS OUT
OF BALANCE WITH OTHER NON SAFETY
CONCERNS.
BUT AGAIN AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
IT'S.
IT IS DIFFICULT PUT YOURSELF IN
THE PLACE IN THE THE PLACE TO
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE ROOM
THAT THE DEPICTION OF THE THE
INFORMATION COMING FROM THE TWO
SIDES IS CORRECT THAT'S WHAT WE
HEARD IS THAT.
THE DECISION MAKERS WERE BEING
ADVISED.
BY ONE GROUP THAT THE THE
PARAMOUNT CONCERN WAS THE
POWERHOUSE ANOTHER GROUP WAS
VERY CONCERNED AND AND THOUGHT
IT WAS A MORE IMPORTANT
CONCERNED THAT WE NOT OPERATE
THAT EMERGENCY SPILLWAY KNOWING
WHAT THE NEW AT THAT POINT IN
TIME.
OF WHAT WENT INTO THAT DECISION
AND THE CONFIDENCE IN THE MODELS
THAT GOOD MERCY SO IT WOULDN'T
BE USED. THAT'S WHERE I WASN'T
IN THE ROOM WHEN I DIE I DON'T
KNOW SO I CAN ABSOLUTELY FALL
THAT DECISION I MIGHT HAVE MADE
THE SAME THING SAME DECISION AND
AND IF I WERE IN THE SAME PLACE.
IT IT IS A.
BECAUSE IT WILL WE DON'T KNOW.
IS EXACTLY.
WITH THE STRUCTURE OF THE DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM BEING WHAT IT WAS
WITHIN DWL R.. HAD IT HAD A
HIGHER PROFILE WOULD ITS VOICE
HAVE BEEN HEARD MORE LOUDLY AT
THAT PARTICULAR POINT TIME
PERHAPS YES.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE PERHAPS AN EXAMPLE OF OF
OF THE CULTURE.
COULD SIDE OF SIDE OF THINGS.
SO.
IT'S I DON'T WANNA FAULT THAT
THE CIVIC HAD WE'VE.
WE TRIED TO WRITE THE REPORT AS
CAREFUL AS WE COULD BUT
SOMETHING SOMETIMES THING SCREAM
OUT MORE LOUDLY THAT WE WANTED
TO SCREAM OUT I THINK THIS MAY
BE A BIT ONE WE REALLY DON'T
WANT TO SAY WE WE'RE NOT SAYING
THAT WAS A WRONG DECISION.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE IN
EMERGENCIES LIKE THAT THERE
AREN'T WRONG DECISIONS YOU'RE
MAKING THE BEST DECISION YOU CAN
WITH WHAT YOU KNOW.
THEY THE CULTURE IDEA IS THAT
HE GOES BACK TO THE CULTURE IN
THE BALANCE.
GOES BACK TO THIS QUESTION OF
WHEN ANY ORGANIZATION HAS ITS
LIMITS ON AN AMOUNT OF MONEY IT
HAS IT HAS IT HAS AVAILABLE AND
IT HAS DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES.
AND WHILE WE'RE ALL WE'RE TRYING
TO SAY THIS REPORTS WE THINK
RIGHT NOW WITH WHERE THE DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM IS WITHIN THE O.
M. ORGANIZATION. AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT BEING AS FAR AS WE
COULD UNDERSTAND REGULAR
BRIEFINGS TO JOE OR ANOTHER
EXECUTIVE.
ON THE DAM SAFETY PROGRAM THAT
IT PERHAPS IS IN GETTING ITS
VOICE IN BALANCE WITH SOME OF
THOSE OTHER OBJECTIVES AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT HAVE A. BIT OF A
LOUDER AND MORE PROMINENT VOICE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN THEIR
DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO THAT.
A DIFFERENT WAYS FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN AND THAT'S FOR THAT'S THE
PUZZLE FOR DWI TO FIGURE OUT IS
HOW BILL IT.
AND THEN AND THEN PEOPLE WERE
INVOLVED IN DAM SAFETY TO REALLY
FEEL FREE THAT THEY CAN RAISE
ISSUES.
AND AND AND DAM SAFETY GETS ITS
VOICE.
SIMILAR IN GALLAGHER.
AND CHAIRMAN IF YOU WOULD MIND
I MEAN IF I COULD ADD A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT I WAS IN THE ROOM
NOT FOR EVERY MEETING WHILE THAT
WAS GOING ON AND CHAO'S ACTUALLY
GONNA GET TO THAT CERTAINLY
COULD YOU KNOW BECAUSE I KNOW
JOE YOU WERE PART OF THE.
INCIDENT COMMAND YOU KNOW I MEAN
I'M JUST.
FOR APPENDIX CELL I THINK
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD LOOK AT IT BECAUSE IT
REALLY SHOWS WHAT HAPPENED ON
THE TIMELINE.
AND THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE
GOING ON BUT I JUST READ FROM A
COUPLE BUT CAN ARTS AND THERE IS
AND I'LL ASK YOU KNOW ASK YOU TO
RESPOND JEWELERS.
.
AT ONE POINT EXECUTIVE SAYS THE
PLANT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY. IN TERMS OF
PRIORITY
.
ONE FEBRUARY TENTH THERE WAS A
DECISION MADE.
.
TO TAKE THE FLOWS THERE OF SPILL
IS RUNNING AT SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND CFS.
AT THAT TIME.
AND THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
ACTUALLY TALE REYES WAS GOING
DOWN SO THE THREAT OF FLOODING
TO THE POWER HOUSE.
NOW WAS NOT A MINUTE AT THAT
TIME IT WAS DECREASING.
AT THAT TIME. AND THERE WAS A
MANAGEMENT DECISION MADE.
.
TO LOWER THE LEVELS FROM SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND A FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND IS DETAILED THAT. HAD
THE KEPT RUNNING AT SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND WE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN TO
EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY.
.
BUT THERE WAS A DECISION MADE TO
LOWER BACK DOWN TO FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND THAT DECISION WAS MADE.
QUOTE HERE AND ON PAGE EL TEN
THERE WAS SILENCE RATHER THAN
EXPLICIT AGREEMENT.
FROM MOST AND THOSE MOST
PREVIOUSLY VOCAL IN THEIR
OPPOSITION WERE NOT PART OF THE
DECISION INCLUDING THE CHIEF DAM
SAFETY OFFICER.
.
THAT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT.
THERE WHEN THAT DECISION WAS
MADE.
IT ALSO STATES THE INCIDENT
COMMAND DISAGREED WITH THAT.
DECISION.
AND ALL.
POINT TO THAT POINT IN THE.
REPORT.
I DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT OF ME
RIGHT NOW THAT. LEAH THE
INCIDENT COMMAND THAT DISAGREE
WITH THAT AND TRY TO OVERTURN
MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT SAID THE
DECISIONS ALREADY BEEN MADE.
WE'RE KEEPING IT FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND. CFS.
YOU WERE INCIDENT COMMAND I
BELIEVE DURING THAT POINT IS
THAT DID YOU HAVE A DISAGREEMENT
WITH MANAGEMENT OVER WHETHER NOT
TO REDUCE THOSE FLOWS. SO I WAS
NOT THE INCIDENT COMMANDER BUT I
WAS PART OF THE INCIDENT COMMAND
TEAM AND SO. HAVE I REALLY WANT
TO STEP BACK AND PUT YOU IN THAT
SITUATION BECAUSE I THINK I WAS
NOT PART OF THE INTERVIEW SO I
DON'T.
WHAT WAS SAID TO THE FORENSICS
TEAM AND WHAT THEIR DISCUSSIONS
WERE AROUND HOW THEY CONCLUDED
R. WROTE THAT BUT I CAN TELL YOU
FROM BEING A MEMBER THAT WAS UP
THERE AND WAS AYE AT EVERY
MEETING MEL? WAS I AND MANY
MEETINGS AS WE WERE MAKING
DECISIONS YES I THINK THE POINTS
I CAN MAKE IS THAT. FROM
FEBRUARY SEVENTH.
FOR WAS ONSITE VSO DE WAS ON
SITE.
CONSULTANTS WERE ONSITE DAM
SAFETY EXPERTS WERE ON SITE FROM
THAT POINT FORWARD. EVERY
DECISION.
TO CHANGE THE FLOW OF THE
SPILLWAY. WAS DONE WITH ALL
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM.
THERE WAS IN MY RECOLLECTION AND
WHERE I WAS THERE IT WAS NEVER A
ONE PERSON DECISION IT WAS A
CONSENSUS FOR BRINGING ENOUGH
INFORMATION FROM ALL GROUPS.
WHILE THERE WAS GEOLOGISTS THEY
WERE SAYING AND THERE'S BAD ROCK
IN THE.
EMERGENCY SPILLWAY THERE WERE
ALSO GEOLOGISTS WHO WERE SAYING
AND. THERE'S BAD ROCK BAD ROCK
UNDER THE SPILLWAY AND WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO ERODE IT. SO THERE
WAS RISKS IN ALL THOSE AREAS
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO MANAGE IT
WASN'T A SINGLE ONE THAT WAS
BEING FOCUSED IS CAN WE FIND.
FLOWS
THAT MAKE THE WHOLE SITUATION
AND COME OUT WITH THE BEST
OUTCOME AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE
WERE MANAGING THROUGH AND
OBVIOUSLY IN A CRISIS. THERE'S
INFORMATION FROM A LOT EXPERTS
COMING IN FROM A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AREAS IN THE HARD PART
AT THAT MOMENT A TIME IS AT RISK
IS HARD TO CALCULATE. AT EVERY
MOMENT A TIME AND YOURS YOU'RE
TAKING IN THAT INFILL MAKING
DECISIONS SO THEY.
WHEN WE DECIDED TO MOVE TO FLOWS
FROM SIXTY FIVE TO FIFTY FIVE IT
WAS BECAUSE THE MODELING WAS
SHOWING THAT THAT. WAS ENOUGH TO
KEEP THE WATER AWAY FROM FLOWING
OVER THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
THAT WAS PUTTING THE IN THE.
FLOOD CONTROL OUTLET SPILLWAY
IN LESS RISK OF CONTAINING DO
ROAD WHICH WE WERE SAYING SO WE
WERE SEEN THAT HAPPENED IT
WASN'T LIKE A RISK THAT COULD
HAPPEN WE WERE SEEN CHUNKS OF A
HUNDRED FEET. OF SPILLWAY.
ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS IS BEING
LOST
AND WE HAD THOSE TRIGGERS OF.
WE CANNOT LET IT GET TO A POINT.
WHERE IT MAKES THAT SPILLWAYS
UNSERVICEABLE AND NOW YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE? IT'S BASICALLY
A RUN OF THE RIVER DAM WHERE
WHATEVER'S COMING AND IS COMING
OUT WE CANNOT AND THAT THERE SO.
IT WAS TRYING TO MANAGE ALL
RISKS.
AND TAKE PUBLIC SAFETY AS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY. AND FIND THAT
SWEET SPOT WHERE IS EVERY
DECISION PERFECT.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THEY WERE DECISIONS THAT
WERE BEST A SITUATION THAT WE
HAD AND I THINK THAT'S.
KIND OF WHAT I HEARD THE
FORENSICS TEAM SAY WHEN ASKED
WOULD THEY DO ANYTHING
DIFFERENT.
RIGHT AND AGAIN I THINK IT'S
BEEN SO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO YOU
KNOW SECOND GUESS EVERY DECISION
THAT WAS MADE IN THERE BUT THERE
WERE DECISIONS BEING MADE IN
THERE WAS A DECISION MADE
ULTIMATELY.
TO REDUCE THAT FLOW FROM SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND CFS TO FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND CFS NO ONE AGAIN AND
ALL THE DETAILS BUT. IT'S ALSO
VERY CLEARLY SPELLED OUT HERE
THAT THE EROSION AT THE SPILLWAY
AND ACTUALLY STABILIZED AT THAT
POINT. HAS HAD THE STABILIZATION
OF THE POWER OF THE POWER LINE
THAT PEOPLE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
BUT.
DID THE VERY CLEAR FINDING HERE
IN NOT JUST RELATED TO THE
EMERGENCY INCIDENT.
BUT JUST ACROSS THE BOARD IS
THAT PUBLIC SAFETY PRIORITY IS
OUT OF BALANCE WITH OTHER NON
SAFETY PRIORITIES THAT IS THE
FINDING OF THIS REPORT.
THAT'S VERY CLEAR IS THAT RIGHT
MR FRANCE.
THAT'S PERHAPS STATED A LITTLE
MORE STRONGLY THAN I WOULD
STATED OR I THINK THE REPORT
STATES IT BUT.
IT DID.
THE DAM SAFETY WE THINK NEEDS A
LOUDER VOICE THAN IT HAS.
.
AND AND TO BE ISSUE TO BE MORE
CONFIDENT THAT ALL THOSE.
OBJECTIVES ARE IN BALANCE.
AND WHAT I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE
I'VE HEARD FROM MISS YOU MR
PATTERSON ASKED YOU A QUESTION
YOU SAID WE DON'T QUITE AGREE
THAT WE'RE OVERCONFIDENT. WE
DON'T QUITE AGREE THAT WERE
COMPLACENT.
I'M HERE AND WE DON'T REALLY
QUITE AGREE THAT WERE OUT OF
BALANCE ON.
PUBLIC SAFETY OF THE FIRST PART
OF THIS WHOLE THING OF CHANGE
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS
ADMITTING THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM.
AND THERE'S A LOT TO DO IN THIS
AND I KNOW IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO HEAR IDW R.
WE AGREE WITH THESE FINDINGS.
WE AGREE THERE'S A PROBLEM.
AND WERE GOING TO.
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THESE AND
OTHER SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
IN HERE.
THAT ARE TWO D. W. ARE NOT TO
THE INDUSTRY AT LARGE BUT TO D.
W. ARE.
ARE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTED BY YOU.
AND WOULD YOU AND AND I AS JUST
A QUICK FAULT THAT WOULD YOU BE
OPEN TO HAVING MR FRANCE MAYBE
THE FORENSIC TEAM OR AN OUTSIDE
BODY STAY ON. TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE ARE IMPLEMENTED
ADEQUATELY.
OKAY WELL I WILL START SO WHILE
I HAVE BEEN THE ONE WHO IS SAID
I DON'T QUITE AGREE. ON THOSE
VARIOUS FACETS.
THERE IS.
A PORTION IN ALL OF THOSE THAT I
DO AGREE WITH AN EVEN IF I DON'T
THIS IS.
THE FOR THE.
WE NEED TO TAKE A HALF STEP BACK
WE NEED TO APPROACH THIS.
FRESH EYES WITH EGO CHECKED AT
THE DOOR WITH HEY THIS IS ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD ABOUT MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS ENHANCEMENTS DOING
THINGS DIFFERENTLY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT AND HOW THAT CAN
MODEL THE WAY.
FOR THE INDUSTRY ITSELF SO YES
WE ARE COMMITTED TO.
IMPLEMENTING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THIS REPORT DO WE HAVE ALL
THAT SORTED OUT NOT QUITE YET
WE'RE STILL GOING THROUGH THE
REPORT ITSELF AS MR FRANCE SAID
WE.
WE'RE NOT GIVING.
IN ADVANCE COPY THE DRAFT OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT'S A WORSE
STILL GOING THROUGH IT AND.
FIGURE OUT WHAT OUR GAME PLAN
IS.
TWO MOVIES FOR AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE COULD COME BACK.
OBVIOUSLY BUT IT WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER BAKED WE CAN
KIND OF LAY IT OUT FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE'D BE HAPPY
TO DO THAT.
SO THERE IS A COMMITMENT I WILL
SAY THAT YES TO IMPLEMENTING NOW
ABOUT TO HAVE AN OUTSIDE EXPERT
BODY.
HELPING WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THOSE.
SO IS PART OF THIS A
COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
WE ARE HIRING A.
FLORIDA CONSULTANTS PER SE AND
WILL AGAIN LIKE LIKE THE BORDER
CONSOLES IN THE FORENSICS TEAM
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO THIS DANCE
SAFETY ORGANIZATION.
HAVE THEM PICK YOU KNOW THE
EXPERTS IN THE WORLDAND HAVE
THEM BE ANOTHER CONSOLE ABOARD A
CONSULTANT'S BASICALLY TO REVIEW
OUR FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
YES.
PRIVATE I MEAN BECAUSE WE KNOW
MORE ABOUT THIS JEWEL THAT I
THINK THERE'S MAYBE SOMETHING'S
BEEN THE CONFERENCE OF NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURES ABOUT THE
FACILITY UP THERE AND LOOKING AT
ALL OF IT. AND WHAT MAYBE NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED YOUR APPROVED.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ABOUT
PROCESS OKAY SEE OTHERS AS WELL
YOUR AYE AND SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
THERE'S OTHER THINGS HERE
INVOLVED IT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO
HAVE OUTSIDE EXPERTS
AS ONE OF THE CRITICISMS IS THAT
YOU GUYS ARE AN INSULAR
ORGANIZATION.
NOW YOU YOU ARE THAT THERE'S
AGREEMENT AND THAT SOMETIMES
AGREEMENTS NOT RIGHT.
SO HAVING.
YOU NO OUTSIDE PEOPLE HELP GUIDE
THAT AND SURE THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPEN THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU GUYS
WILL DO AND THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THERE IS A BORDER
CONSULTANT SPEAKS ON THE ON THE.
COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS ASSESSMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S MORE OF A VERY
SPECIFIC POWER BILL BUT YES
THERE WILL BE ABOARD A
CONSULTANT LOOKS AT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON BOLSTERING.
OUR OUR CULTURE OUR WHOLE DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM SO THAT THERE
WILL BE
A SEPARATE SET OF.
CONSULTANTS OUTSIDE EXPERTS
WAYNE AND ON THAT.
THANK YOU SKILLS.
PROCURE. UM.
AND YOU KNOW MISTER GALLAGHER
REPRESENTS HEARING HE SAID HE
WAS SOMEBODY WHO'S EVACUATED
AND.
CERTAINLY AS SOMEBODY WHO
REPRESENTS A DELTA AND HIS WOULD
BE. THE RECIPIENT OF ALL THAT
WATER IF IT SHOULD.
HE SHOULD HAVE COME DOWN
EVERYTHING SHOULD HAVE FAILED.
WE KNOW THAT. THIS IS AND YOU
ARE MAKING IN REAL TIME. OR ARE
IS A MUCH DIFFERENT SITUATION
THAN REVIEWING. THINGS IN AND
BEING ABLE TO SIT UP HERE.
BUT I DO THINK THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I MEAN IF NOT HAVING A
CONSULTANT DURING
IMPLEMENTATION.
I THINK ANOTHER FORENSIC LOOK AT
THE IMPLEMENTATION WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA AND PERHAPS ANOTHER
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE HEARING.
DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA ABOUT HOW
LONG THE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WILL TAKE AT
THIS POINT.
THAT'S.
YEAH I WAS GONNA SAY FOUR TO SIX
MONTHS.
JUST WE GET HAVE SOMETHING
THAT'S WELL THOUGHT OUT AT THE.
BRING BACK OKAY. BENSON HURDLE
SOMEONE TO MAKE UP.
ASK A QUESTION BUT IT AGAINST
IT WE HAVE ANOTHER PANEL COMING
UP ON DAM SAFETY WOULD YOU
RATHER HOLD FOR THAT SEE THAT
COMMITTEE OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ASK YOUR QUESTION NOW.
OKAY.
I'M LOOKING.
THANK YOU CENTER OF.
AND I THINK THAT CHAIRS OF THE
COMMITTEES FOR ALLOW ME TO BE
HERE TODAY THIS IS NOT THE HOUSE
AYE SERBIAN BUT. AS.
WOULD ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER I
REPRESENT THE AREA AND WE'VE. OF
CHALLENGES.
UP.
SEND EIGHT THAT WILL BE ONE OF
THE ISSUES IS.
THE STRUCTURE ON THE CULTURE OF
THE ORGANIZATION NOW EVERY
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY.
GETS OSSIFIED BECOMES INSULAR
WHATEVER IT HAPPENS.
D. W. ARE IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE
AND I THINK THE FORENSIC REPORT
DID POINT THAT OUT FOR DECADES.
LET ME ABOUT FIFTY YEARS.
CERTAIN THINGS ARE NOT ATTENDED
TO.
WHAT INSPECTIONS DID OCCUR?
SOME KIND OF THINGS DID NOT
HAPPEN.
ONE OF MY FIRST QUESTION IS DID
YOU DO ANY BORING. BUSH BORE
DOWN INTO THE FIRMAMENT AND TO
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON UNDERNEATH
SEVEN THE GALLAGHER DID SOME
RESEARCH AND JUST SUFFICE TO SAY
THERE WAS NOT MUCH BORING DOT.
MORE SURFACE INSPECTION.
AND THEN NOT ATTENDING TO THOSE
SIX.
THAT BEING THE CASE THEN.
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS
WHAT?
KIND OF OVERSIGHT PROSPECTIVELY
CAN OCCUR.
ASSOCIATIONS TO. THAT DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HIRING
CONSULTANTS THAT'S FINE.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME OTHER
MORE STRUCTURAL CHANGES
NOW ONE OF THE DRASTIC ONES
WOULD BE TO TAKE THE DIVISION OF
DAM SAFETY AND HAVE IT NOT
REPORT TO D. W. ARE BUT MAYBE
DIRECTLY TO THE RESOURCE A
SECRETARY.
I'M JUST THROWING THAT OUT KIND
OF RHETORICALLY NOT SAYING I
PROPOSED IT.
BUT IT'S A THOUGHT.
AND.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME CHANGES.
AND ON THE TIMELINE.
THERE'S ANOTHER ISSUE.
SOMEONE GALLAGHER AND I HAVE
COMMUNICATED TO THE FEDERAL AND
DIRECTOR COMMISSION AND A BACK
PERSONALLY HAVE MET WITH THEM.
MEMBERS THEREOF.
A WITH THE CONCERN ABOUT NOT
PROCEEDING WITH THE
CERTIFICATION UNTIL THESE ISSUES
ARE ADDRESSED AND HANDLED TO THE
COMFORT OF.
EVERYBODY.
AND IN THEIR SUBMISSION TO YOU
JANUARY TENTH.
THEY ARE THAT THIS IS FOR
FEDERAL INJURING HER COMMISSION.
AT THEY ARE ASKING THAT YOU
FORMING SUBMIT A COPY OF THE
REPORT OF THE WRECKED FOR THE
RECORD JUST FOR WITHIN THE NEXT
SEVEN DAYS AND WAS WHICH.
THE SUBSTANTIAL WITH THE
SUBMITTAL PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INITIAL COMMENTS OR
CLARIFICATIONS YOU MAY HAVE
REGARDING REPORT.
AND LASTLY A VERY IMPORTANTLY
THEY SAY WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
THE LETTER SUBMIT A PLAN AND
SCHEDULE TO ADDRESS THE
FINDINGS.
NOW YOU'RE SAN FOR SIX MONTHS.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR A PLAN.
CAN YOU HAVE A PLAN SUBMITTED TO
FOR WITHIN. THAT TIMELINE FORTY
TO SIXTY DAYS A PAN OF
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES RAISED
ABOUT THE DEFICIENCIES.
TAKE CARE.
I THINK YOU KNOW THE AND WE JUST
GOT THAT LETTER THIS MORNING SO
THANK YOU.
YES WE WERE WE HAVE TO COMPLY
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PLAN
INTO THEM.
THE DAYS BUT I THINK THE ADDED
TIME THAT KIND I WHISPERED.
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR WAS SO
THAT WE CAN TURN THAT PLANET WE
TURN INTO FOR INTO MORE OF A
STATE PLAN. YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
GET IT DONE WITHIN THIS YOU KNOW
OUR OUR INFRASTRUCTURE SO I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE OURSELVES A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME.
TWO BE ABLE TO NOT GIVE YOU SEE
MAYBE A HIGH LEVEL PLAN THAT WE
BE TURNING AND FOR BUT MAYBE A
MORE DETAILED PLAN THAT.
IF YOU GUYS AT QUESTIONS WE GET
ANSWERS SO WE DO INTEND TO DO
THAT.
THEN IT SPEECH GOTO AND AND I
WAS GONNA SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
THAT YES I THINK.
THAT WOULD BE AN INITIAL HIGH
LEVEL KIND OF SKETCHED OUT PLAN
BUT.
SORT OF EVEN BACK TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON'S
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT KEEPS ME UP
AT NIGHT THE FOUR TO SIX MONTHS
IN MY. MIND IS A PLAN THAT IS
MORE DETAIL THAT REALLY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT WE IDENTIFY CLEARLY
WHO'S DOING WHAT WHAT ARE THE
MECHANISMS TO IMPLEMENT TO
ACCOUNT FOR TO REPORT SO IT
WOULD BE A.
A. MORE ROBUST PLAN IF YOU WILL
DETAILED THAT REALLY SKETCHES
THINGS OUT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
AND ILLUSTRATES HOW WE'VE
CHANGES WE'VE MADE.
HOW WE MADE SHIFT
SOME? ACTIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO PRIORITIZE WERE
MOVED RESOURCES TO THIS
PARTICULAR AREA SO I THINK IT'LL
COME INTO FACES IS PROBABLY THE
SHORT ANSWER TO LET ME DOWN
EMPHASIZE SOMETHING THAT THAT I
AM LOOKING FOR AN EXPECTED.AS
YOU PROCEED PROSPECTIVELY TO
ADDRESS THESE AREAS OF CHANGE.
THAT THEY BE DONE IN AN OPEN
PUBLIC PROCESS I ASKED THE
QUESTION IN A RECENT MEETING
WHERE THESE GOING TO BE IF MUCH.
EMBODIED AND REGULATIONS AND
EFFECTIVE THROUGH REGULATION AND
IT WAS KIND OF THERE WAS
RESISTANCE TO THE DEPARTMENT.
IF YOU SEPARATE DO IT BY D. O.
M. DEPARTMENT OPERATION MANUAL
OR BUT BY EDICT WELL THAT'S NOT
REALLY PERMIT. AND IT DOESN'T
AND AND THE REASON I'M PUSHING
SO HARD.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
IN SOCIETY IN CALIFORNIA BUT
PARTICULAR IN THE AREA THE MOST
AFFECTED.
THERE'S NO TRUST.
THE AGENCY IS NOT TRUST.
AND I'LL SAY THAT SOMEONE
GALLAGHER AND I DON'T.
TRUST YOU EITHER IN MANY
RESPECTS WE LIKE YOU PERSONALLY.
AND EVEN GREAT UNDER THE
PRESSURE YOU HAVE CUT TO CONTEND
WITH INCREDIBLY.
BUT THERE'S NO TRUST IN THAT HAS
GOT TO BE ELEVATED AND IT'S GOT
TO BE ELEVATED IN THE WAY THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE ASSURED THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE SUSTAINING. SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO WHAT YOU CAN
AND REGULATION.
BECAUSE IT ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE PROCESS IS VERY
FORMAL.
AND THE PUBLIC DOES HAVE INPUT.
AND YOU CAN'T CHANGE IT WITHOUT
DOING ANOTHER REGULATION.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WHATEVER
YOU DO HAS GOT TO HAVE A
STATUTORY FOUNDATION
SO PLEASE DO. CONSIDER THAT.
AS WE PROCEED AND LET JUST LET
ME EMPHASIZE THAT THAT ISSUE.
OF THE TRUST.
AND THEN THE THAT. THE
SILTATION.
AND DREDGING OF THE CHANNELS.
THIS IS BEEN A BIG ISSUE THOSE
AFFECTED OUR FISHERY.
AND WE GOT A HECK OF A PROBLEM
THIS YEAR.
OF A GOOD WATER YEAR.
BUT A BAD YEAR FOR.
KIND OF DESTROYING.
HABITAT.
FOR THE REWRITE.
AND IS NOT GOING TO BE A PART OF
YOUR PLAN.
DREDGING PARTS UP AND DOWN THAT
RIVER NOW YOU DREDGED IN FRONT
AT THE FOOT OF THE DAM AND
THAT'S ALL OUT.
BUT DOWNSTREAM THERE'S AN AWFUL
LOT OF.
BUT OF SELF.
AND ACTUALLY YOU HAVE THE UP THE
SNAG.
MANY TREES WE WATCHING GO BY IN
FRONT OF OUR HOUSE.
RIGHT DOWN THE RIVER.
THEY HANG UP AND THINGS THAT GO
BUMP ON THAT WITH IS THAT GOING
TO BE A PART OF ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES. BUT SOMETHING REGARDING
GETTING THAT SILT AND THOSE.
TREES OUT OF THE LA RIVER
CHANNEL.
SO I THINK THE WAY HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS AND AGAIN I'M
SORRY I'M NOT GONNA GIVE YOU AN
ABSOLUTE YES OR NO AT AT THIS
POINT BUT IT'S IT'S KIND OF.
RELATED SCHOOL SO WE HAVE YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY DAM SAFETY.
AND THE FACILITIES UP THERE
EVERYTHING.
THING THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WITH THE PRINCE AKEEM
REPORT THAT WE'RE GONNA TO SET
INTO MOTION. THERE'S ALSO THE
LICENSE THAT.
BRINGS AND OTHER ELEMENTS NOT
HOME ENTIRELY UNRELATED BUT YOU
KNOW. KIND OF.
THE ADDED BENEFIT OF
IMPROVEMENTS AND THEN. THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING WITH THE COALITION THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE HAVE I KIND OF
THINK OF RIGHT NOW IS THAT THIRD
LEG OF THE STOOL. THERE ARE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE OBVIOUSLY
RELATED.
TO THE OTHER TWO BUT I THINK
WE'RE STILL AT A POINT WHERE WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
IF THEY'RE NOT HOW DO WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEM TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE AND FOR ME
I'M STILL KEEPING THAT ONE.
SENTIMENT REMOVAL MAYBE THINGS
LIKE SNAGS.
IN THAT.
THIRD LEG.- UNTIL WE CAN REALLY
SORT OUT
HOW OLD.
HOW WE CAN MOVE AHEAD WHAT KIND
OF ENHANCEMENTS IMPROVEMENTS
COULD BE MADE THERE BECAUSE IT'S
JUST? IT IT DOESN'T CLEANLY FIT
JUST YET AND TO THE OTHER TWO
AND THAT'S THAT'S BEEN.
LAST POINT I'D MAKE IS IT AND I
APPRECIATE THE YEAR AGREEMENT TO
WORK WITH ME ON THIS CONCEPT.
IT'S OVERSIGHT.
AND IN THAT GOVERNS EVERYTHING
BUT ONE ASPECT OFTHE OVERSIGHT
THAT IS NECESSARY IS LOCAL.
INVOLVEMENT.
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE MOST
AFFECTED BY WHAT GOES ON WITH
THE DAM.
AND A LOT MORE THAN JUST A
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND.
ARE AFFECTED BY IT.
AND IN FACT IT'S THE KIND OF THE
KEY OF THE WHOLE STATE WATER
PROJECT SO MANY MILLIONS.
ARE AFFECTED BY BUT I HAVE
SUGGESTED.
SOME KIND OF A.
NOT A FORMAL REGULATORY
AUTHORITY WE DO NOT NEED ANYMORE
OF THOSE.
BUT A BODY PROSCRIBED BY LAW.
WHERE BY PERIODICALLY THAT
ENTITY NAY EACH?
THE TALKS ABOUT THE ISSUES
RELATED. TO THE OPERATION AND
THE CONDUCT OF THE DAM.
WE GET SOMETHING BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES CALLED OF.
MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER.
WHICH WAS SET UP DE FORMALIZED
BY THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
CONSERVATION FORUM.
A GROUP OF LOCAL LEADERS AS WELL
AS STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCY
PEOPLE THAT REGULARLY MAKE.
A.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER SOME KIND OF
AN ENTITY LIKE THAT TO HELP HAVE
A GREATER COMFORT LEVEL IN TRUST
FOR THE COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THAT RIVER.
YES ABSOLUTELY LIKE CONSIDER
THAT AND WE WOULD WELCOME THAT
AS VEHICLE TO HELP US WITH
INFORMATION FLOW WE ABSOLUTELY
RECOGNIZE.
SOMETIMES FOR MOST THE TIMES
WHEN INFORMATION MIGHT BE COMING
DIRECTLY FROM US INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE BEST VEHICLE
BY WHICH TO DO THAT SO A GROUP
OR FORUM THAT COULD HELP US WITH
THAT AND ALSO TOO YOU KNOW BOTH
WAYS WOULD BE TWO WAY
COMMUNICATION TO REALLY HELP US.
STAY REALLY AWARE OF THE
CONCERNS OR HAPPENINGS WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY THAT WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT OR MAYBE YOU
PERCEPTIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
THAT TOGETHER WE CAN KIND OF
WORK THROUGH SO YES I THINK WE
WOULDWELCOME THAT. WELL AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS YEAR DOING
SOME THAT COMMUNITY FORUMS
SIX THAT SEVERAL.
THE IN THE AREA THAT WE
REPRESENT THAT'S BEEN VERY
HELPFUL TO THEM. MADAM CHAIR
THINKING.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF YEAH I
WOULD SAY THE AND YOU KNOW THAT
THE THE REPUTATION THE AGENCY
HAS UP IN THAT AREA IS IS NOT
POSITIVE. WHICH I'M SURE MAKES
IT MORE DIFFICULT THAN FOR YOU
TO GET INFORMATION OUT BUT YOU
REALLY NEED TO DEVELOP A SHOULD.
PLAN.
BUT SOME AMBASSADORS TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE COMMUNITY
INFORMATION BECAUSE WITH THE IN
THE ABSENCE OF INFORMATION
PEOPLE MAKE UP ALL KINDS OF.
THINGS WHAT'S GOING ON OUT THERE
FACE AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW TO
THINK YOU SENATOR IN. A AGAIN TO
BOTH THE PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT
MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT THAT AREA
WE.
WE ARE SORRY THAT YOU ALL TO GO
THROUGH THAT AND AND KNOW WHAT
AT.
A CRISIS IT WAS FOR ANY PUBLIC
SERVANT THIS AS OUR HEARTS ARE
OUT WITH THE. MEMBERS TO AND THE
PEOPLE DOWN IN THE SENATE BARBER
AREA RIGHT NOWTHEY'RE FACING
BURST FIRES AND THEN NOW
MUDSLIDES.
MISTER LIKE WE WANTED ALSO IN
LIGHT OF THE FORENSIC REPORT IS
DUE TO WE ARE STILL EXPECTING
FEMA.
TO PAY FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION RECOVERY
EFFORT.
SO.
OBVIOUSLY IT IS OUR HOPE THAT
YES WE WILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR BOTH THE.
EMERGENCY RECOVERY AND REPAIR
AND RECOVERY STAGES WE ARE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH FEMA THEY HAVE
ASKED OBVIOUSLY FOR THE REPORT
AND FOR TIME TO GO THROUGH IT.
ANDWE ARE SETTING UP AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS SO WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY GO THROUGH IT AND
ADDRESS ANY OF THEIR QUESTIONS
I'M NOT SURE WHO ELSE THEY'RE
REACHING OUT TO BUT.
WE WANT TO CLEARLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR QUESTIONS ARE WITH
THEIR CONCERNS MAY BE AND MOVE
FORWARD FROM THERE.
THREE MUCH OKAY.
THREATEN THINK YOU AND I WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL ON DAM
SAFETY.
AND I THINK.
PROBABLY.
CHIEF DIVERT YOUR STAND BECAUSE
I HAVE I HAVE GRANT DAVIS UP AND
THAT ERIK KOCH.
INTEGRATED WATER MANAGEMENT
SHARON TAPIA CHIEF DIVISION OF
SAFETY OF DAMS.
AND CHRISTINA CURRY DIPPY
DIRECTOR PLANNING PREPAREDNESS
AND PREVENTION
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY.
BUT I WOULD ASK IF.
THE PRISONERS COULD BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE BRIEF IN THEIR
PRESENTATIONS TO ALLOW SOME TIME
FOR QUESTIONS.
OKAY SO YOU'LL PROBABLY GRATEFUL
THAT NO I WILL NOT E SAYING
ANYTHING FOR THIS ONE.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR COKE IS GONNA
OPEN IT UP WITH SOME BRIEF
REMARKS AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
THE PRESENTATION
SO.
SO GOOD MORNING TEARS AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS OUR CO KIND THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF INTEGRATED
WATER MANAGEMENT HARM WATER
RESOURCES.
AT WHICH INCLUDES A DIVISION OF
SAFETY OF DAMS.
WE'RE HERE TO. BURKE WERE HAPPY
TO JOIN IN TODAY'S IT DISCUSS
THE LESSONS LEARNED IN THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THE DIVISION
SAVED HIM DAM HAS MADE. AND WILL
MAKE AS A RESULT THE LESSONS
LEARNED. FROM FOR BILL INCIDENT.
WITH ME TODAY IS SHARED HAPPIER.
WHO IS OUR DIVISION CHIEF FOR
THE DIVISION OF SAFETY OF DAMS?
AND TINA CURRY OF THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENTION OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
I'M I'M GOING TO SORT OF CHOP UP
MY PRESENTATION A LITTLE BIT
SOLVE DISCREDIT SKIP AROUND
LITTLE BIT.
AND.
I'M REALLY ONE TO SAY THIS
THOUGH THAT ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA.
DIDN'T HAVE A STRONG DAM SAFETY
REGULATORY PROGRAM.
FINDINGS IN THE EYE OF T. REPORT
AND OUR OWN OBSERVATIONS AS A
RESULT OF OR BILL INCIDENT.
DEMANDS A PARADIGM SHIFT MOVING
FORWARD IN DAM SAFETY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
DAM SAFETY PROGRAMS HAVE
PREVIOUSLY FOCUSED ON PREVENTING
A CATASTROPHIC FAILURE OF THE
DAM ITSELF. DID NOT FULLY
INCLUDE THE CONSEQUENCES
CONSEQUENCES OF THE FAILURE OF
APARTMENT STRUCTURES.
INCLUDING SPILLWAYS EMERGENCY
SPILLWAYS ALLEN BELTS AND OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE DAM.
AS A SYSTEM.
INSPECTIONS ARE AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF STRONG DAM SAFETY
PROGRAM.
HOWEVER INSPECTIONS ALONE ARE
NOT ENOUGH TO CONNECT THE DOTS.
TO FIND MAJOR ISSUES UNDERLYING
STRUCTURES.
THE AUTHORITY HAS STRENGTHENED.
ITS INSPECTION PRACTICES THROUGH
MORE REGULAR AND DETAILED
INSPECTIONS IN GREATER OVERSIGHT
OF THE REPAIRS BEING PERFORMED
AS A RESULT OF THOSE.
BUT THAT AGAIN IN ITSELF WILL
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
SYSTEMATIC ISSUES CAN ONLY BE
IDENTIFIED. THROUGH A ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE REEVALUATION.
REPORTS AND STUDIES.
THE AUTHORITY HAS EXPANDED ITS
VERY SUCCESSFUL EXISTING SEISMIC
REEVALUATION PROGRAM.
TO INCLUDE SPILLWAYS AND OTHER
PERTINENT STRUCTURES.
START DAM OWNERS OF NINETY THREE
DAMS
SPILLWAYS SIMILAR TO LIKE OR
RELATIVES HAVE BEEN ENGAGED AND
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM
AND ARE INDEPENDENTLY EVALUATING
THEIR STRUCTURES AND THEIR
PERMIT STRUCTURES.
WITH MORE THAN HALF OF THE
JURISDICTIONAL DAMS.
BEING OVER FIFTY YEARS OLD WITH
AN AVERAGE AGE.
AB SEVENTY YEARS.
MANY DAMS WILL NEED SOME LEVEL
OF REPAIR.
AND FOR SOME FOR REPLACEMENT.
THIS WILL EQUATE TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NEEDED TO REPAIR. AND
BRING THESE FACILITIES UP TO
CURRENT STANDARDS AND
OPERATIONAL EFFECTIVENESS.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE DIVERSITY OF
DAM OWNERSHIP. FROM A SINGLE
FARMER TWO MAJOR UTILITIES.
AND THERE VARYING FINANCIAL AND
TECHNICAL RESOURCES
MANY DAM OWNERS WILLBE
CHALLENGED IN FIXING THEIR
DOWNS.
AS IS CURRENTLY THE CASE TODAY.
THE RESULT IS THE FORCED
IMPLEMENTATION OF RISK REDUCTION
MEASURES SUCH AS RESERVOIR
RESTRICTIONS.
PARTIAL OR FULL DRAINING OF
RESERVOIRS.
WHICH IN TURN RESULTS IN THE
LOSS OF NEEDED WATER SUPPLY IN
CRITICAL FLOOD.
PROTECTIONS STORAGE.
WELL WE'RE SHIFTING THE PARADIGM
OF THE NCP ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY.
TO ACCOUNT FOR AND COUNTER THE
LESSONS LEARNED AND ORVILLE.
WE MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE
INTELLECTUALLY OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS IN
REPAIRING AND MAINTAINING OUR
DAMS.
WITH FUNDING PERMITTING RESEARCH
AND DAM ORDER AND SAFETY
EDUCATION.
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO SHARE AND WHO WILL GO
FOR THE FLIGHT DECK THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE.
IT.
IT IN YOUR PACKETS AND MOVE
ALONG THEN TO TINA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY. AND IN YOUR PACKET I HAVE
ABOUT TEN SLIDES NOW GO THROUGH
PRETTY RAPIDLY.
ERIC KINDA CAPTURE THE JUST OF
IT BED IT'S KINDA NICE TO SEE
SOME PHOTOS AND GRAPHICS TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT.
SO THE FIRST ONE IS OUR DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM THAT. BIG CHANGES
TO OUR PROGRAM HAVE OCCURRED
HISTORICALLY THROUGH BIG
SIGNIFICANT INCIDENCES AND AND
FAILURES.
AND WE STARTED OUR PROGRAM IN
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE AS A RESULT
OF THE SAINT FRANCIS STATE DAM
FAILURE THAT OCCURRED THE YEAR
PRIOR.
THAT DAM FAILURE WILL BE
HITTING ITS NINETIETH
ANNIVERSARY IN MARCH OF THIS
YEAR.
OVER FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE LOST
THEIR LIVES.
AND ANOTHER BIG CHANGE SAID THAT
CHANGE BROUGHT ON THE REGULATION
OF ON SCREEN DANCE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THERE IS
THE FAILURE OF THE OFF STREAM
BALDWIN HILLS DAM IN THE LA
AREA.
IN THAT CAUSED THE LOSS OF FIVE
FIVE PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES.
THIS AMENDED THE WATER COATING
NOW INCLUDE OFF STREAM
RESERVOIRS.
AND DOWN BELOW YOU'LL SEE LOWER
SAN FERNANDO WHICH AS MANY OF
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH. THIS
ONE WE HAVE THE LOWER SAN
FERNANDO EARTHQUAKE OCCURRED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
YOU'LL SEE THAT.
THERE'S EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
DOWNSTREAM OF THE STAND AND WHAT
HAPPENED. LUCKILY AT THE TIME.
R. DIVISION HAD HAD THIS DAMN
RESTRICTED ACTUALLY FOR A
DIFFERENT REASON IT WASN'T
SEISMIC REASON.
SO IT WAS RESTRICTED AND THE DAM
OWNER ACTUALLY HAD HELD THE
WATER EVEN LOWER.
AND WHEN THE EARTHQUAKE OCCURRED
HAD DUE TO HOW THIS DAM WAS
BUILT IT.
LIQUEFIED IN THE WHOLE ENTIRE
STE UPSTREAM SLOPES LATE INTO
THE RESERVOIR.
AND SO THE WATER LEVEL HAD BEEN
DOWN THIRTY FIVE FEET AT THAT
TIME IN YOU CAN SEE THIS IS THAT
THE RESULT THAT THE END OF THE
EARTH QUAKE. IT WAS WITHIN FEET
OF OVERTOPPING AND THAT'S WHAT
TRIGGERED THIS EVACUATION.
SO TO KEEP IN MIND WITH
EARTHQUAKES AND LIKE WHAT WE SAW
WITH ORVILLE ON THE FLIGHT EVENT
THERE IS NO TIME TO EVACUATE.
EARTHQUAKES HAPPEN
INSTANTANEOUSLY.
GOING ON TO THE NEXT SLIDE IS
JUST A PICTURE OF OUR OVERALL
INVENTORY WE HAVE TWELVE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE DANCE. YOU'LL SEE IN
THE LITTLE CHART THE VERY.
.
FROM ORVILLE BEING OUR HIGHEST
IS SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY AND
THEY GO DOWN TO.
VERY SMALL DAMS. HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE
AND.
I HAVE VERY VARIETY OF TYPES OF
DAMS TO.
AT OUR OWNERSHIP OR OWNERSHIP IS
ALSO VERY VARIED ACROSS THE
STATE YOU'LL SEE THE CHART ON
THE RIGHT. AND ALSO WHO HAS
EXTREMELY HIGH IN HIGH DAMS.
WE HAVE SOME OF THE LARGEST DAMS
IN THE NATION THE MOST COMPLEX
GEOLOGY AND VERY COMPLEX SEISMIC
REGIME. AND WITH THEIR OWNERS
THEY VERY BOTH TECHNICALLY AND
IN THEIR RESOURCES FOR FINANCIAL
SUPPORT.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE LITTLE BIT
ABOUT EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
SO I CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY PRIOR
TO THE OROVILLE EVENT HAD BEEN
ENCOURAGING DAM OWNERS TO HAVE
THE KEYS IT WASN'T REQUIRED.
THOUGH WE KNEW THE IMPORTANCE
OF IT AND PROBABLY AT THAT TIME
CALIFORNIA WAS LAGGING IN THE
NATION ON THIS.
SO WE ENCOURAGE THEM WE SET OUT
TO.
NATIONALLY A LEARN ABOUT IT
INUNDATION MAPPING TOOL THAT
WE'VE BEEN YOU UTILIZING AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY HELPING DAM
OWNERS.
DUTY EIGHT KEYS.
SO FROM THAT WE AFTER THEY WERE
RELEVANT NOW WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE INUNDATION
MAPS WE LEARNED A LOT FROM
MARVEL WE NEED SPECIALIZED MAPS
FOR CRITICAL PRINCES. SO THAT
YOU EVACUATION SCANNED BE
CONTAINED WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES.
AND NOT DISPLACED PEOPLE WHO
DON'T NEED TO BE DISPLACED.
AND.
.
THIRTEEN A NEXT MEAN SHE HAS NOW
THE AUTHORITY TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE.
HE PEES
DID PICTURE YOU SEE HERE IS
ACTUALLY PARRIS DAM IT'S ONE IDW
R. STAMP. AND YOU'LL SEE WE HAVE
WE HAVE JUST DEVELOPMENT
OCCURRING ALL ACROSS THE STATE
JUST AT AT DID THE DOWNSTREAM
TEARS OF THE STANDS TWENTY YEARS
AGO THIS DbN LIKE LIKE THIS APP
AT PARIS SO. WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA IN
REAL I HAVE A LOT OF LARGE DAMS
BETTER UPSTREAM OF THESE
COMMUNITIES EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THE NEXT SLIDE IS JUST A QUICK
SLIDE SHOWING OUR OVERVIEW. OF
WE ARE ABLE TO LAUNCH THIS
PROGRAM VERY RAPIDLY THIS YEAR
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAD BEEN
ENGAGED WITH OWNERS ON MAPS IN
THE EIGHTIES. WE ALREADY HAVE
THE TOOL ESTABLISHED AND WE HAVE
A VERY STRUCTURED PROCESSAND
HOW WE DO OUR DAM REVIEWS
EMERGES FOLLOWING A VERY SIMILAR
MECHANISM TO GET THE PROGRAM UP
AND RUNNING.
L. LITERALLY WE HAVE BEEN
INUNDATED WITH INUNDATION MAPS.
IN DECEMBER THEY BECOME AND
BOXES TO US AND.
AND I KNOW KALAYEH SAYS
RECEIVING THE SAME BOXES.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE SLIDE SIX IS
JUST A QUICK STATUS OF OUR
INUNDATION MAPPING PROGRAM.
I DAM OWNERS ARE VERY ENGAGED IN
THIS.
THAT THEY'RE ON THE PHONE TWO
S. QUITE QUITE A BIT. TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE REQUIREMENTS IN
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR THE MAPS IN
THE TIME LINES.
WE KNOW THAT SOME DAM OWNERS
LIKELY WILL NOT MEET THESE
DEADLINES.
AS SOME OF THEM DID NOT HAVE ANY
AP IN MATH IN PLACE OF WHEN THE
LEGISLATION WAS APPROVED.
AND THEY ARE WORKING TO TO MEET
THE DEADLINE SO SO OUR GOAL IS
TO REALLY WORK WITH DAM OWNERS
AND TO GET E. AP'S BECAUSE WE
MEDIATE HE'S COMING WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THERE APPROVED
IT SO THAT THEY'RE CORRECT IN
ACCURATE IN CAN BE IN PLACE OF
AN EMERGENCY WERE TO OCCUR TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
THE NEXT SLIDE IS SLIDE SEVEN.
THIS GOES BACK TO INSPECTIONS
AS WAS ALREADY DISCUSSED.
BY MR FRANCE.
INSPECTIONS IN OUR VIEW ARE ARE
VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT THEY'RE NOT THE AND ALL OF
YOU REALLY GOT IT DO YOU DEEP RE
EVALUATIONS TENDER STAND. BUT
ONE THING I WANT TO POINT OUT ON
INSPECTIONS IS IS THE VALUE THAT
THEY HAVE. IS THAT THEY MAKE
SURE THAT THE DAM OWNERS
OPERATING AND MAINTAINING THE
DAM PROPERLY.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THERE IS A
DAM FAILURE IN HAWAII WHERE
SEVEN PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES.
BECAUSE THE STATE I HAD NOT BEEN
OUT INSPECTING THE DAM IN NEW
DAM OWNER TOOK OVER AND THEY
ACTUALLY FILL THE SPILLWAY WITH
DIRT.
AND OF IN A STORM CAME THE DAM
OVERTOPPED BECAUSE THE SPILLWAY
WASN'T CLAIRE.
SO WIVES ARE STILL BEING LOST
AND. WITH INSPECTIONS NOT BEING
DONE SO INSPECTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT PART OF A GOOD DIEM
SAFETY PROGRAM.
WE ARE.
BEING A MORE AGGRESSIVE ON OUR
INSPECTIONS NOW WE'RE GONNA GIVE
DAM OWNERS LESS TIME TO GET
REPAIRS DONE.
WE'RE GONNA BE MONITORING THOSE
REPAIRS MORE CLOSELY. AND OF
FOLLOWING UP AND TRACKING THAT
EVERYTHING'S BEEN DONE PROPERLY.
SLIDE EIGHT IS.
.
A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF OUR
REEVALUATION PROGRAM RE
EVALUATIONS AREN'T NEW TO US. WE
HAVE BEEN DOING THEM FOR DECADES
THAT WE STARTED WITH THE LOWER
SAN FERNANDO. HAD THAT WAS
ACTUALLY STE A CHANGE IN
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THE WHOLE
MECHANISM OF UNDERSTANDING HOW
SOILS LIQUEFY WAS LEARNED
THROUGH THIS EVENT.
AND ONCE THAT HAPPENED THE
DIVISION DID.
OF REEVALUATION STUDY OF ALL
THE HYDRAULIC PHIL DANCE IN THE
STATE. AND ALMOST NEARLY ALL OF
THOSE ARE ARE FIXED NOW THERE'S
A FEW.
STILL OUT THERE THAT THE DAM
OWNERS HAVE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
AND ARE NOT ABLE TO FIX BUT
THOSE ARE RESTRICTED.
AND NEXT UP WE HAD FULL SUMGAIT
FAILURE AND AGAIN WE EVALUATED
TWO HUNDRED DAMS.
TWO HUNDRED GATES IN THE STATE.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING IS
IS CONTINUING ADVANCING AN
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING LIKE I
SAID.
EARTHQUAKES HAPPEN THERE'S NO
NOTICE WE HAVE SO ANY DAMS IN
THIS NOT JUST THE AGE OF THE
DAMS IT'S SIERRA THAT THEY WERE
CONSTRUCTED AND. SO WHEN YOU
HAVE DANCE EVER CONSTRUCTED IN
THE AIR THEY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
LIQUEFACTION YOU HAVE A LOT OF
SOILS UNDER THE DAMN SICK COULD
LIQUEFY. YOU HAVE SOILS WITHIN
THE DAM THE CA LIQUEFY SO IT'S
ON EARTH DAMS IT'S REALLY THAT
CONSTRUCTION AT THE TIME THAT.
AND THE METHODOLOGIES THAT WERE
USED VERSUS A CONCRETE
STRUCTURES ARE WE SEE THAT
THAT'S AN AGING PROBLEM BUT IT.
BEEN ADDITION TO UNDERSTANDING
STANDARDS AND CODE REQUIREMENTS
TO.
AS SORT OUR CON OR EARTHQUAKE
ENGINEERING REEVALUATION PROGRAM
LOOKS AT EARTH DAMS CONCRETE
DAMS AND WE ALSO DO A PRINT AND
STRUCTURES LIKE OUTLET TOWERS
AND GATES.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY WITH ORVILLE
WE STARTED THIS YEAR ANNEGRET
VERY AGGRESSIVE PROGRAM OF
LOOKING AT SPILLWAYS. AYE WE'RE
STARTING WITH THESE NINETY THREE
THIS IS A START.
THIS IS NOT THE END ALL IN OUR
INVENTORY WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE.
AT EACH YEAR TO GRAB ANOTHER
BALK AT OF OF DAMS THAT WE
CONSIDER THE HIGHEST PRIORITY.
AND GET THOSE OWNERS ENGAGED.
I DO WANT TO SAY AND I THINK
WE'LL GET TO IT ON THE NEXT
SLIDE.
AND THE OWNERS ARE VERY ENGAGED
IN THIS THIS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT HIM ARE YOU
AWAKE.
EVERY DAMN OWNER OUT THERE IS
AWAKE I WILL TELL YOU THAT. I WE
HAVE DIEM OWNERS ALREADY.
HAD ORVILLE NOT OCCURRED THE
WAY IT DID.
WE HAVE DIMINISH NOW. TELLING
US ARE GONNA BE REPLACING THEIR
SPILLWAYS.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE SEVERITY OF
THIS AND WHAT IT CAN LEAD TO SO
I'M THERE THAT THE HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS IS OF THIS IS OUT
THERE.
AND.
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THESE DO
TAKE TIME. DOING THESE
EVALUATIONS.
REQUIRES US TO HAVE THEM GO OUT
AND DO DRILLING TO GET THE DATA.
AND AND TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S UNDER THERE AND HOW
SERIOUS IS IT IS IT SERIOUS
ENOUGH TO DO A FULL REPLACEMENT
IS A PARTIAL REPLACEMENT
SUFFICIENT.
AND SO THESE PROJECTS DO TAKE.
TIME TO EVALUATE AND THEN ONCE
IT'S DETERMINED TO GOES INTO
PLANNING THESE CAN TAKE A COUPLE
YEARS OF PLANNING. THEN THE PER
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY THE PERMITTING
PROCESS THAT THEY HAVE TO GO TO
AND THEN THE CONSTRUCTION SO YOU
SEE FULL REPLACEMENT YOU MEAN
THIS BILL LAWYER THE DAMN ARE
YOU REFERRING TO SPILLWAYS YEAH
SO THERE'S A AND. THEN THE
SENATE CLAIRE AREA THERE ARE
GONNA BE DOING A COMPLETE AND
ALMOST DAM REPLACEMENT.
AND NOW THEY'RE GONNA DO THE
SPILLWAY ALONG WITH IT SO.
AND THAT'S
SURE THAT YOU SEE RIGHT HERE.
BUT AGAIN IT'S IT WERE JUST
FOLLOWING A AGAIN A IS A VERY
STRUCTURED PROCESS THAT WE DO
FOR SEISMIC AND THE SPILLWAYS
HEARING THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING OUTLETS.
OUTLETS ARE ANOTHER CONCERN
THAT WE NEED TO BE ADDRESSING ON
DANCE THAT DAY AGE THEY CORRODE
WE GOTTA MAKE SURE OUR OUTLETS
ARE GOOD AND WE GOT TO BE
LOOKING AT DRAINAGE SYSTEMS AND
DANCE BECAUSE THERE. THAT'S WHAT
PROTECTS YOUR DAMNED IF YOU DO
GET SOMETHING A WEEK GOING
THROUGH AND EVERYTHING BANG
THANK YOU NEED GOOD FILTERS.
SO IT ARE.
HAVE YOU TALKED MY ONLY THING IS
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HEARD
BEFORE WAS THAT PEOPLE JUST
LOOKING AT THE DAM THE STRUCTURE
FAILURE VERSUS ALL THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS THAT MAKE UP THE DAM
SYSTEM.
IF YOU WILL SO WHEN YOU'RE DOING
THESE NEW EVALUATIONS ARE YOU
LOOKING AT IT HOLISTICALLY AS A
DAM SYSTEM AND NOT JUST
INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA BE DOING
BOTH.
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE
ON SPILLWAYS YOU REALLY GAIN
THAT EXPERTISE WHEN YOU'RE
FOCUSED AND AND AND YOU DIE DEEP
IN YOU LEARN EVERYTHING ABOUT
IT.
BUT WHAT THAT TYPICALLY OPENS UP
IS YOU'RE LOOKING AT MORE THAN
JUST THAT.
A LOT OF TIMES WITH THEIR DANCE
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SIZE MAKE IT
AUTOMATICALLY MARKS IT YOU KNOW
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU DO YOUR HOUSE
REMODEL IT IT IN MARCH BECAUSE
YOUNG COVER THIS NEW AND COVER
THAT. WELL OVER THERE YEAH.
AND THAT THAT'S HOW IT HAPPENS
BUT.
.
KNOWING THE.
YOU KNOW. KNOWING WHAT HAPPENED
OR AVAIL AND HOW SIGNIFICANT
THAT WAS AND IT WILL BE FOCUSED
ON SPILLWAYS BUT IT'S ALSO GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT.
COMPREHENSIVELY MORE THAN THAT.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE SOMETHING
SPECIFIC TO THIS PRESENTER.
OKAY I JUST HAVE A COUPLE MORE
SITES AND.
MEANING YOU GUYS HAVE ALREADY
STRESSED YOU GUYS KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THE AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND LACK OF INVESTMENT AND I
DON'T NEED TO GO THROUGH THAT.
AND BASICALLY THE COMMON THEMES
WE SEE IS A DAMNING REGULATOR.
THESE ARE TOP THREE IT'S IT'S
THAT FUNDING MECHANISMS.
DANNEMEYER OWNER SOME OF THEM
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS FOR
DIFFERENT FUNDING MECHANISMS.
THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
EVEN THOUGH SOMEONE MAY HAVE A
YOU KNOW P. ELI SINCE.
THEY MAY NOT BE A SPECIALIST IN
DAM SAFETY AND THERE THERE ISN'T
A HUGE INDUSTRY OF DAM SAFETY
EXPERTS.
SO WE DO HAVE TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CONSULTANTS
THAT ARE DAM OWNERS CHOOSE.
AND AND AND BRING THEM ALONG AND
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET ADEQUATE
PLANS AND SPECS.
AND THEN LASTLY S THE
PERMITTING.
PERMITTING DOES. DOES TAKE TIME
AND DAM IS SO WHERE THAT IMPEDE
STAMMER NURSES THEY CAN'T GO OUT
AND QUICKLY DO A REPAIR IF IF
THEY SEE SOMETHING AND IF THEY
HAVE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THAT
YEAR IT REALLY HAS TO BE PLANNED
OUT IN ADVANCE.
AND THEN AGAIN ON THAT SIDE YOU
SEE ALL THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OWNERS SO AGAIN THEY EACH HAVE
THEIR OWN ABILITY AND KNOWING
HOW TO DO EACH OF THESE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS.
AND THEN LASTLY ADVANCING DAM
SAFETY THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM IS
BEEN VERY PROACTIVE AND NAY
NATIONALLY IN PROMOTING DAM
SAFETY. FROM THE NATIONAL THEM
SAFETY REVIEW BOARD WERE VERY
INVOLVED IN ASSOCIATION STATE
DAM OFFICIALS. AS WELL AS THEM
WITH HOMELAND SECURITY.
.
YOU KNOW THERE DEBT DEFINITELY
ARE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING IN OUR PROGRAM
GOING FORWARD LIKE I MENTIONED
ABOUT THE INSPECTIONS. AND
REALLY HAVING ALL OF OUR
ENGINEERS HAVE THAT AWARENESS
WHEN THEY GO OUT AND LET THEM DO
THEIR INSPECTIONS AND. AND WE
ALWAYS DO THAT DEEP DIVE. WHEN
WE DO OUR RE EVALUATIONS AND
IT'S AMAZING R. GETS UNCOVERED
WHEN YOU DO THAT.
.
THAT'S A.
BUT NOW IT'S AFTERNOON SO GOOD
AFTERNOON.
CHAIRS MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'LL BE BRIEF.
THAT NINETEEN AQUARIUM A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE.
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM D. W.
ARE AND TO PRESENT TO YOU WHAT
OUR ROLE IS IN IN DAM SAFETY.
BASED ON WHAT WE LEARNED FROM
OROVILLE AND JUST A VERY.
SMALL SMALL BIT ABOUT CALLAWAY
YES ON OCCASION NOT TOO FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT WE ARE THAT YOU
PROBABLY ARE TO HAVE A LOT OF
EMERGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THIS YEAR BUT WE ARE A STATE
AGENCY THAT'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
ASSISTING WITH ALL ASPECTS OF
EMERGENCIES FOR ALL HAZARDS IN
CALIFORNIA WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHEN WE NEED TO BRING THEM INTO
HEALTH WORKING ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT TO BRING IN EXPERTISE
AND OF COURSE ALL OF IT IN
SUPPORT OF COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE BEEN
ACTIVATED.
I THINK ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
YEAR.
IN RESPONSE TO EMERGENCIES WERE
ACTIVATED RIGHT NOW IN RESPONSE
TO THE ON GOING ON FIRE THAT IS
AND LEAD TO THE THE MUTTS LIGHTS
ON BUT ON BALANCE WITH THAT I'M
PART OF DALLAS IS ROLE IS TO
ALSO. FACILITATE EMERGE
READINESS FOR EMERGENCIES
EMERGENCY PLANNING.
PREVENTION.
OR LEAST MITIGATION AGAINST
EMERGENCIES.
AND THAT'S WHERE WHEN WE LOOKED
AT WHAT NEEDED TO CHANGE ENDING
ADVANCES.
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT.
IMPORTANT AND THE WORK THEY DID
IF YOU ARE STILL MANY. THINGS
HAPPENED AND WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR EMERGENCIES BECAUSE
THAT'S JUST A REALITY IN OUR
STATE.
I'VE HANDED OUT A VERY.
SIMPLE.
.
INFOGRAPHIC ABOUT EMERGENCY
ACTION PLANS AND.
TO HELP IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT
THESE ARE SIMPLE DOCUMENTS BUT
JUST KINDA GIVING IDEA WHAT THE
COMPONENTS ARE. OF THESE SO YOU
CAN GET A FLAVOR OF WHAT IT IS
WE'RE GOING TO BE RECEIVING WE
HAVE BEEN GETTING LOTS OF A
BOXES INDUSTRY IS TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY AND THAT RESPONDING.
AND.
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT IT.
IN LEVERAGING OUR EXPERTISE AND.
LOOKING FOR THESE COMPONENTS
AND THAT THING ABOUT PLANS IS
THEY ARE IMPORTANT TO HAVE THEY
HAVE VERY SPECIFIC ELEMENTS TO
THEM AND WE WANT TO SEE THAT
STANDARDIZED.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE'S LOTS OF DAMS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN BE FOUND BY
THIS BY THIS RULE AND.
YOU KNOW WE WE ARE BUT AS
IMPORTANT AS THE PLAN ITSELF IS
THE PROCESS THAT. THAT IT IT.
E. UM THE RESPONSIBLE ENTITY
GOES THROUGH TO DO THAT AND THEY
HAVE TO INVOLVE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT.
WILL BE AFFECTED BY THAT PLAN
MIGHT BE AFFECTED BY THAT
EMERGENCY AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
GOING TO HELP FACILITATE DAM
OWNERS DO. BUT ACTUALLY BE
CHECKING FOR WHEN WE REVIEW THEM
AND THEN TATIAN THAT THAT WILL
BE DONE.
WITH WITH A CERTAIN FREQUENCY
SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WORKS WITH THEM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT NOW ON TO DO
EXERCISE A FOR EMERGENCIES.
WE HAVE A WARNING CENTER THAT
IS.
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO DOING.
YOU KNOW PASSING ON EMERGENCY
INFORMATION FOR WHETHER FOR
FIRES EARTHQUAKES SO ALL OF THAT
EXISTS WITHIN CALLAWAY US SO WE
WILL BE APPLYING THAT TOWARDS
OUR OUR VIEW ON THESE AND DAM.
EMERGENCY ACTION PLANS.
SO WE OUT MEAN I'D I WON'T GO
THROUGH ALLTHE DETAILS ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW LONG WE HAVE TO
REQUIRE WHAT WILL GO THROUGH IT
IS NEW WE'RE JUST GETTING OUR
FIRST BATCH OF THEM SO WE'RE
GONNA LEARN A LOT IN THE
PROCESS.
THAT WE HAVE SET UP SOME TOOLS
TO EVALUATE THESE IN A
CONSISTENT WAY TO BRING IN
EXPERTISE ACROSS OUR AGENCY WE
HAVE A FIRE AND RESCUE DIVISION
WE HAVE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION WE HAVE. A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DIVISION THEY BY
EXTENSION HAVE REACH OUT INTO.
VARIOUS FIELDS AND CAN HELP US
AND FORM.
THESE PLANTS AND WE WANT THEM
TO BE GOOD YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T
IT AT GOTCHA WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE I'M TRYING TO TO TO CATCH
THINGS WE WANT TO ACTUALLY WORK
WITH DAM OWNERS WORK A
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE PLANS ARE UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE EFFECTIVE WITH. THEIR
TESTED AND THE END OF THE DAY
THE PUBLIC HOUSE HAS COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THE
DAM OWNERS AND WE ARE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY AND WE HAVE BEEN
BEFORE EVEN MORE SO NOW WE MEET.
WEEKLY MAYBE
ARE FREQUENTLY THAN THAT WITH
THE DIVISION OF SAFETY OF DAMS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SHARING
INFORMATION AND. WE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING WHAT THEY'RE
SEEING ON THE MAPS WE THEY KNOW
WHAT WE'RE RECEIVING OVERSEEING
ON THE PLANS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER BECAUSE THE
COMMUNICATIONTO THAT
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE COMMUNITIES
AS THESE. AS A SPAWNING GOES
UNDER WAY ISN'T THESE PROGRAM
ENHANCES.
COME ABOUT BUT AND AND YOU KNOW
AND COMMUNICATION FROM OUR
DIFFERENT AGENCIES ON THIS TOPIC
THAT THAT'S ALL AS SEAMLESS AS
POSSIBLE AND ELIMINATING.
ANY CONFUSION R. OR I'M CROSS
WIRES IS VERY RIGID TIME FRAMES
WITH THESE INFORMATION IS GOING
TO BE MOVING FAST BUT WE STILL
NEED TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT AND. AND SHOW THAT
WORKING TOGETHER SO SO REALLY I
THINK THAT THAT THE VALUE THAT
WE ADD IS.
AS WE DIG INTO THESE PLANS WE
START TALKING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES ABOUT THEIR INVOLVEMENT
IN THESE EDUCATING THEM ABOUT
THESE PLANS.
WORKING WITH DAM OWNERS ON THE
EXERCISES AGAIN ARE REALLY
GONNA.
YOU HOPE TO SEE THAT THAT.
THAT THE ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE
RECOGNIZE ARE NEEDED REALLY
STARTED TO PLAY OUT IN THE
MONTHS AND AND.
YEARS AHEAD IN THEIR ALL HAZARDS
PLAN
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS TO EVACUATE.
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE FLOODS WE'VE
HAD THE FIRES WE'VE.
WE'VE HAD.
THE MUD SLIDES AND SO HERE'S
ANOTHER YOU KNOW KIND OF I HAVE.
RISK IN WHICH THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY SO THERE'S THERE'S A
NEED TO BE CONSISTENT AS A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC YOU CAN ON
HOW IT'S GOING TO WORK. AND.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
HAUSER'S THAT THEY'RE EXPOSED TO
AND.
I THINK ARE AND BE ABLE TO SORT
OF FOLD THIS INTO THE FRAMEWORK
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IS GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT AND A ROLE THAT
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY AND THAT
WE.
ARE EXPECTED TO DO QUITE
FRANKLY AND JUST AGAIN.
THE MERCY ACTION PLAN
THEMSELVES ARE GOING TO INCLUDE
SOME OF THE THINGS I THINK WERE
TALKED ABOUT IN THE PANEL LIKE
OUR YOU KNOW HOW IS SOMEBODY
GOING TO KNOW SOMETHING'S WRONG.
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO TELL?
THERE'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
TIERS OF EMERGENCIES POTENTIALLY
BECAUSE THERE'S THE MAIN DOWN
AND NOW WE KNOW YOU KNOW THIS
BILL WAY MAY BE.
WHILE STILL SERIOUS MIGHT KIND
OF HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY THAT
THAT EMERGENCY COULD PLAY OUT
SO.
ROLESAND RESPONSIBILITIES WHO
DOES WIDE.
UP AT DEFINING THE RESPONSE
PROCESS STEP ONE THREE STEP TEN
YOU KNOW WHATEVER IT IS THAT'S
CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN AROUND THE EMERGENCY
EVENTS WHETHER WHETHER DAM
OWNERS GOING THE FLIGHT IMPACT.
THAN THAT OF
COURSE DRIVES THE EMERGENCY PLAN
SO THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THE BASIC
COMPONENTS.
YOU KNOW THESE ARE YOU KNOW WE
EXPECT TO GET REALLY LARGE
DOCUMENTS BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF DETAIL OUT OF FACILITIES YOU
KNOW WITHIN EACH DAM.
THE YOU KNOW WE WE THINK WE
HAVE A GOOD.
START TO BE ABLE TO EVALUATE
THESE AS HIS COMMANDED AND LEARN
FROM THE PROCESSES WE GO SO OUT
STOP THERE I KNOW THERE'S
QUESTIONS AND.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER AND I THINK
ANY OF US. SLIGHTLY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE GOOD FOR US AT THIS
POINT THINK AGAIN THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR WE SHOULD HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY
BONUS TO HER THOUSAND PEOPLE
EVACUATED. WITH NO LOSS OF LIFE.
WAS TALKING WITH THE DIRECTOR OF
CAL THAT ABOUT HIS SECRETIVE
CALVET ABOUT WHEN HAD EVACUATED
THE NAPA HOSPITAL ME ANYTIME YOU
SEEN THAT ONE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
YOU EVACUATE SENIOR FRAGILE I
HAD PEOPLE FROM NURSING HOMES IT
IS INCREDIBLY A DANGEROUS AND
AND AND YOU KNOW YOU TAKE A
NINETY FIVE ROLLED OUT WITH WITH
WITH PNEUMONIA NEITHER THINKS.
THAT'S HOW A LOT OF LOS WHAT
HAPPENED SO THAT IT DIDN'T OCCUR
IN THE SITUATION I THINK IS
QUITE REMARKABLE.
ON.
QUESTION FROM A GREAT.
YEAH THINK ABOUT YOUR AND ALSO
DID WANNA JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON ON ON ALL THESE
ISSUES WERE.
ACTUALLY CO AUTHORING
LEGISLATION WITH SENATOR NIELSEN
S. ELDERLY PEOPLE BEING
EVACUATED TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT.
YOU KNOW WAS ADDRESSED
ADEQUATELY WAS DEATHLY SOME WE
FOUND THAT WE KNOW WE CAN DO
BETTER ON.
ASSUME THAT'S A VERY GOOD POINT.
.
COUPLE THINGS I JUST WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP ON I I THINK I HEARD
THAT WE ARE GOING TO NOW HAVE AN
EXECUTIVE IT DO YOU HAVE YOU
ARE.
THAT IS FOCUSED ON DAM SAFETY.
.
SPECIFICALLY IS THAT CORRECT.
AND WHO IS THAT I GUESS NOW.
OPEN SO FOR ORACLE THERE WILL BE
A SPECIFIC EXECUTIVE LEVEL POINT
PERSON WHICH IS TED CRADDICK
WHO.
MIGHT.
WHO HE SITTING BACK HERE IN THE
AUDIENCESO?
FOR DAM SAFETY.
DEPARTMENT WIDE.
YES FOR THE REGULATORY SIDE OF
THINGS SCARE COKE.
AND. SHARON.
OKAY DEBT AND AS AS HAD OF DS SO
DE AND THEN AS THAT OF THE
INTEGRATED WATER MANAGEMENT
OKAY.
.
YOU MENTIONED THE FOURSOME GAVE
FAILURE. A MISSTEP VIA AND I
KNOW AND THAT HIGHLIGHTED THE A
THIS PROBLEMS WITH ANCHOR TENANT
RODS THAT ARE AGED.
.
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF WAR BILLS.
ACRE TEN IN RAZA KNOW THAT WAS
THERE SIMILAR AGE AS FULSOME.
AND HAVE WE REPLACE THOSE YET
WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THOSE.
AND.
SO WITH WITH FULL SUMGAIT THE
ACTUAL.
FAILURE MECHANISM WAS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT KNOWN AT
THE TIME INDUSTRY AND THAT WAS.
THE TRUNNION FRICTION.
SO IT'S ACTUALLY WHERE THE GATE
ROTATES AND THAT FRICTION
BECAUSE OF THAT THE TRUNNION
PENS WEREN'T PROPERLY
MAINTAINED.
THE FRICTION GOT TOO HIGH IN
THAT'S WHAT CAUSED THE GATE TO
BUYING DE. UM AND THEN WHEN IT
FINDS THAT THEN IT EFFECTS THE
TENDONS BUT TENANTS ARE IN AN
INDUSTRY ISSUE. BECAUSE THERE
EMBEDDED INTO CONCRETE.
AND.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY
DIFFICULT TO RETROFIT.
AND SO I KNOW THE ONES THAT
OROVILLE ARE BEING EVALUATED.
NOT TOO LONG AGO I. THINK
JUST A MONTH OR TWO AGO THAT
AND.
D. W. R. HAD A WORKSHOP ON IT
AND I HAD SOME OF OUR STRUCTURAL
EXPERTS IN OUR DIVISION ATTENDED
SO WE'RE FOLLOWING ALONG WITH D.
W. ARE. WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH
IT?
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
DEFINITE PLAN YET THEY'RE STILL
UNDER INVESTIGATION. BUT OF
REPLACING TENDONS.
I THINK YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE.
MAYBE PROBABLY WHATEVER COMES
OUT OF D. W. ARE. COULD LEAD THE
NATION AND AND IN THE TECHNOLOGY
OF HOW TO FIX THESE YEAH I WOULD
STEPS AS IT DOES ON THE NEEDS
ATTENTION AND FOLLOW UP FROM D.
SOD I KNOW THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW WITH THE
ANCHOR ATTENDANCE AT OR. YEAH.
WHO IS LOOK WHO WAS THE HEAD OF
THE ON AND DIVISION?
VIA DURING THIS INCIDENT CRISIS.
IDW OR.
SO THE FORMER DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR STATE WATER PROJECT THAT
AN AND MS HOUSED UNDER WAS
MARC ANDERSON AT THE TIME WHO'S
AHEAD OF THEIR OWN AND DIVISION.
.
SORRY ESTATE TO POP I KNOW THESE
NAMES I I PROMISE SO. BUT DAVE
DAVE DIVALL IS THE HEAD OF THE
ON M. SECTION AND THERE IS A
DIEM SAFETY GROUP THAT IS PART
OF THAT THAT. I PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE ARTICULATED IS SEPARATE
FROM.
THE DIVISION OF SAY RIGHT IN
THERE'S IT STANDS SAFETY
ENGINEER.
ARE IS IT YOU KNOW I THINK DOES
THE TERM.
THAT IS THAT DAVE IS WELL
THAT'S DAVE PANIC ROOM. DAVE
CONNECTED YES WE A LOT OF DAYS
OKAY S. DAVE AND THEN THE HEAD
OF THE. OH NAM IS DAVE DO LAWS
CURRENTLY STILL CURRENTLY YES
OKAY. AS AND.
WHO HAD COURTS TO CHILL AND
THEN THE OVERALL HEAD OF THAT
DEVELOP THAT?
THAT.
BIGGEST OF STATE WATER PROJECT
WAS MARK ANDERSON IS NOW RETIRED
IS THAT YES OKAY YES ANGELES
TAKEN HIS PLACE CORRECT IS ONE
TO CLARIFY THAT YEAH.
AS SOON AS THE DAM SAFETY
ENGINEER GONNA PLAY A LARGER
ROLE IN THE NEW KIND OF LIKE DAM
SAFETY.
COMPONENT HERE IS THAT OR IS IT
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME WAY.
WELL I THINK THAT'S IN.
THOUGH OKAY WELL AND.
CLAIRE FUSIONS BUT I'M HARKENING
BACK TO THE.
INDEPENDENT FORENSIC TEAM
REPORT IN THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE CHIEF.
DAM SAFETY ENGINEER IN THERE SO.
WE WILL.
.
FIND WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IF THE LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE
COMMENTS OF THE REPORTS I WANNA
RUN THAT TO TO GROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER ISSUES THAT
WE MAY HAVE THEIR THAT WE
RESOLVE THAT THERE IS.
HE NO NO HINDRANCE TO
COMMUNICATIONS GOING UP.
FROM THE DAM SAFETY ENGINEER TO.
MYSELF THE DIRECTOR JOEL.
SO THAT WILL BE IN AREA WE WILL
FOCUS ON MOVING FORWARD.
AND THEN JUST LAST QUESTION IS A
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE FINDINGS.
SPECIFIC TO THE STATE WATER
PROJECT IN THE IN THE.
FRIENDS REPORT WAS.
AND OF THIS QUOTE FROM AT THE
IFD FOUND THE DWI WAS LIKELY
SUBJECT TO SIGNIFICANT
PRESSURES.
BY THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
TO CONTROL COSTS.
IN THESE PRESSURES WERE EXERTED
IN VARIOUS WAYS
SUCH AS OPENLY DURING
DISCUSSIONS. IN MEETINGS.
.
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF HOW WE
MAKE SURE WE MANAGE THE STATE
WATER PROJECT ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY IS NUMBER ONE.
HOW DO WE TAKE YOU KNOW THESE?
YOU KNOW INFLUENCES FROM THE
CONTRACTORS AND COST PRESSURES
HOW DO WE TAKE THAT OUT OF THE
EQUATION.
BECAUSE I THINK PROBABLY MOST
PEOPLE HERE SAYING LOOK
FROM HERE ON OUT WHATEVER NEEDS
TO BE DONE FROM SAFETY HOWEVER
THAT'S A TERM AND WHETHER IT'S
BY THE. DAM SAFETY ENGINEER.
NEO BY THE NEW.
THAT.
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE GONNA SET UP.
DEAD THAT JUST GETS DONE AND
IT'S NOT THERE'S NO DEBATE WITH
THE BENEFICIARIES OVER WHAT WHAT
THE COST SHOULD BE.
IT IT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND THAT
IS AGAIN AND THEN THEREFORE BE
PAID FOR BY. THE BENEFICIARY
MEAN IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE DISCUSSED.
AND IS.
I MEAN IS TO YOU IS THAT EVEN AN
ISSUE.
.
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT. HOPEFULLY
IT IS BEING ADDRESSED.
BUT
YOU KNOW D. W. R. WE MAKE OUR
DECISIONS IN TERMS OF
PRIORITIZING. MAINTENANCE ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE IN
CONTINUAL COMMUNICATION WITH THE
CONTRACTORS JUST
IN TERMS OF LETTING.
AT FOR PLANNING PURPOSES
BILLING PURPOSES.
SO WE HAVE DIALOGUE AND TERMS OF
HERE'S WHAT'S ON TAP FOR THE
UPCOMING YEAR WE'VE GOT SOME
PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF
MAINTENANCE.
I THINK BUT WE MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND WE IMPLEMENT THEM.
I THINK PART OF WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT TO IMPROVE THAT IS
THIS IN PART THE COMPREHENSIVE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT THE ASSET
MANAGEMENT.
EFFORT THAT JEWEL DESCRIBED
EARLIER WHERE WE WILL.
TAKE OF MORE ROBUST LOOK AT.
AND OF COURSE REALLY DO THIS
DEEPER DIVE RIGHT WITH THROUGH
THE RE EVALUATIONS AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A LIST OF ASSETS
THAT WE THAT NEED MAINTENANCE
MAYBE THEY NEED REPLACEMENT
REPAIRS.
PRIORITIZE THOSE BASED ON RISK
BASED ON NEED AND THAT SO WERE
FOR OUR PART GOING TO HAVE A
MORE ROBUST PLANNING. AND
PRIORITIZING PROCESS WE WILL
STILL COMMUNICATE THAT
OBVIOUSLY.
WITH THE CONTRACTORS BUT.
THIS IS.
OUR PROCESS IT IS OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE NEED TO.
MAKE THOSE REPAIRS AND DO AND.
MAKE THOSE IN A TIMELY MANNER
OBVIOUSLY.
RIGHT ISSUE AND IS A REAL QUICK
FOLLOW UP ON THAT IS YOU KNOW
WOULD YOU CAN SEE YOU SO THERE'S
A LOT OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
YOU GUYS IN THE WATER
CONTRACTORS.
YOU IN THE CASE OF THE P. YOU
SEE WE'VE WE'VE SAID HEY YOU
KNOW PC IMPEDE YOU NEED IF YOU
GUYS GONNA BE COMMUNICATING
REGARDING THINGS NO EX PARTE
COMMUNICATIONS AND THE PUBLIC.
I MEAN SHOULD WE HAVE A SIMILAR
PROCESS IN PLACE. IF YOU'RE
COMMUNICATE ALL THE TIME
ESPECIALLY AS REGARDS TO WHAT'S
GOING TO BE DONE IN TERMS OF
OWN.
THAT THOSE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BE MADE PUBLIC IN THE THERE ARE
NO EX PARTE COMMUNICATION.
WELL.
CURRENT SOMETHING TO CONSIDER
BUT I THINK THAT.
THE DIALOGUE WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
IN THE STRUCTURING HAVE IT UNDER
WORKS I MEAN I THINK A PART OF
WE NEED TO WE HAVE REGULARLY.
SCHEDULED MEETINGS IN WHICH WE.
TALK WITH THE CONTRACTORS IN
PART IS THEY NEED TO PLAN FOR
UPCOMING EXPENSES AND BILLS AND
CHANGES IN THE BILL SO.
THAT NECESSITATES THE NEED TO
REALLY.
BRING THEM ALONG IN THESE
PLANNING. EFFORTS AND AS WE KNOW
BIGGER EXPENSES ARE COMING DOWN
THE LINE WE NEED IT WE'RE TRYING
TO PROVIDE THEM TIME TO.
.
I JUST THEIR BUDGETS AND AND
WHAT NOT TO A ADDRESS A BILLS
WHEN THEY COME AND.
SO.
IN IT WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT I
NEED AROUND THE STATE AND WE'RE
STARTING TO GET A LOT MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT AND I THINK
THAT I MEAN THAT WAS AN ISSUE
THAT I REACHED ON. ON NOW THE
OROVILLE TOUR AS WELL.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
BENEFICIARIES ARE PAYING FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE UPDATE
AND EVERYTHING AS WE'RE GOING
FORWARD?
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE STILL.
MOVE NEED TO PUT HAVE A LOT OF
ATTENTION ON NOW I UNDERSTAND
IT'S GONNA BE A NEW ABILITY TO
FINE OWNERS A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY YOU'RE HOPING IF THAT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE IN A MECHANISM TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY.
AGAIN THE IT IN PARTICULAR THE
DAMS THAT THEY HAVE IN ORDER SO
THEY CAN MEET SAFE USED.
YEAH AND YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'LL WORK MOST EFFECTIVELY
WITH THE OWNERS WHO ARE NON
COMPLIANT.
.
THE ONES THAT AREN'T ABLE TO DO
IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE. THE
RESOURCES.
IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE
IS THAT REALLY GOING TO BE.
TOUGH BYNUM AND THAT'S WHERE
THE RESERVOIR RESTRICTIONS COME
AND IT'S MORE THE PHYSICAL STUFF
THAT WE CAN DO AND RISK
MITIGATION MEASURES THEN FINDING
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO GO FIX THE DAMS TIME.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING HOW LONG ARE YOU DOING THE
THE LEVEL RESTRICTIONS.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GIVE SOMEBODY
RESTRICTION HOW LONG IT IS A LOT
DOESN'T LAST IN OUR CLASSROOMS
HILLARY'S FIXED. IT YEAH AND
SOMETIMES.
.
AND SOMETIMES AS WE GET NEW
INFORMATION AND WE MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS SO IF SOMETHING'S
FIRST FOUND TO BE SEISMICALLY
DEFICIENT IT STARTS WITH THE
RESTRICTION AND AS WE GO THROUGH
IT. AND IF WE FIND OUT AS MORE
DATA COMES AND IT'S
IT'S WORSE. THAN WE THOUGHT THEN
THEY'RE STRETCHING GOES DOWN
LOWER.
YOU KNOW THE. NATIONAL WATER
DOES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
JENNER DOES.
WELL WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE.
LIKE SUPPOSE HAMMER WOULD BE
OVER THESE. PRIVATE.
THEY HELD DAMS OR.
SOME KIND OF A DISTRICT.
HELP THEM.
BUT WHO IS SHE HAD FOR SURE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
BUDGET I KNOW FOR CAST SOME OF
THE ALREADY.
BUT THAT'S AN IRREGULAR
AUTHORITY.
WHAT WHAT SEVENTY? WHAT WHAT
SECURE YOU KNOW THE?
THAT WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES DOES
WHAT IT SAID THE DO AND NEEDS TO
DO.
DOES THE REGULATOR.
IDEAS IDEAS THE REGULATOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
DO ABSOLUTELY WHO IS. THE
AUTHORITY TO BE A SAFE ADAPT SO
IT'S THAT SITUATION WHERE BUT I
CAN THEY FIND THE DEPARTMENT OR
SANCTION THE DEPARTMENT ANYWAY
WHATEVER THEY WANT AS A
REGULATOR.
AFTER GOING THROUGH THAT TERMS
OF DEVELOPING REGULATIONS BUT.
WE TREAT.
THE DEPARTMENT JUST LIKE WE
TREAT THE FARMER AND AND SO THE
SAME RULES WILL APPLY.
SO YOU CAN A FORCES SECTION YOU
CAN GO TO COURT TO.
AND WILL.
YEAH WE'RE WORKING WHAT THAT'LL
BE IN OUR A REGULATIONS BUT JUST
FOR A QUICK EXAMPLE PARRIS DAM
THE WHEN THE SUN HERE WHEN THAT
THE SEISMIC DEFICIENCY WAS
FOUND.
WE ORDERED A TWENTY FOOT
RESTRICTION ON THE ROWS OF WAR.
OKAY AND JUST LET ME SAY IF WE
EVER GET TO A SITUATION WHERE.
THE ASSEMBLY IS HAVING TO FIND
THAT APARTMENT FOR SOMETHING AND
WE HAVE A TOTAL BREAKDOWN WERE
NOT ALLOW IT TO HAPPEN UNTIL WE
WILL STAY COMMUNICATIONS SO YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE THAT REGULATOR IS
PART OF. THE YOU KNOW THE THE
SAME DEPARTMENT I DON'T
FACILITY.
pRIGHT AND SO THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO TO MAINTAIN COMMUNICATION AT
WORK MIDDLE CLOSELY WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THEY'RE WITHIN
THE REGULATORY BOUNDARIES.
WELL THAT'S ONE THING THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TO SEE YOU KNOW.
THE PUBLIC LOOKS AT IT AND SAY
SEE YOU CAN REALLY.
HAMMER ON THEM.
AND IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY AND A
VERY HEAVY HANDED WAY THAT I'M.
BEEN DEALING WITH IT WITH ALL OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS ALL THE TIME
THE AGENCY BY AGENCY.
SOME A LITTLE BIT WORSE IN OTHER
LIKE FISH AND WILDLIFE.
BUT THAT SAID THEN THEY LOOK AT
HERE'S A MONUMENTAL FAILURE.
AND AT ENDEMIC FAILURE OVER
DECADES.
AND SO WHAT THE CONSEQUENCE.
AND WHAT DID ANYBODY GET FIRED
DID DID ANYBODY GET. DISCIPLINED
OR.
DEMOTED OR.
DID THE AGENCY SUFFER ANY.
ANY CONSEQUENCE.
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY SOME PUBLIC
ANGER AND LEGISLATIVE ANGERED
YOU'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH PLOT OF
THAT.
BUT.
YEAH WE OF THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE LOOKING AT NEXT WHY
THE OVERSIGHT AS WE DISCUSSED
JUST OVER IMPORTANT.
AND SUFFICE TO SAY IT'S GOT TO
BE BETTER THAN IT HAS BEEN.
THANK.
IT'S FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND IT OULD MAYBE JUST RESPOND
I THINK DOES A GOOD POINT I
MEAN.
YEAH AND I'VE BY THINK IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP A COUPLE TIMES BUT
WHAT HAS HAS THERE BEEN CHANGES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
HILL FROM ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDPOINT OFSAY SEEN THAT HEY
THESE THERE WERE SOME SERIOUS
DEFICIENCIES HERE.
DID YOU GUYS MAKE. INTERNAL
CHANGES ACCORDINGLY I MEAN I'M
TAKE US WHERE THEIR FIRINGS WERE
THEIR REASSIGNMENTS WHERE THERE
CHANGES.
A YOU KNOW.
THE TERMS OF OF OF STRUCTURE AS
A RESULT OF OF THIS.
SO THERE HAVE BEEN CHANGES
STRUCTURALLY.
AYE.
CAN'T COMMENT ON PERSONAL TYPE
ACTIONS IF THEY'RE MORE THE
ADVERSE NATURE. I'M BUT I WILL
SAY SO SOME EXAMPLES OF THAT
OUR.
.
THE. BRINGING TECH CRADDICK INTO
THIS NEW POSITION EXECUTIVE
LEVEL POINT PERSON FOR OR A
FILMY WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
HAS TO BE ONE. PERSON THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS IS THAT PERSON
INFORMATION GOES THROUGH HIM
INFORMATION COMES BACK.
THROUGH HIM SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
INTERNAL TYPE CHANGES WE'VE
MADE.
OTHER CHANGES HAVE BEEN MAYBE
NOT I'D FROM AN ORGANIZATIONAL
STANDPOINT BUT. INCORPORATION OF
YEAR WE TOOK A LOOK AT THE
TWENTY FOUR POTENTIAL FAILURE
MECHANISMS THAT THE FORENSIC
TEAM IDENTIFIED EARLY ON.
WE ADDRESS THOSE
IN THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
OF THE MAIN SPILLWAY SO.
THAT WAS AN IMMEDIATE CHANGE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE
COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS ASSESSMENT I
RECOGNIZE IT'S VERY SPECIFIC AND
AND MORE HAVE YOUNG CONSTRUCTION
IN INCOME AND CONSTRUCTION HANCE
MINTS.
.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE.
M.. ERIC AYE I WILL JUST POINT
OUT IS ARE THE.
NEWEST DEPUTY DIRECTOR WE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO.
.
LOOK AT.
RESTRUCTURING REFOCUSING A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY ON
ELEMENTS LIKE FLOOD MANAGEMENT
IN GENERAL WHICH IS UNDER ERIC'S
PURVIEW I KNOW DS SO DE THERE IS
ALWAYS A FIREWALL BUT THAT WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN. BUT I THINK
JUST IN TERMS OF COMMUNICATIONS
REPORTING WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT HOW.
HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY TO KIND OF
HAVE SOME TRANSPARENCY IF YOU
WILL I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THEM? THEMES WE'VE HEARD OVER
THE LAST.
NO SINCE LAST FEBRUARY IS IS HOW
CAN THE DEPARTMENT BE MORE
TRANSPARENT AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN CHANGES WERE MAKING. SO NOT
WANT.
WE'RE NOT DONE THERE'S A LOT
MORE TO COME I THINK
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FRIENDS
EIGHTEEN REPORT WILL BE AND NEXT
BIG STEP FOR US.
WE HAVE SOME STRIKE TEAMS WE
PUT TOGETHER INTERNALLY TO DEAL
WITH DIFFERENT SPECIFIC ELEMENTS
AROUND THE OROVILLE. FACILITY
WHETHER IT'S THE SPILLWAY
WHETHER AT SOME OF THE
RECREATIONAL.
EARLY IMPLEMENTATION ACTION SO
WERE WERE FOR IDENTIFYING PEOPLE
IN PULLING THOSE TEAMS TOGETHER
TO MOVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND QUICKLY ON SOME
OF THESE ELEMENTS.
AND THERE MIGHT BE MORE BUT I
WAS OF THE ONES THAT. ARE
POPPING UP IN MY HEAD RIGHT AT
THE MOMENT.
THINK YOU'RE A MUCH.
AND THINK TO THIS PANEL IT'S
ALSO BEEN VERY INFORMATIVE AND
WE APPRECIATE IT.
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS SO PEOPLE ONE OF HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY ONE LINE UP ON
THE SIDE OVER HERE AND THEN TAKE
NOT MORE THAN TWO MINUTES TO
EXPRESS YOURSELF.
RON STRUCK FRANCE OF THE RIVER.
WE WERE ONE OF THE OUTSIDE
GROUPS THAT I RAISE THE. ISSUE
OF.
OF THEM.
G. LOGICAL TO POLLUTE STABILITY
OF THE WHOLE SIDE.
.
CLEARLY THIS THIS HAD BEEN A
VERY INFORMATIVE HEARING.
BOTH A MACHETE YOU AS WELL AS
TO MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE.
.
IT ALSO I THINK HIGHLIGHTS THE
INCREDIBLE.
.
TRUST THAT WE HAVE TO PLACE.
OR THAT WE WE. WE'RE WE'RE
FORCED PLACE IN THAT APARTMENT
AND THE DAM SAFETY REGULATORS.
.
BUT EXAMPLE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
HEARD.
THE CONCERNED.
IN DURING THE INCIDENT
THAT IF THERE WAS A FAILURE OF
THE.
ELECTRICAL POWER STANDARD
ELECTRICAL POWER TO THE. US OF
FLOOD CONTROL ADVOCATES. THAT IT
WILL TAKE SEVERAL DAYS TO SOME
ANOTHER GET BACK CONTROL OF THE
KATE'S.
THE.
.
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS MANUAL
CLEARLY STATES FOR OROVILLE
CLEARLY STATES THAT THERE'S.
BACKUP POWER INDEPENDENT POWER.
AT THE DAM THAT IS FULLY CAPABLE
OF OPERATING THE GATES.
.
I SO I ASSUME THAT WAS IN INDEED
IN PLACE I'M SURPRISED HERE
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
OR PERHAPS IT WAS A MISSTATEMENT
BUT THE THE ISSUE.
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND FOR US.
AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT IS.
THAT THAT'S CRITICAL ENERGY.
INFRASTRUCTURE INFORMATION
THAT'S REALLY NOT AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC THE DEPARTMENT
PROBABLY WOULDN'T FEEL.
THAT HE COULD DISCUSS.
ANY DEFICIENCIES THAT IT MIGHT
HAVE IN EMPOWER INDEPENDENT
POWER RELIABLE POWER TO THE
FLOOD CONTROL OUTLETS. AND SO.
AND WE WE IN EFFECT HAVE TO
TRUST THE DEPARTMENT.
AND.
THE FEDERAL REGULATORS.
THAT.
THAT INDEED IS NOT A PROBLEM.
AND WE ALSO HEAR THAT WEALTH OF
THE EMPHASIS HAS BEEN ON.
.
A DEALING WITH ISSUES THAT FAIL
THE DAM.
.
NOT HAVING POWER TO THE FLOOD
CONTROL OUTLETS IS A VERY
SERIOUS DEFICIENCY. AND LET IT
VERY WELL MAY NOT FEEL THE DAM.
LEAST IF THE EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
DOESN'T FAIL.
.
SO.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M FULLY CONFIDENT OR THE
DEPARTMENTS FULLY CONFIDENT
WHERE YOU AND YOUR OVERSIGHT
ROLE.
IS FULLY CONFIDENT THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
REGULATORS REALLY HAFTA.
FIRM HAND ON THIS.
THE.
THE SECOND POINT I WOULD JUST
RAISE.
WHICH IS A POINT I ALWAYS RAISE.
IS.
IT'S GOOD TO HEAR THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS CONSIDERING.
.
ON EMERGENCY SPILLWAY THAT
WON'T THROW LARGE QUANTITIES OF.
A HILLSIDE INTO THE CANYON
BELOW.
BUT AT LEAST AT THIS POINT I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NO PLANS TO DO
THAT.
SO SOME OF THE DEFICIENCIES
THAT YOU SAW SOME OF THE CHAOS.
THAT WAS ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE.
INCIDENT HAS YET TO BE.
FULLY ADDRESSED
AND.
AND I HOPE THE DEPARTMENT DOES
AND HOPE THE REGULATORS.
ADDRESS THAT.
BUT.
FOR AS AN OUTSIDE GROUP OR JUST
AS A MEMBER OF THE INTERESTED
PUBLIC IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US TO ENGAGE.
WE'VE HAD FOR.
FORMAL COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION SINCE THE INCIDENT.
AND THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
CHARGED WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THE FACILITIES ARE ADEQUATE TO
HIS.
YOU KNOW OF SUSTAIN THE
FUNCTIONS THE MISSION OF THE
PROJECT. AND WE'VE YET TO HEAR
ANYTHING BACK FROM THE
COMMISSION.
SO. I HAVE WARY NOW.
QUIT. YOUR ROLE AS A AS A AS A.
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
MANDY BE ERY IMPORTANT SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
AND. IT WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED SUCCESSFULLY AND IN A
WAY THAT INVOLVES.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SO THAT WE
CAN TRUST THAT.
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
REGULATORS ARE DOING THEIR JOB.
SO THAT'S KIND OF MY MY REMARKS
FOR THINK IT'S PREMATURE
THANK YOU.
NEXT PERSON.
CUPID TWO MINUTES YOU CAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE GROUP THANKS IDW ALL
FOR THE GREAT WORK THEY'VE DONE
ON THE SPILLWAY TO THIS PORT.
JOHN FRANK SENIOR TEAM FOR NOT
STANDING REPORT.
SHOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IN US
GOING FORWARD. CONSERVATIVES AND
IDENTIFY YOURSELF JUST I'M
SORRY.
BUT I'M THAT MEN TAKE ON ME.
.
FOR TIME EVACUEE.
AND RESIDENT OF YUBA CITY.
AND EIGHTY SIX A MY FATHER'S
CELL NUMBER MAIL. AND I WAS
INUNDATED THREE TO FOUR FEET OF
WATER
IN WHICH PUT ME OUT OF BUSINESS
FOR SIX MONTHS SANTA DOZENS OF
FAMILIES WITHOUT INCOME FOR THAT
LENGTH OF TIME AS THE MACHINE
RISK COMPLETE STRIPPED DOWN.
PERRANCE MOTORS REPLACED
I FELT THE PAIN OF MISMANAGEMENT
FOR DECADES NOW.
AND I I THINK IT'S NOT WATER AS
MUCH IT IS HUMAN DECISIONS AND I
THINK REPORT JOHN. AND THAT OF
YOUR TEAM CLEARLY POINTED OUT.
THERE'S ONLY A COUPLE TIMES IN
WHICH
GOOD OVERSIGHT IN REGULATION
HAPPENS THAT IS IN THE FIFTY
YEAR RELICENSING OF THE DAM.
AND IN THE FIFTY YEAR WATER
CONTRACTS
THAT HAS NOT BEEN MENTIONED IN
THIS.
BRIEF HISTORY ON THE WATER
CONTRACTS.
WHEN THE OROVILLE DAM WAS BUILT
IT WAS PART OF ONE OF MANY
PROJECTS THE OTHER ONE BE IN THE
NORTH COAST RIVERS.
WHICH WAS TO PROMISE AN
ADDITIONAL WATER THAT WAS NEVER
BUILT.
SO THAT THE WATER THAT WATER
CONTRACTORS GOT FOUR POINT
MILLION ACRE FEET WITH THE CALL
TABLE A WATER NEVER MATERIALIZE
IT CAME TO POINT FOR ANNUAL
DELIVERIES.
THOSE.
TABLE A WATERS HAVE BEEN USES
TRADING CARDS BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES NAMELY IN THE
MONTEREY AGREEMENT WITH THE KERN
COUNTY WATER BANK.
IN WHICH THEY FORFEITED SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
RESOURCES IN THEIR INVESTMENT NO
WATER BANK.
RELEASED A TO PRIVATE HANDS IN
EXCHANGE OF RETIRING TABLE A
WATER.
THIS TABLE EIGHT WATERS BEEN
USES LEVERAGE FOR WATER
DELIVERIES A PRIORITY OF. WATER
AND POWER FIRST OVER DAM SAFETY.
ANOTHER INCIDENTS IN REGARDS TO
THAT WAS MARISCHAL DAM WAS NEVER
BUILT.
ON THE YUBA RIVER WHERE THE
FEATHER IN THE U. BECOMES
TOGETHER BEFORE THE FEATHER
JOINS THE SACKING HAD
SACRAMENTO'S WAY.
THAT WAS TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF FLOOD PROTECTION.
WHEN THAT DAM WAS NEVER BUILT
FOR KONAMI WENT BACK TO DO W. R.
AND SAID THAT YOU NEED TO
PROVIDE ANOTHER HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER.
THAT SCHEME THAT THEY CAME UP
WITH.
PROVIDE THAT HUNDRED HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
WATER. WAS TO ALLOW WHAT THEY
CALL SURCHARGE FLOWS TO GO OVER
THE TOP OF EMERGENCY SPILLWAY.
BURIED IN ALL THAT DATA THAT WE
COULDN'T FIND ALONG WITH.
BORE HOLE DRILLING WAS THEIR OWN
OPERATIONAL MANUAL THAT REQUIRED
THEM TO LOOK RELEASED TEN TO
TWELVE FEET.
OF WATER OVER THE TOP EMERGENCY
SPILLWAY.
WHICH EVERYBODY SAYS THEY NEVER
WANTED TO USE.
THEIR OWN OPERATION MANUAL WAS
COMPROMISE IN DOING SO THEY
COMPROMISED.
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE FLOOD
STORAGE SPACE ON THAT RIVER.
TWENTY PERCENT WOULD HAVE KEPT
THE WATER FROM REACHING THE TOP
THE LEVEES BACK IN EIGHTY SIX
AND NINETY SEVEN. WE WOULD HAVE
HAD THAT THE LEVEE SLUMPING WE
WOULD HAVE HAD.
THE STATE PAYING OUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN DAMAGES IN NINETY
SEVEN.
BECAUSE THEY COMPROMISED FLOOD
PROTECTION FOR THE SAKE OF WATER
DELIVERIES.
I FIND IT.
IRONIC THAT AT THIS MOMENT THAT
YOUR BILL DAM HAPPEN BOTH THOSE
SETS OF REGULATIONS ARE BEFORE
US TODAY.
THE RELICENSING WITH FOR FOR
ANOTHER FIFTY YEARS.
AND.
THE FIFTY YEAR WATER CONTRACTS
WITH THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS.
HIDDEN IN THAT IS. NOT ONLY DO
THEY WANT TO MAINTAIN A FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION ACRE FEET OF
TABLE A WATER THAT IS
UNDELIVERABLE.
BUT THEY ALSO WANT TO SET UP
FINANCIAL COMMITTEE.
THAT GIVES STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS NDW R. EQUAL
REPRESENTATION ON ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON HOW MONEY IN
BUDGETING SHOULD BE DONE.
AND NO WHERE IN THAT.
CLAUSE FOUR FOUR POINT FOUR
POINT FOUR FOUR WITHIN STATE
WATER CONTRACT.
IF I'M NOT IMPACT REPORT THERE'S
GOING TO BE COMING OUT SHORTLY.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC RECORD
CETACEAN ANY PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
OF THE BUDGETING THAT GOES
TOWARDS PUBLIC SAFETY THAT THEY
SAY IS OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
I THINK THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD DO
TWO THINGS.
I THINK YOU SHOULD PUT TOGETHER
A LETTER JUST LIKE A LOT OF THE
LOCAL COALITIONS HAVE. YOUR
REQUEST FOR TO HOLD OFF ON THE
RELICENSING OF OROVILLE DAM.
INTEL THESE ISSUES BROUGHT FORTH
BY JOHNS GREAT TEAM ARE DRESSED
TO THE SATISFACTION OF ALL THE.
MEMBERS THAT HAVE TO LIVE
DOWNSTREAM OF THAT DAMN.
THE SECOND THING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE OUGHT TO DO. IS TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT THE RELICENSING UP
WITH THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
IN TAKE OUT THOSE CLAWS THAT ARE
SELF SERVING.
AND PUT PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST
WITHIN THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTED YOU RELY SINCE IT'S
WELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY AND IN NO. FROM AND CREATE
MANNERS ALRIGHT OF THIS
CONCLUDES THE HEARING AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THEIR TIME THEIR EXPERTISE HOME.
AND AGAIN WE WE TO CENTERS
NIELSEN AND MISTER GALLAGHER.
AGAIN WE WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT
WAS A VERY TRYING TIME FOR YOUR
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND.
IF WE WERE ALL GONNA DO BETTER
GOING FORWARD WE WILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH